- Learn how to create and deploy
a full stack web application
using Svelte, Vercel, and Postgres,
and they'll do it all on your browser.
- Hello and welcome to the
Full Stack Development Course.
My name is Mike Nikles.
I am your instructor for this course,
and I will talk about
myself and my background
in just a little bit.
Before we get to that,
I want to introduce you to the
course, the technology stack,
and a little bit of how we are
going to be developing this.
Now, why do we do a full
stack web development course?
I've been in the industry
for a couple of years.
And one thing I noticed is that
there's a lot of information
online about web development,
different frameworks,
different technology stacks.
There's a lot of information
about backend development,
and there's a lot of
information about how to build
and model your database
and your backend systems.
Now, what I think has been
missing is this entire end-to-end
full stack web development, like what,
how do you connect the
website to the backend?
Like of course there's
REST APIs, there's GraphQL.
There's different ways of communicating
between the frontend and the backend,
you can find that information online.
It's again, like anything
else, a lot of stuff out there,
but how do you really connect
the front end to the backend?
What are some of the best practices,
some gotchas to watch out for?
And the same is true for
the connection between
the server side or the backend
and your database, right?
You could use raw SQL queries,
you could use an object
relational mapping, an ORM,
you could use a NoSQL database
where you persist JSON-like
data or documents.
But again, how exactly
are you going to do that?
And in this course,
I am going to teach
you the full end to end
from building the web application,
connecting it to an API,
and then persisting data in
the backend in a database.
We will be talking about the entire thing,
we will also be deploying that
into a production-like environment,
so that at the end of the course,
you have what it really takes
to start your next project.
Whatever you are going to
build by the end of this course
will be the starting point
for your next project.
So you don't have to build all this,
gluing together by yourself.
Let's talk about where we
are going to develop that.
Most of you are very familiar
with your local development environment,
where you have a bunch of
tools installed, a terminal,
probably, some kind of
command line interface,
and probably some editor
of one sort or another.
In this course,
I'm going to be using
something called Gitpod.io,
Gitpod is providing developer environments
in the cloud for each task
that we're going to work on.
So imagine instead of, you know,
curating and maintaining
our local environment,
where we install certain versions
of Node or Java, what we
get is a new environment,
always cleaned from scratch,
automatically set up for each
task we're going to work on.
We will get into that in
more detail as the course
progresses, and I will
introduce this as we go.
One thing to keep in
mind is if you do prefer
your local environment,
that's perfectly fine.
You can follow along with everything we do
by using your local environment.
There's no problem with that.
Let's talk about the technologies.
You can see on the screen, on the website,
we will be using a
framework called Svelte.
Svelte is currently in version three.
It's been stable for a while,
and it's used in production
by a number of big companies,
the API slash backend,
and also the hosting a
framework for Svelte itself
will be SvelteKit.
SvelteKit as you can tell by the name
is developed by the same team.
And very recently, the
founder and creator of Svelte,
Rich Harris announced that he
is joining Vercel full-time
so Svelte is now backed by a
large player in the industry
who really cares about
making the web faster.
Lastly, we need some kind of database.
In this course, we're
going to use Postgres.
We will be talking about other
databases at the very end
when we talk about next
steps, and you know,
this is a stack that I chose
because I'm very familiar with it,
and I think it is future proof in terms
of what you learned and what
you can apply at your work
or in your next, you
know, free time project.
over the next few years.
Lastly, we will be using
two deployment platforms,
one is Vercel, we will deploy
the SvelteKit application
to ourself and serve our
web application from there,
and secondly, we really use
something called Railway,
a hosting provider where
we will be hosting Postgres
and you'll see how easy it is
to set up a Postgres database
on Railway connect with
SvelteKit in Vercel
and get everything up and running.
That is a very high level
overview of what are we going to
be talking about and how are
we going to be developing this.
Let me also give you a
little bit of background
about myself so that you have an idea
of what I'm talking about
and why I do have the
experience to teach this course
and help you with your next
full-stack application.
So I have been a web developer since 2000,
so it's been a couple of
years and the web has gone
through a number of transitions.
You know, things like jQuery.
Well, first of all, PHP
and jQuery came out,
a whole bunch of different
things happened since then.
React is very big, lots
of people using that.
And then I started using Svelte
about two and a half years ago
when it was at version two.
And I've advocated for it
ever since, and, you know,
with the recent announcement
of Vercel backing Svelte,
I think this is a really strong framework
to use for a course like that.
Now at the moment, I'm a
developer advocate at Gitpod,
and that's obviously why
we will be using Gitpod
for this course, and I will
be introducing the concept,
as I mentioned before, it's not mandatory
to use it, but it is
there to give you an idea
of what the future of
development looks like.
You can find me on my
blog at mikeNikles.com.
This is where I share, you know,
any of the open source
project I launch or release.
You can go there and have a look.
There's a bunch of Svelte related content.
There is React related
content from the past.
So go check that out
if you're curious about what I talk.
Next, you can find me
on Twitter @MikeNikles,
same handle as my website URL.
And this is where you get
to see my daily thoughts.
It's usually about full stack development.
It's about mentoring.
I talk a lot about career growth.
I wrote a book about that as well,
giving you tips and tricks
on how to manage your career
in the software industry, so yeah,
do check it out on Twitter,
definitely lots to share there.
And a couple notes on my previous life
before I joined Gitpod,
I spent a few years at
Google where I helped
enterprise customers
migrate their workloads
from on-premise to the
cloud and, you know,
kind of help them with the
migration and digital innovation
as we went through that,
I spent a few years at Mobify,
a company now acquired by Salesforce,
where we built mobile
friendly e-commerce sites
on top of a desktop application.
So imagine the desktop site
that wasn't mobile friendly
Mobify would kick in
at run time and convert
that entire website
into a mobile friendly UI and
learned a lot about, you know,
monkey patching, all sorts of
things when I was at Mobify.
Prior to that, I did a couple of years
at Layer 7, that was an APA
gateway security company.
My role there was to train
and teach the product
to customers of Layer 7.
So as you can see, I've
been around for awhile.
I've had different hats around
my own business for awhile,
and now I'm here teaching
the full stack web development course.
And with that, let's get started.
All right let's have a look at
what you will learn in this course.
A couple of things I
already talked about, Svelte
on the front end,
SvelteKit to build the API
and host the web application,
Postgres for the database
Vercel to serve the website and the API
and the Railway to host
the Postgres database.
I talked about that before
so no change on that.
In addition to all that,
we will look at TypeScript.
So the reason that we're
going to use TypeScript
is because I want to show
you a fully typed environment
where we actually can use TypeScript
and autocomplete for our database model.
So if we have a database
model called todo-item,
and that has a number of columns,
we can then use that
autocomplete in TypeScript
to access the values in these calls.
This is all possible because
of Prisma, a tool that we are
going to use in order
to generate these types
based on a database schema.
Now, Prisma will also help
us to run all the SQL queries
and abstract all that from us.
So even though we are using
SQL database, Postgres,
we have not actually going
to write any SQL queries.
It's really beautiful, you're
gonna absolutely love it,
I can promise you.
There will be an interface generated
or a client generated by Prisma,
where we can just use it with TypeScript,
call functions on it,
and it will fetch data
from the database, do all the SQL queries,
conversions and all for us.
The last thing we're going
to dive in is NPM scripts.
You may have heard of tooling like gulp
or other tools that help you glue together
your development environment
and start, you know,
dev servers and watch for file
changes and things like that.
We will simplify that
in my personal opinion,
by using NPM scripts and
basically have all the scripts
that we need in order
to test, deploy and
develop the application.
This will all be part of
NPM scripts inside package,
JSON file at the root of our project.
This is at the high level,
what are we going to learn.
You do not have to be an expert
or even the beginning any of that,
all you need to know is
basic JavaScript skills.
The rest I will teach you as we go through
and as it becomes necessary.
So don't expect to be a TypeScript expert
by the end of this course, however,
if you have never heard of
TypeScript or have never used it,
you will be just fine
going through this course.
And I will guide you and
teach you everything you need
to know in order to develop this project.
The same is true for
any of the other technologies
that we are going to be using.
Fantastic, with that, this
gives you a good overview
of what we're going to be learning.
Now let's move on and look at
how we're going to build
our developer environment.
There's one more thing
I want to talk about.
And you also noticed that
I have slowly disappeared
from the screen.
That's just so that we get
the full real estate here
to focus on the course.
And I will be back later to
show you a few more things.
Now, what I want to talk about
is one more thing that we are
going to learn that is called
Gitpod, now with Gitpod,
you can spin up fresh
automated developer environment
for each task in the cloud in seconds.
Now that's a fancy way of saying
that instead of using your
local development environment,
what you get is a new
developer environment,
fully automated for
every task we are going
to be working on.
You will see how this works
as soon as we start coding very shortly.
But for now, I just want
you to be aware of this.
And as I mentioned just a little
while ago, you don't need to use it,
but if you do want to
see what it looks like
and how it works, definitely give it a go.
You get 50 hours for free per month.
So plenty of free time
to actually get through
that entire course together with me here.
So with that in mind, check out
Gitpod.io if you're curious,
otherwise let's quickly move on and get
into the project overview and discuss
what application we are
actually going to develop.
Okay, now, today we talked
about what do we will learn,
let's have a look at the UI of the project
that we are going to develop.
You can see where you're going
to build a todo application,
and I'll explain in just
a second why we focus on
the todo application.
The UI you see here is developed
by the Svelte team, and
you get that out of the box
if you create a new Svelte application
that uses the default template.
Now, why are we copying
something that already exists?
Because this course is about
full stack web development.
So I don't want to spend
time building the UI,
and instead we will use something existing
and we'll spend the time
in the course, focusing
on deploying, gluing the things together,
writing scripts and automating
a lot of the process
for the deployment of the
full stack application.
What did you want to talk about
though focusing on the why
we chose a todo application.
And the reason for that is very simple.
A todo application gives
us everything you need
in order to build your own project
once you're done with this course.
To get started, we have
to create todo-items.
So we can tap here to add a new item.
They will teach us how to
send new data to the backend
from where we will persist
it in the database.
You'll always need that functionality,
no matter what application you build.
Secondly we will learn how to read
the items that we created.
So that teaches kind of the opposite way.
We're going to go to the database
and ask for information that
will be sent to the backend,
and from there to our
front end application.
Next, we will learn how
to update an existing item
by checking it off or marking it as done.
That will teach us how to
go to the database and edit
or update an existing item
that's already persisted.
And lastly, we will learn over here,
how we delete an item from the database.
If you take the initial letters
of create, read, update, and delete.
You, get the acronym CRUD
that you may have heard of
or read about before CRUD is
the foundation that you need
for any project that you
will be working on in future.
So if you know how to do that as part
of a very simple todo application,
you can apply that exact same concept to
your next billion dollar idea
that you will be developing.
With that out of the way,
I want to move on and
give you an introduction
to the architecture of the
entire end-to-end stack
so that we can see how the front end,
the API and the database all
communicate with each other.
Now that we've seen the UI
of the todo application,
I want to talk about the
end-to-end architecture.
What is this going to look
like once it's all deployed
onto Vercel and Railway?
The very first thing we will be working
on is the front end, we
were going to build that UI.
It will not do anything when
we click on any buttons,
but at least we will
build the user interface
with all the different
states and all that,
so that the real focus after
that can be on the rest of
the architecture, all the stuff
that's white at the moment.
So let's have a look at
what we are going to build.
As I mentioned, we will be using Svelte
for the front end to develop
that web application.
Now, in order to serve the web application
to our users, we have
to host it somewhere.
And the hosting for the
web application will happen
on Vercel and we will be using SvelteKit.
They have to same logo, but
Svelte on the front end,
SvelteKit on Vercel to
host the application.
Also in Vercel, in SvelteKit on Vercel,
we will have the APIs
exposed for the front end.
So if we look at that,
we will have the frontend make
API requests to a REST API
hosted on Vercel, in
SvelteKit for example,
to fetch all todos.
So a get request slash todos
and then the SvelteKit API
will return a JSON object
with the list of the todo-items
that you can see in the UI.
We saw that just a few minutes ago.
In order for SvelteKit
to return that JSON,
we need to fetch it from the database.
So let's have a look
at how this looks like.
Somewhere we'll have to
write select star from todos,
sent that query to the Postgres database
that is deployed on Railway.
The Postgres database will
return the SQL response
that contains the rows from the database
for all these items that are persisted.
And then it will be sent to SvelteKit
and returned to the Svelte application
in the browser, from
where we can then render
the JSON and display this beautiful list.
You notice there's a missing piece.
And that missing piece is Prisma,
a library we are going to be using
that helps us translate from the requests
that we get in get todos,
we will be able to just
call a few functions,
telling Prisma to go get our todos
and Prisma will take
care of writing the SQL
or generating the SQL that
will be sent to Postgres.
Equally, when the response
from Postgres comes back onto Vercel,
Prisma will be the first point of contact
to take that raw SQL response,
convert it into JavaScript objects
that we can then turn into JSON responses
that are being sent back to the browser.
So Svelte on the front end,
sending an API request to
SvelteKit from where we use
Prisma in order to send a
request to the Postgres database.
On the way back when
the response comes back,
Prisma converts the SQL
response to JavaScript objects,
SvelteKit creates the response
for the browser, sends it back,
and the browser displays the
todo-items that we fetched
in the first place, a very
standard three tier application.
And this is exactly what we're
going to build as part of
this course, so let's move on
and get started with coding.
Okay, let's get started
with the initialization
of our application.
First things first,
we need to create a Git repository
somewhere so we can host
to code start creating pull requests.
You can do that on
Bitbucket, Gitlab or GitHub.
I choose GitHub here,
but this works with any other
hosting provider as well.
So at the top right,
I'll start by clicking
the plus new repository.
I want this to be part of Gitpod-IO,
full-stack-web-development,
that's the repository name.
I want to make it public, so
you all have access to it.
And you can look at the source
code and follow along as well
as I want to add a read me
file just so that we have some
content in the repository
when we get started.
Let's create a repository
and that only takes a couple seconds.
Now we've got this all
set up and we are ready
to initialize our SvelteKit
application so that we can
then build the front end
and eventually deploy
that application to Vercel.
The first thing you notice on my screen
is that I have a green Gitpod button
that I added here as a browser extension.
If you're interested in following along,
and I recommend you to just
experience what it is like
to develop your application in the cloud
and access it through a
browser, you can install that
Gitpod button by opening a
new tab and Gitpod.io/docs
and search for browser extension
and the References browser extension.
You can click the Chrome link
if you're on a Chromium based
browser or Firefox if you use Firefox,
I believe there's a safari extension
as well that you can find as well.
So once installed, then you
will see that green button,
if you don't want to install
that for some reason,
you can achieve the same
behavior as the button does
by going to your URL in the address bar
and prefix the URL with Gitpod.io/hash
that's Gitpod.io/hash,
that works for GitHub, Gitlab
or Bitbucket repository URLs.
When you hit enter, that
will start a Gitpod workspace
for that specific URL that you provide.
The only difference between
using the URL and using the button,
is that the URL navigates away
from your repository page.
Whereas the button over here
create a new environment
and opens a new browser tab
and then starts to workspace there.
So I prefer the button
just many for that reason.
And also it's easier
than changing the URL.
Before we do any work,
we don't want to work on the main branch.
So let's quickly create an issue
so that we can do our work
in the feature branch,
and then merge that branch
back into the main branch
when we are ready for that.
Let's call it initialize the application.
We submit that.
And now we are looking at
an issue and we still have
to GitPod button, so at
the same concept applies
prefix the URL Gitpod.io/hash
or install the browser extension.
We're going to click the button here.
You see it opens a new tab.
It creates a developer
environment from scratch,
and that's every time we
do any work on an issue,
we use a brand new environment
and we will later automate
this so that it will
download dependencies,
start the dev server, start the database,
it will all do all that for us.
So we don't have to do
any of that manually.
So that's a pretty good start.
What we're looking at here is VS Code
accessed through a browser,
but also we have access to the terminal.
So if we go to the hamburger menu,
terminal, and new terminal,
what do you see down here is just
a Ubuntu based operating system
where we can run commands
that you can run locally as well.
And we can use to have just
as a local environment.
By the way, if you prefer to
work on your local computer,
then you can certainly
clone the repository
and follow along locally.
The alternative is that
you could still leverage
the high powered computers that you get
through Gitpod, but use your
local VS Code, so again,
through the menu at the
bottom here, you could say,
GitPod open in VS Code or
GitPod opening VS Code insiders,
depending on which version
of VS Code you have installed
on your local computer.
What that does is it will
basically start up VS Code
on your local computer and
connect to the GitPod environment
in the cloud.
So you would leverage CPU and
memory and hard disk space
provided by Gitpod,
but access it through your
local VS Code instance
if you prefer to do that.
In my case, I prefer the
browser because you know,
it's simply opening a tab,
but you can use any of
these ways to follow along
with the tutorial, there's
no much difference.
All right, we have a
repository with a read me file
that has no content basically.
What we want to do next is create
the SvelteKit application
so that we can initialize
that application,
commit and close that issue.
In order to do that, let's go over
to the documentation for SvelteKit.
So kit.Svelte.dev
that's kit.Svelte.dev, hit enter.
And on that page, there's a
bunch of good information.
The docs are very valuable,
but what we care about at the
moment is how to get started.
NPM init, Svelte dot next
and the name of our application.
In our case, we already
have an application created
when we created the Git repository.
So let's just copy the first
part npm_init_svelt@next,
we copied that part, and in our terminal,
in the terminal, we can paste that.
And then we can just instruct
the command line interface
to use the current directory
instead of giving it a application name.
If we give it a name, it would
create a directory for that.
But we are already
in the full stack web
development directory.
So npm init svelte@next .
It's asking if we want to
install that package, we say yes,
that was a very quick,
downloaded a few things.
And now it is telling us
that this is beta software,
expect bugs and missing features,
that's just a warning as well.
SvelteKit is used in production
at numerous companies,
including Gitpod's marketing website.
So this is not really a concern.
Just something to be aware
of that there may be breaking
changes, but the documentation
is extremely well done.
And it tells you how to migrate
if there's something breaking.
The next thing we noticed is
that the directory is not empty
that's because we already
have a read me file.
In our case, we can safely say yes,
that we want to continue,
so we press the Y.
And now it's asking us
which Svelte app template.
You have two choices here.
We can choose the SvelteKit demo app,
which gives you three pages.
And one of the pages is
the todo application that
we are going to build.
The other alternative is skeleton project.
That's what we are going to use
because the skeleton project
gives you a very bare minimum foundation,
very little configuration,
very little code exists.
And that's really the best
way for us to go through
the entire full stack web
development from the beginning,
building the web
application and documenting
or talking about every single line of code
that we we're going to write.
So by the end of it,
you fully understand
why the code is there,
what it does, and what its impact is
to the overall application.
So which Svelte app template?
Let's choose skeleton
project for this question.
The next question is, do
we want to use TypeScript?
The answer is yes,
that will help us when we
start to introduce Prisma
as well as when we work with
the code in our application.
So let's say yes for the question,
whether to use TypeScript
and then yes lint for code linting.
We're going to say no, that's,
you know, either way works,
but for the purpose of this
course, we're going to say no.
And Prettier for code formatting.
I highly recommend you
do that in your project.
Once you went through the
course and do more familiar
with the full stack web
application development,
in the case here,
we are not going to configure
this as part of the course.
So we are going to say, add
Prettier for code formatting.
No.
There we go, a updated read me file.
So we can close that tab.
The other thing we notice
is that it gives us some next steps.
The first is NPM install
to get all the dependencies
and run all the scripts, so let's do that.
NPM install in the command line
that downloads a few
necessary dependencies,
such as Svelte and SvelteKit,
and the other step was to git init.
We don't need to do that
because we already have
a git repository and
git add, and git commit,
we will do later in a
slightly different way
than using the command line interface.
What we do want to do too is NPM run dev,
that will start our development server,
and we can have a quick look
at what we get to start with.
So let's run that, NPM run dev
it starts the server on
localhost port 3000 and GitPod,
notice that there's no
service running on that port,
so it prompts us to open a
preview or open a browser.
If I click open a preview,
you can see that the
simple browser pops up
right within my editor so
that I can review the code
of my application right here.
The alternative is if we go to the footer
and we click on port 3000,
you can see it switched
to the remote explorer tab
on the left side.
Port 3000 has an option
in the middle to open
the preview again, same as before,
or on the right side,
If we press the globe,
we can open a browser
which opens a new tab.
And now we can inspect
that web application
just the way we would do
an old local computer.
Okay, that's a pretty good start.
I think we satisfied the
requirement of the first issue,
which was to initialize the application.
What are we going to do
now is commit these changes
merge it into the main branch.
And then we will follow up
and go through the folders and
directories that exist in here
created by the init script
when we created the application earlier,
so that you understand all
these files and what they do.
All right, in order to commit
and push these changes,
we can use the source
control tab on the left.
If you're familiar with
the command line interface,
we can control C in the
terminal, cancel the server,
and you can use the git
commands right here.
That works as well.
Let's use the UI for now.
So we have to give it a commit message.
We're going to call this
initialize the application,
and we can click the button
with the check mark up here to commit.
Alternatively, with
the text field focused,
you could do command enter
or control enter depending
on your operating system
and get the same result, but
click the button for now.
It is asking us that or telling
us that there are no stage
changes, that's because we
didn't stage any of that.
And it offers us to
automatically do that for us,
and then commit the files in
this case, we're going to say,
yes, that's what we want.
Take all these files and commit them.
Wonderful.
We have it committed, we have
not pushed it to GitHub yet,
so we could press the publish
changes button right here.
And then we can go to GitHub,
create the new pull request,
and merge that into the main branch.
The alternative and I believe faster way
is to use that icon next
to the commit, the one here
that says create pull request.
If we do that, you can see that
it automatically creates
a pull request for us.
One thing we want to do is update the name
of the title that defaults
to the name of my branch,
and that we'll talk about
the branch in just a second
for now, let's change the title
to something more readable
I need a description,
I like to say which issue we are closing.
In this case, it's number one.
If you don't remember which
issue you're working on,
you can always look in the footer
where you have a branch
name with your user name
slash the name of the issue
dash the number of the issue.
So if we look at the issue
here, it is initialized
the application number one,
the branch name is the same.
Now you remember,
I never actually created a new Git branch.
All I did was I started to
Gitpod developer environment
from that issue by
clicking the Gitpod button.
So Gitpod is all about
automating your developer
environment and making
you more productive.
Now it knows that in 99% of the time,
when you open a Gitpod developer
environment from an issue,
you're probably going
to work on that feature
and you want to eventually
create a pull request
to merge back into the main branch.
So GitPod is smart enough to just create
that branch for you with a
sensible default, in this case,
it's user name slash issue
dot title dash a number.
We don't have to do that
any time by ourselves.
It's just done for us.
So if you don't remember
what issue number you're
working on, check the footer.
Next up, we can create the pull request.
And it's telling us that
there's no upstream branch
for that name, that's fine.
Please publish it for us automatically.
We can say publish branch
that pushes the branch,
creates a pull request in GitHub.
And you can see now we have a preview here
of what that PR looks like,
and we could even merge
it right away from here.
What I want to do instead is go back
to GitHub and show you what it did for us.
It created a pull request,
it linked it to our issue
number one, because I said
close issue number one.
If you go to the PR, see
this closed issue number one.
That's how GitHub knew
that they are connected.
And usually we would ask a
colleague to go and review that.
We will do that by ourselves
in just a little bit.
For now, we can safely go in here and say
that we would like to
merge that pull request.
So we say merge, and we confirm.
Now that merged the PR,
you can see it's merged.
We don't need the branch anymore.
And if we go back to
issues our issue got closed
because the application
is now initialized.
We still have that
environment running here.
And what do we want to do with that?
If you work locally, then you
would keep that environment,
you would switch back to the main branch,
pull down the latest
changes we just merged.
And then when you work on the next issue,
you would create a new
issue, create a new branch.
You know, start working
and do that over again.
With Gitpod because we
get a new environment
for every task we work on,
we can either just close the browser tab
and that environment will
automatically shut down
a few minutes later.
Or we can explicitly go
to the hamburger menu
and say, Gitpod, stop workspace.
And then it starts to shut down
and it will eventually disappear.
We no longer need that, we
never have to come back to it.
If for some reason you
do want to get back to an old environment,
you can always go to Gitpod.io/workspaces,
and you will get access to
that or click open workspace
from this tab, which would
open it again if you needed to.
The dashboard will show you a
list of existing workspaces.
As I said, there's very few reasons
where you really want to go back.
We are done with that, so
we close the browser tab.
We don't need the documentation either.
Goodbye.
All right, back to the main page,
we now have our application initialized.
So let's dive in and learn
about each of these files,
what's important and how
we can work with these
files to build our application.
Fantastic work.
We already merged our
very first pull request.
There's a few more to go
until we have a end-to-end
full-stack web application.
Before we do any more coding though,
I want to go through and make
sure you fully understand
what the different files
and directories are
within our project.
If you are already familiar
with a SvelteKit application,
then feel free to fast
forward 10, 15 minutes or so
to go to the next section
where we will continue with the coding.
If this is the first time you hear
about SvelteKit, I highly
recommend you follow along
and learn about the configuration
files, the NPM script,
and the source code so
that you later understand
where each file is and what they do,
and what's their purpose.
So we could review the
files and code right here.
I think a VS Code environment
is a bit more familiar
for most people, so let
me start a new workspace
on Gitpod, straight on the main branch.
And use to walk you through
and explain the different
files and directories.
Okay, that should only
take another second.
We don't need to get started
page, let's have a look, so
the arguably most important
file in this entire application
is the package.JSON file.
If we open that up,
you can see that it has a name of version
and that's a good start,
you can start tweaking that as you go.
Now, the other thing to
look at is the dependencies.
The first thing you notice is that
it only has a dev dependencies.
So when you build a Svelte application
or in this case SvelteKit application,
then Svelte itself is
not really a framework
that needs to be part of
your production dependencies.
In fact svelte is a compiler
that converts or compiles our Svelte files
into pure JavaScript that can be deployed
to the browser where the
browser then just parses that.
So it's very little overhead.
And the performance
therefore is quite good
on the browser side,
because there's a lot
less code to download,
a lot less JavaScript
to parse and execute.
So because of that, you notice
that the Svelte dependency,
as well as the Svelte JS
slash kit dependency for our
application framework, they
are both dev dependencies.
The other dev dependencies
you notice is Svelte-check
pre-process, we'll look at all that later.
What we also want to
look at is the scripts.
There are a number of interesting scripts
that need to be talked
about, the first one is dev.
If you're going to run that
out would be NPM run dev,
we saw that a few minutes ago,
it uses a binary called SvelteKit
that's provided by our
SvelteJS/Kit dependency.
SvelteKit takes a number of arguments.
If you pass in dev,
it starts a local development server
that also provides hot module reloading.
So we can make code changes
and we see the changes in the browser
without the need to
refresh the application.
The next script that's defined is build.
Because Svelte is a compiler,
before we can deploy the application.
We have to run the build script,
which goes through our entire application,
compiles all the files
and generates an output into
a directory here as well,
the root, we will see that later.
That directory will then
be consumed by adapters.,
we will talk about that
when we get to deploy
the application, but basically
it's an intermediary format
of JavaScript files and
other files needed to deploy.
So the build step
compiles the application,
creates that output,
and then we'll skip on,
and we look at preview.
Preview allows us to start a local preview
based on the generated
output from the build script.
So if you run NPM run build,
and then NPM run preview,
you get a preview of your
application the way it will look
in production, so no hot module reloading,
no development server running.
This is really much
more closely reflecting
what the production environment
is going to look like.
There's two more scripts I
want to quickly talk about,
this is check.
So check allows us to use a package
or a binary called Svelte-check.
This is very handy because
it's kind of like ESLingt,
which checks your JavaScript
code, Svelte-check
reviews your Svelte files and
gives you a warning or hints
if certain things are missing.
For example, if you have
accessibility issues
in your website, such
as missing attributes
for accessibility on
your images or buttons,
the Svelte-check binary
will tell us about that
and give us the output in the console
so we can then address
it and make sure that the
applications we build are
of the highest quality.
Check:watch is basically the same thing,
but it runs continuously.
So while we're making code changes,
if we run that in the terminal,
it will continue to output
any potential errors,
and we can fix that while we're
working on the application.
The package script that we
skipped so far is really
something more advanced
that we don't really need
to worry about right now.
But if you were to develop a library
that you want to publish to NPM,
you could use to packet script
to help you with that process.
For the time being, we can
safely ignore that and move on.
So that makes up the
content of the package JSON.
The next thing that's important
is the Svelte config file.
If we look at that,
you can see that there's a
couple of things going on.
The first is the config
options that we export
contain a pre-process property.
And this basically just informs
the Svelte compiler how
to prepare the code.
So if we were to use SASS
or other features in our CSS, for example,
we could configure that here
and the Svelte compiler would
take that into account
when it processes the code.
The other important property is kit.
And one thing you notice
is there's an adapter
defined at the moment.
This is using an auto
adapter provided by SvelteJS.
So later we will replace
that with a Vercel adapter
so that we can deploy to Vercel.
If we were to deploy to
Netlify or CloudFlare workers,
we could install the appropriate adapter,
replace that line, and
we would be good to go.
We will do that later in the course.
The next thing is a target.
And you can see the comment.
This is telling the application
where to render the Svelte app.
It's similar to what you
might be might have seen
in other application frameworks,
where you have a difficult
root, with an id root.
So it is under source app HTML.
There is a if with an ID Svelte,
this is where the content
of our Svelte files
will be rendered into.
Let's have a look at
that src/app.html next.
So source, app.html.
This is the entry point
where we can specify HTML,
all the attributes we need there.
We can specify the head, the body,
anything that is shared
across the entire application.
It's a good place to
define common meta tags
that do not change like, you know,
the charset put in the favicon,
viewport things, all that.
Later, we will learn how
we can populate the head
with additional information,
for example, the page title,
which changes depending
on the page we are on.
And also down here,
we see that div with id Svelte
where eventually the Svelte
application will be rendered
into either server side,
if we do a server side
rendering or on the client,
when somebody navigates
from one page to another.
Okay, the next important directory
is under source and it's called routes.
And within that,
we have a file currently
called index.Svelte.
If we open that up,
you can see there's an H1 element
with a welcome to SvelteKit
content, as well as a paragraph
that says, visit some link
to read the documentation.
That code is what's eventually added
into that Svelte body here.
So if we were to quickly
go to the hamburger menu,
terminal open a new terminal.
And we run NPM run dev,
remember that starts
our development server.
And oh, of course, that doesn't work.
We have to first NPM install.
We didn't have any dependencies installed.
And with the dependencies installed,
now we can run NPM run dev.
And that spins up port 3000
Gitpod tells us about that.
We can preview, see, this is
the code I was talking
about in the routes.
So if we make this,
we can see there's a div
ID Svelte H1 in paragraph,
which maps to, what we have
here, H1 and paragraph.
Alright, we will add some
syntax highlighting to that file
very shortly, for the time
being, the VS Code that we are
using here, doesn't have the
Svelte extension installed,
and that's why we don't see anything yet,
but that's an easy fix
we'll do in a few minutes.
Good, so let's get rid of this
and close all these terminals.
Good.
The other thing I want to briefly touch on
is the tsconfig.json.
Because we select the
TypeScript as a framework
that we're going to use
to build this application,
SvelteKit automatically created
that configuration file for us,
and it has all the things we
need for this application.
So there's no need to understand
each of these properties
and configuration values,
if you are curious,
the TypeScript documentation
contains notes about
each one of those you can
mouse over and then just click
the link to the docs, but as I said,
there is no need to understand
what is going on here.
It is safe to assume that
the Svelte developer team
made a good decision here on the defaults.
So we can trust them,
that they did the right thing for us.
Good, that concludes the
introduction to the files.
So you know, it's very basic for now.
Really, all we need to know at
the moment is source routes,
index is our index page in the URL.
If we were to create a about us page
or any other route, then Svelte
uses a file based routing.
So if we do routes new file,
and we say about-us.Svelte,
and then here, we would
have an H1 called about us.
And if we were to go and
start to dev server again
through the terminal and NPM run dev,
if we go back to the tab that
we had opened previously,
we can now go to the URL
and do slash about-us.
And then we see the content
of the about us page.
So this is how you can
create multiple pages.
In our case, all we're going to do is use
that index page to build our application,
but it's good to know how you
can extend your application
to add additional content.
Fantastic, so this is
all we want to talk about
for the time being.
Let's now go on and
continue with the setup
of our developer environment
and this environment here,
we just use that for a showcase purposes.
So even though I have changed
files here, I can just say,
go to the menu here and
say, Gitpod, stop workspace.
And I don't have to worry
about these changes.
They will never interfere with
my new environment that I'm
going to create to work on
as my part of the next task.
So we did that, we can close the tab.
We also don't need this anymore.
And we are back to the GitHub repository.
So with that, let's swiftly move on.
The next section of this course
is only for people who follow along
using Gitpod, the automated
developer environment.
So if you prefer to work
on your local computer
and don't want to experience
the way it works on Gitpod,
then feel free to jump
down to the description and
click ahead to the next section.
For anybody who does
want to work on Gitpod
and do remember you get 50
hours for free every month.
So that's a good
opportunity to play around,
get an idea of how this
way of working helps you
and makes you more productive.
What are we going to do now
is configure Gitpod so that
when we start a new developer
environment for this project,
we want to Gitpod to run certain commands
automatically for us.
We also want to configure the
VS Code in order to make sure
everybody who works on this project
has the same VS Code extension,
so everybody gets a great
experience out of the box
and if they want to, they
can install other extensions
that they personally prefer.
But at least there's a
base set up that makes
for a great experience for
everybody who uses that project.
So let's go ahead and configure
the Gitpod environment.
We have an issue created already
called configure Gitpod.
If we open that up and
as we did before we click
the Gitpod button to spin
up a new environment.
That takes a couple
seconds just to pull down
the necessary container
image and start the IDE.
There we go.
Now in order to configure
Gitpod, we have two options.
One, we can go to Gitpod.io/new.
If we go there, we can
create a new project.
We can select the organization
or account, and then our repository,
and then follow along the instructions
on the screen to configure the project.
Now I prefer to add a configuration file
to my source code so
that the configuration
of the developer environment
is also part of the revision history
so we can see what changed
and when did it change
and maybe also the reasons
behind some of the changes.
So the way we can do that
is we can create a new
file at the project route.
So if we right click into
the black area around here,
we say new file.
The file name we want
to create is .Gitpod.yml
which stands for YAML, GitPod.yml
And within the file here,
we have certain properties
that we have to define
in order for Gitpod to pick that up.
What we can do is we can do autocomplete
with control space,
and it gives us a number
of top level properties
that we can specify.
Now, if we don't know what
they do, the easiest way
to learn about that is to jump over
to the docs on Gitpod.io/docs.
And on the left side,
if we go to references,
they say .Gitpod.yml reference,
and you can see that all the options,
including sub properties are defined
and well-documented in here.
So if you get stuck or if you're
not sure what to configure,
this is your go-to place
for the configuration file.
Now for us,
I'll walk you through the key things
that we need to make sure are configured.
When we start a new workspace,
you saw it a few minutes ago,
we have to run NPM install,
and then we have to run NPM run dev,
and we have to do that every time we start
a new workspace just like
in your local environment,
you have to start a dev server
every time you work on your project.
Now with Gitpod, we can automate that.
So there's something
called a tasks property.
And as you saw, if I use
auto complete for that,
tasks, it automatically gives me a dash.
And then it lets me type something here.
So again, if we use auto-complete
at that level, it gives me a few options.
So what do we want to do for now,
we'll look at other ones later,
but for now we need an init
task, so we can say init.
And init is something that runs every time
somebody pushes code to
the GitHub repository.
Imagine your colleague,
they merge a pull request
into domain branch, and
as soon as that happens,
something called GitPod prebuild kicks in.
So GitHub notifies
Gitpod about the change,
and then Gitpod kicks off
a prebuild where it looks
for to GitPod YAML file and
automatically execute whatever
commands we specify within the init tasks.
So in our case,
we want to always download
and install to dependencies
for our project, as soon
as somebody changes code.
So we can see NPM install
for the init task.
Now there's one more thing we
want to add to that same task.
So remember one dash equals to one task.
The other thing we want to
add is a command right here,
the command executes when
somebody starts a workspace.
So at this time,
NPR install already executed
on the Gitpod server
at some point before
somebody starts to workspace.
So what do we want to do
every time somebody opens
one of these workspaces?
We want to start the
development server, NPM run dev.
So with that, we can
now open the workspace.
Anytime we open a new workspace,
the server will already be started for us,
and we are ready to
start writing some code.
And before we go any further,
let's validate that these changes
do what we expect them to do.
The way to test that is to
keep this developer environment,
so if we look at the URL,
we are currently on an
environment called copper-thrush,
we want to keep that,
and we want to start a second environment
where we are going to test these changes.
So the way we can do that
is in source control,
we can add a comment here
to commit the tasks that we configured.
So add init and command tasks.
We can commit, then we say, yeah,
please do a stage and commit that.
And we create a pull
request remember, right next
to the check mark, we can
say create pull request,
and that's eventually we will want to call
this pull request, add
Gitpod configuration.
And we want to close issue number three.
Remember down at the bottom,
you can see in the branch name,
which issue number we're working on.
For now, we are not done
with that pull request,
we want to do more work,
but we want to just test these
two tasks, these two lines.
So let's make it a draft so
that everybody else on the team
knows we're working on it.
Yep, same message.
We don't have an upstream branch,
please publish that for us.
All right, we don't want
to run that, all good.
Ignore that error, that's not relevant.
Okay, now going back here, we
do have a new pull request.
Add Gitpod configuration.
Here, we can see that
we added these two tasks
to the GitPod YAML file.
Now in order to test that new file
that we created, we can go
to the conversation tab.
And what we can do is start
a second Gitpod workspace.
Again, remember the
URL starts with copper,
and if we open a new one,
it is now ember-dragonfly.
That developer environment
here is completely separate
from the one we have in
the other browser tab.
The differences that the
amber-dragonfly Gitpod environment
uses the new configuration file
that we added to the branch.
So look at that, there's
some stuff from VS Code.
We see that a service is
available on port 3000
and in the terminal we
noticed that our application
is already running on port 3000.
That is pretty incredible
because we didn't actually
do anything, we just automated at once,
and now everybody who uses this project
in a Gitpod environment gets
all of that automatically.
So what is the next thing
every developer is going
to do when they work on this project?
Everyone who works on that and
wants to make a code change
wants to validate their changes.
So the very next step
literally everybody would do
is open that preview URL of
our development environment.
So wouldn't it be nice if we
could automate that as well?
Yeah, you guessed, right,
we can definitely do that.
The way we do it is that the
environment we just tested,
whether the application
starts up, amber-dragonfly,
we can close that we no longer need it
because we already tested
and validated the changes
to the Gitpod YAML file.
So hamburger menu, Gitpod stop workspace.
We're going to throw that
away, never needed again.
Now back here in the copper
environment or our developer
environment where you can
clean some stuff up and back in
the tasks, we can now add
something else at the top level,
which is called ports.
And we know that our server
starts on port 3000 right,
in order to preview the web application.
So we can say, Hey, Gitpod,
if you see a service
listening on port 3000,
then do something for
us, now we don't need
the visibility private
that's the default behavior
if we don't configure it,
so it will leave that out.
But what we do want is control space.,
and then we want to configure the onopen.
Onopen, you can mouse over and
get more details about that.
But this is basically
when Gitpod recognizes
a service listening on
the configured port,
and then it will do something for us.
So we have a few options here.
We can ignore it, this
is helpful for, you know,
a database service or something that runs
to use a hot module, reloading.
Ports like that we don't care about,
we can simply ignore them.
Notify is the default
behavior that pops up
that little box at the
bottom here we saw before,
where we can open in
preview or open in browser.
And we have these two options
as a default here as well.
So in our case,
we want to open a browser
window automatically
so that we don't have to click that link
in the terminal, let's do that.
There we go.
That is now going to
open a new browser tab
with the preview automatically.
So let's have a look.
We're going to go back
to our source control.
Quickly double-check, we
added a ports, all right,
so let's commit that saying
configure port 3000 behavior.
Yep.
Same thing.
This time around, we
already have a pull request,
so we don't have to create another one.
All we can do is just use these three dots
or click the sync changes, either way.
Three dots and push or sync changes.
And this will say, yup,
yup, it will pull and
push all the changes.
Go for it.
Fabulous.
We're moving back to the pull
request where we now have
that configure port 3000
behavior as a new commit message.
In order to test that and make sure
that the developer environment
does open a new tab,
same as before, we
click the Gitpod button,
open a new environment,
and you can see there's
a prebuild in progress.
That is because my environment
is already configured.
So prebuild means it is
running the init script
that we configured into GitPod YAML file.
That happens only once,
we were just too quick,
that hasn't finished, that's
why we saw it in the URL
on the UI, but there we go,
now it starts coral-llama environment.
Again that's the third
developer environment
and it also opens a tab for our preview.
That's pretty cool, it
doesn't ask us anymore
whether we want to open a
preview or open a browser
for this port.
That's the VS Code pop
up, we can just say no.
Get rid of that.
Okay.
That's pretty cool, now let's have a look.
If we go to the preview
environment and we inspect
the website, you can
see vite connecting...
And if we wait a couple of seconds,
it will try to reconnect again.
What's happening here is
that SvelteKit under the hood
uses what's called vite.
And that provides a hot
module reloading functionality
that we want to leverage.
Now, unfortunately by default,
the vite server runs on
port 3000, localhost:3000.
The problem we have is
that our web address
is a public URL on a Gitpod.io subdomain.
So you noticed that was a reload
and it didn't actually
successfully connect.
That's not a big deal.
We can configure vite in
order to do the right thing,
it keeps doing that reloading
here until we configure it.
So we are running on an HTTPS URL
that is this super long URL here
and no port, which means
HTTPS default port is 443.
So what we need to do is we need
to somehow configure
SvelteKit to use this URL,
to connect to the hot
module reloading server,
instead of using
localhost 3000 by default.
Let's have a look and how we can do that.
First we are going to stop the server
and what are we going to do next
is we're going to close
or actually keep the same
environment here, remember
the old one we had,
where we configured the tasks
and then we pushed it to GitHub?
That environment is something
we could keep working on,
but it doesn't really make much
sense because it's outdated
by now, we started up
the new environment based
on the new configuration.
So we can basically just stop this,
stop this environment now
and no longer worry about it.
We'll shut that down.
Close the browser tab.
Now we are working on that
pull request that we opened up.
Okay, so we stopped the server down here.
And the next thing is in
the Svelte config file,
we can come in here and down in the,
in the kit configuration,
we can add a new value.
So what do we want to do here is vite
and then it's called server, you can see,
we get nice autocomplete for everything.
And then the property is HMR
for hot module reloading.
There's two properties we want to set.
The first is client port, as I mentioned,
the default is 3000 and the
other one we want to set
is the host.
And again, by default, this is localhost.
The question is, how do we
change this port to 443,
and this host to whatever
URL we have here?
That URL changes for each environment,
so we need to find a
way to dynamically load
the URL and configure
the Svelte environment.
So luckily the Gitpod environment provides
a command line interface that's called GP.
So if we open the terminal
a bit bigger here,
I can show you how this looks.
Let's clear this.
If we type gp url, that gives us the URL
of our environment, matches
the URL up here, right?
However, our URL has the port in front.
So gp url accepts an argument,
if we pass the port number at the end
and we hit enter again,
it gives us the preview URL of
that port that we specified.
And this is the URL that we
want to specify for the host,
and then port 443.
We could somehow try to hard-code that,
but not everybody uses Gitpod yet.
So we have to also make sure
localhosts 3000 is configured
for people who work on
their local computer still.
Let's have a look, how we can do that.
The easiest way is to use
an environment variable
where we specify whether
we run on Gitpod or not.
So the place to do that is
in the Gitpod YAML file,
what we can do here is in the command.
So when the new development
environment starts up,
we want to run that gp url 3000 command
and save the results, that URL
in an environment variable.
That means if somebody
starts the environment
in their local computer,
none of the code in the
Gitpod YAML executes
because they use a local environment,
they don't get the benefits
of this automation,
which then means the environment
variable that we're about
to set does not exist on the
localhost, let's have a look
how this looks like.
So here we want to do export,
let's call it HMR_HOST
and that equals, and then
two back ticks, gp url 3000.
And then start the dev server.
Now, HMR host after this line
looks equals to this entire URL, HTTPS,
blah, blah, blah.
So let's have a look.
We can take that HMR host
and in the Svelte config,
since this is just a regular
JavaScript that executes,
we can use the process.env for
all the environment variables
and have a look at
whether HMR host exists.
So we can just do a shorthand,
which means if that URL exists
then process env host,
otherwise localhost.
So that means we can now run
this script either locally
without Gitpod or on Gitpod.
And the host is always set correctly.
One small tweak we need
to do is that the HMR host
is including the HTTPS
or the protocol as well.
vite doesn't like that.
It just wants to host
because it uses web sockets.
So it will then change HTTPS
to web socket protocol.
So we can use JavaScript here
to basically just substring the HTTPS://
So we'll do sub string
and HTTPS:// .length.
This will get rid of that of that part.
What I mean is .length in here,
so that it counts the character here,
and then start from the
beginning of that URL gets starts
at this point here, and it
takes 3000 and the rest.
The other thing we want to
do is if we have the HMR host
variable set right here,
then the port is 443.
Otherwise the port is 3000.
So this work around here
in the Svelte config,
let's make this a bit
bigger, get rid of that.
The few lines here that'd
be added as a workaround
allow us to run the HMR hot
module reloading on Gitpod,
and also make sure that people
can still run the project
locally and also get the
benefits of hot module reloading.
So there's quite a few changes.
It's definitely a good time to go
and test that in a new
environment, before we do that,
you can imagine that if we have more
than two commands, like
even now we have this one
and this one, if we had two
or three other commands,
this will start to get
really hard to read.
So there's a little bit of
a better way to write that.
If we add a pipe here and
we moved that to a new line
with two spaces indented,
remove the end, make a new line,
we can now add as many commands here.
Starting dev server.
So we can add as many, and they
all run one after the other.
So it's a bit easier to read
and definitely easier to
maintain as we go forward.
We don't need the echo, so
we can get rid of that line.
But now we want to go and test
this in a new environment.
So let's go to the source
control and commit these changes,
configure HMR, oops
on Gitpod and localhost.
Alright, commit these changes.
We can close that preview.
We no longer need this or
browser tab, get rid of that.
And we want to sync the changes.
Here, we'll push, all right, go for it.
I can probably stop showing
that from popping up.
Nice.
Heading back to the pull request.
We have a new entry.
That's the changes we just made
in order to spin up an
environment on these changes.
You know how this works by
now, click the GitPod button.
It spins up a new developer environment
that now contains that HMR
host environment variable.
So let's have a look at what happens.
It's good practice that you always keep
at least one environment
running here in case, you know,
something went wrong
with your configuration,
or you run into some issues
with the changes you made,
but just good practice
to keep that around.
There we go, look at that,
we got the new browser tab.
We saw that before, if
we inspect this now,
then we can see that vite is now connected
to the development server.
So once we go back and we
start making code changes
to that Svelte file, as
soon as we save to changes,
that page will reload and
display the updated code.
So that's nice, now we know
that our new environment,
which is now beige-condor,
we know this works and the configuration
that we made in the
previous one was correct.
So at this point,
it is safe to come in here
and close that environment.
So hamburger menu, Gitpod stop workspace.
That's going to shut down, eventually.
There we go, and we close it.
Okay, very nice.
So we now have HMR running,
hot module reloading works.
We have a bunch of automation
to install dependency,
start a dev server.
And what do we want to do next
is, let's look at the source
roots, index.Svelte.
This is not ideal.
Not having any syntax
highlighting makes it really hard
to move along and start writing code.
The solution for that is to install
the Svelte VS Code extension,
which is going to help
us with autocomplete,
it's going to help by the way that syntax
and all that kind of stuff.
The way to do it is just
like you're used to,
extensions over here.
And then we can look at the recommended
it already suggests that we
install Svelte for VS Code.
So if we click on that,
usually you would click
the install button,
but that installs it only for yourself,
and if you have other team members,
you want them to have the
same experience and you want
the extension to be
installed for them as well.
So the way you can do that is if you look
at that page on Gitpod,
click the little settings icon
here to manage the extension.
And then there's a menu item called
add to Gitpod YAML file.
And we click that.
Then we can close the extension view here,
switch back to the files, or the explorer.
And now we can see that the file changed.
So let's look at that
and see what we find.
There is a new section that it
was added, VS Code extensions
and then the ID of the
VS Code Svelte extension
that basically just tells
Gitpod that every time somebody
starts a workspace, to also install
whatever extensions are listed here,
you could add another dash
below and add additional
extensions that are
needed for your project.
One thing we do notice
is that it's underlined.
So there's something wrong with it.
And that's expected
because if we mouse over,
you can see that the
extension is not installed.
We only added it to that file
so that the next time
we start the workspace,
the extension will be
automatically installed.
Now we have an option here
to say quick fix and fix that for us.
So if we do what we can say,
install the Svelte extension,
or we could start another workspace.
And then the Svelte extension
will be automatically installed for us.
So for now I'm going to opt out
to just ignore that morning.
And then when you start
the next workspace,
you will see how the extension
is automatically added
for us, and we don't have to do anything.
Now there's one more thing I want
to configure while we're here.
But before we do that, let's
quickly make a commit here
at the Svelte VS Code extension.
Okay.
Quickly commit that because
it's a unique change we made.
So the last thing we want to configure
in the Gitpod.yml file at
the route is the prebuild.
So let me show you for GitHub,
we can say that GitHub prebuild
and we can give it a couple of settings.
So the first thing we want to do
is every time our main branch changes,
we want to automatically
run the init script.
So in order to do that we use master
and then the value for that is true.
The other thing we want to run a prebuild
is every time somebody creates a branch,
irregardless of whether there
is a pull request or not,
but we basically want to
also run the init script
on branches so that if somebody
was to preview a branch
without having a pull request,
they would get the same benefits
of having NPM install already executed.
So the way we do that is we
can just say branches true.
And lastly, we want the same
experience for pull requests.
So pull requests, true.
Again, if you want to see what
other options are available,
head over to Gitpod.io/docs,
references, Gitpod YAML
and then you can jump down here
to the prebuild and see
what else is available.
So let me just add that to the top here.
Hold on.
See this URL.
Let me just see, I think my
syntax is wrong for comments
in YAML, there we go.
It's a hash, not slash slash.
So comment easily to find
that, we know about that, good.
So this is a good place
to check that in as well.
And now Gitpod that will
automatically run a init script.
If for some reason, you know,
you don't configure that prebuild setup,
then what happens is when somebody starts
workspace they would have to wait
for the init script to complete.
So it would just run as part
of each workspace startup,
but you definitely want to enable prebuild
because they will then
automatically run, you know,
well before somebody
starts a Gitpod workspace.
And it will run every time
the code changes on GitHub.
Okay, configure Gitpod prebuilds,
gonna push that as well.
And we have two commits, we
want to push that to GitHub
and make sure everything's
showing up, yep, it's right here.
So with that, we could quickly
go and have a review refresh,
see our latest changes.
So we configured in init
task that runs NPM install,
that happens automatically
every time somebody pushes code
to GitHub, the command
exports the dynamic URL
for our development environment URL.
And then we start the server.
If we see something on port 3000,
which is our web application,
then open a browser.
We also install the Svelte extension
for better syntax support
in these Svelte files,
as well as we configure prebuild
so that they run whenever
there is new branches or pull requests
or changes to the main branch.
Lastly, we updated the Svelte config.
We created a vite configuration
where we specified a client
port and host for hot module reloading
so that this works on Gitpod,
as well as on localhost.
This looks pretty good.
We can now go and ready for review,
ask somebody to review that for us,
and then go ahead and
merge the pull request.
We don't need to branch,
and we also don't need that
environment any longer.
So we can close that and
close to preview as well
And the docs.
Good with that, we now
have a fully configured
Gitpod developer environment
that installs everything we need,
runs all the scripts we need as well.
And we can move on with
the next few tasks.
And we want to do next is
build the HTML structure
of the application.
So we've got an issue open already
called develop HTML structure,
before we get to that,
let's have a quick look again at the UI.
So what are we going to
build is just heading
the form fields, the lines for
the individual items, no CSS,
no functionality, we'll do
everything at one step at a time.
So stay tuned for more afterwards,
but for now, just the
bare bones HTML structure.
In order to do that, we got an issue.
So we're going to start working on that.
And we learn about Svelte,
we learn about different ways
of using Svelte's functionality,
so that if you're familiar with
another framework, you can,
maybe map the concepts between
the two frameworks you know
Svelte and whatever you're
familiar with already.
Okay, we have everything
set up, that looks good.
Our environment looks okay.
And the first things first,
that page here is our index page.
We want to change the title
so that it says todos,
and start adding the HTML structure.
Under source roots, we
have the index Svelte file.
And you can see now that we
have syntax highlighting, that's
because we configured that
in the Gitpod YAML file.
We said, please automatically
install the Svelte extension.
So back in the index file,
we don't need the paragraph,
that is not needed.
The H1 is just saying todos for now,
so that it maps the todos we have here.
Now below the todos,
what do we want to do is create
that + tap to add a todo.
That's really a input field of type text
that's wrapped in an HTML
form so that we can submit
that eventually to a backend where we can
then process it and
persist in the database.
So in terms of HTML structure
for that first part of the user interface,
we really just want to add a form,
so we can use the form autocomplete here.
It asks us to provide an action.
We'll leave that empty for now.
We also leave the method
empty that you can see us
has some options, we'll
work on that when we start
to build the functionality
of the application
to actually add and update items.
So it's a form, and within the form,
we want to add an input field
of type text, because we will be adding
the text of our todo into that field.
We also want to give it a name,
we'll need that in order to identify
that text input in the request
later when we submit it.
So let's stick to text, we
could name that anything,
that's up to you, text
for now does the job.
We also want to add an aria label
so that screen readers announced
this input field and people
who use a screen reader
understand what this is for.
So in this case, it's add a todo.
And lastly, we want to add a placeholder.
And if we look at the mock-ups,
the placeholder we want to add is that
+ tap to add a todo.
So we'll do that, + type to add a todo
And we close that.
So that's, you know, basically
giving us the initial setup.
If we look at the preview, you can see
we have an input field
with the placeholder.
It doesn't quite look
like the mock-up yet,
but we'll get to that a little bit later
when we apply CSS to the application.
Let's have a look at
the mock-up what's next.
We're going to have a
dynamic number of todo-items.
We don't really know how many,
and that obviously changes when
we add and delete the items.
So we'll have to somehow find a way to
show this list dynamically.
For now, as I said, we
care about the structure,
so there needs to be some
kind of check mark here,
some kind of text, now, also,
when you click on one of those texts,
we want to convert it into a text field
so that we can type and
update, the element, todo-item,
and also some button
here to remove the item.
So that sounds to me like
123 different HTML forms
so that, you know, when you click this,
we can submit the request to the backend
and check if that's done,
same for the delete button,
remove it, let's start, have
a look at what it looks like.
The elements are below
the create a todo form.
So we could come here and start
writing the HTML structure.
Instead, I think this is a
good time to introduce you
to Svelte components, just
like any other framework,
you can organize your code by
writing multiple components.
The way it works in Svelte,
and especially in
conjunction with a SvelteKit,
is that under source,
we can create a new directory
and let's call this lib
a new folder, lib, and within
lib, we create a new file
and we call this todo-item.Svelte.
And here we are going to
focus on one line item.
And then once we built that,
I will show you how we
can include it in the UI.
Very straightforward.
The first thing we'd like to do is
most likely at some
point we'll have to style
that entire row, so for
example, when it's checked off,
you can see there some
opacity happening here
on the entire element.
So it's probably a good
start to just wrap everything
in a div here.
And then the first thing
is that a check mark here.
So that's a form with some value inside.
We can then submit later,
so let's add a form,
no action for now, no
method for now, either.
And then we'll add an input.
The input will contain the
value of the todo-item,
whether it's marked as done or not,
but we don't really want to
show an input field for that.
We could use a checkbox potentially,
and you know, style that
to make it look like a,
make it look like a circle.
For now, what we can do is
just make a hidden input field.
We can say type hidden and
give that a name as well.
In this case, we call it
done and then a value.
For now, we don't know
whether it's checked or not.
So we'll just leave it empty until we get
to the point where we start
to style the application.
The next thing is we need a button
for that circle with a check box.
So let's add a button here,
the value for the button
for the time being anyway
is that we can just call it Done/NotDone.
Eventually we'll change
that and use some CSS
to make this better, but
that does the job for now.
We also want to make sure
the screen readers announce
this button properly, so
we say mark done/not done.
Then people know what's going on.
Once we start adding
functionality and we know
which todo-item in particular,
that we are entering,
we will be able to
dynamically update this text
to show the correct aria label,
whether to mark an item
as done or not done.
For now, we don't know that,
so we'll make it more generic,
and also that reminds us later
that we have to update this.
Okay, that is the form for this check box.
Next we need to work on
that text that's shown here.
That's exactly the same
concept so we can type form.
We don't know the action yet,
we don't know the method yet either.
What we do know is that we want
an input field of type text,
and we don't know the value at
this point, so just add that.
And the other thing we want
to do is, you don't see it
in the mock-ups, but when
we click on that to edit it,
we want to show a little save icon
right here next to the delete.
This will help visually tell people
that they have to click
that button or hit enter,
but it's not obvious that
enter is going to save it.
So we'll show a little icon here.
For now, we'll add a button to
just have a placeholder there
and then deal with that later.
So the button will
eventually be the save button
and as well here, we want an
aria label called save todo
that marks the second form
and the last form over here
is the one to delete an item.
Same concept, again, we can probably start
copy pasting some stuff here.
So well, one day form, and
we want to close that again.
Action method, we don't know.
What we do know is that
we'll want the button here.
That again for now, just says Delete.
Once we use CSS,
it will be a nice trashcan
and aria label to tell the
screen readers that this
is to delete a todo.
Very good, that gives us the
forms we need for that element.
Now in the UI, we don't
see any of that yet.
So what we have to do is
switch over back to our
source, routes, index.Svelte.
And we have to import that component,
that todo-item component we created,
the way to do that in
Svelte is very interesting
and also extremely handy.
So what do you see right now is pure HTML,
this is no JSX, no, you know,
library on top of HTML
or anything like that.
It's just HTML the way to
browse that or understands HTML.
In order to import a component in Svelte,
you can add your scripts
that are needed on this route
or in this component particular
right to the same file.
So at the top, it doesn't have
to be at the top, by the way,
it could be below as well,
but I prefer it at the top.
You can add a script tag, that's
a regular HTML script tag.
And within that, we can
say import todo-items.
This is going to be the name
of our todo-item component.
And where do we want to input it from?
One directory up, we are in routes,
so one up and then lib, todo-item.
That imports the todo-item,
now it's not used,
so it get a little notification here,
but we can come down here
and say todo-item, render one of them.
We go back, you can now see that
besides the input field to add a new one,
we also have the Done/NotDone button,
the input field to edit one,
save and delete, not pretty,
but it's all the HTML that we need
in order to render an item.
As you can imagine, adding three of them
renders three todo-item lines.
So I'm going to show you one more thing.
If we were to move things around,
such as let's say, we
moved out todo application
into like sub folders
or change things around.
What we would have to do is go
and update the relative path
that is used in our input statement here.
So in SvelteKit,
there is a convention where
if we want to access anything
in the lib directory,
we can just remove the relative path
and use the dollar sign.
So a $lib, that automatically points
to the source lib, you can see
that up here in the tool tip.
It points to the source
lib todo-item as well.
So it automatically replaces that.
Now we can move that input
statement anywhere in our code,
and it will automatically
resolve to the correct endpoint
or directory here in the file system.
So that's a neat little trick to help us
load that todo-item.
There's one more thing we want to do
while we're working on the HTML structure.
It's setting a title for the application.
At the moment, if we inspect
that and we go to the head,
you can see that there
there's some meta tags.
They come from our source/app.html.
There's some scripts, some
styles, but there's no title.
So remember if we go to src/app.html
there's the meta tags I just showed you.
There's no title, we could add one here,
but then it would be the same title
for the entire application.
So in order to populate
that dynamically created Svelte head,
what we can do in our index
file somewhere up here is
use a special component
called Svelte colon,
and you can see there's a few of them.
The one we care about right
now is head, we use that.
We can now put any HTML
elements that are valid
within the head inside of here and Svelte
will dynamically populate that
when the different pages load.
So the element we want to add is title,
and we want to call it todos.
Now you notice that it already reloaded,
hot module reloading kicked in,
and the title now says todos.
And if we update that and we save,
then it immediately updates as well.
So that's nice,
but let's make an agreement that the title
should always reflect whatever
the H1 element is here.
Okay, so that the H1 on the page
maps to the title in the browser window,
that's happening right now
because we wrote todos twice.
Fair enough, but if we were
to change that todos title here,
we would have to remember
to also change it here.
So I'll show you how you
can use the variables
in Svelte and reference
them within the HTML.
Let's create a variable called title.
And the name for that
is order value is todo
by the way that name, variable
name could be anything.
It could be page, title
whatever you want it to be.
In order to use it in your HTML,
we can select these two
with command D or control D
to have multiple cursors, so
we delete the hard-coded texts.
We use opening curly
brackets, variable name,
closing curly brackets.
And now you can see
the todo here and here,
is still the same.
If we were to make a change,
then the browser updates,
as well as the todo-item here.
So this is how you can use variables
within your HTML in a Svelte component.
So we'll keep it like that,
that's probably a good start.
And it's a good reference as well
if you want to update that later.
Excellent, I think this is a good spot
to declare that issue as complete.
We did develop the HTML
structure, that is all in place.
Now this goes back to todo,
and we can go ahead and
commit these changes.
I personally like to
do a quick self review
before I commit it so that, you know,
at least I had another look
at my code before I push it,
make sure there's nothing obviously wrong
that would just stand out.
And then here, we want to call this,
use the same develop HTML structure,
commit that, yep.
And we can go ahead and write
from here, create a pull request.
We don't need, quick update that a bit,
structure, and we want to
close issue number five,
and we don't need to make it
a draft, we are ready to go.
So create published branch
that will do the work for us, there we go.
We are ready for somebody
to review that for us.
What we did was we updated the index file
by setting a title,
using the Svelte head to modify the HTML
used within the head tag.
And then we created a form
for the creation of new todo-items.
And we render a Svelte component
called todo-item that we
import from the $lib slash todo-item
$lib is a naming convention
that's configured
within SvelteKit to
automatically point to src/lib.
This is our Svelte component
for a todo-item, three forms.
First one to mark an
items done and not done,
save todo and delete.
So this looks very good.
We can commit that and then
move on and start to apply
just a bit of CSS to make
it more look like this
so that this is a bit easier to work with
as we progress and start
to add functionality.
All right, we go and merge
that pull request and delete the branch.
And as we were used to,
we don't need our preview,
we can close that.
The same is true for our
developer environment.
We don't need that either, we
are done so we throw it away.
There we go.
And that's merged.
Issues are gone and we are ready to go
and work on the next step.
Okay, with all the HTML elements
in place, we are now going to add CSS
so that the web application
looks like the mock-ups.
If you remember,
this is the end result of
what we want to achieve
and let's get started with that.
So we have an issue, apply CSS styles,
where we can start a developer environment
and continue with our work.
What are we going to learn here is
how to apply styles in Svelte components.
There's a few options, different ways.
We'll talk about that.
And basically the end result is we want
to turn what do we currently have here,
the unstyled todo application,
we want to turn that into what we see
right here in the mock-up.
Okay, switching over to
our developer environment.
We don't need any of these
things at the moment, the server
is already running, so we'll
just keep that up and running.
Maybe the first thing we can do is inspect
the web application so that
we can then look at CSS,
different styles and keep
an eye on what's happening.
So with that,
let's get started and apply
CSS to this application.
The first thing I want to
show you is how we can use
regular CSS files to style the application
and use the styles that we add
across the entire application
so that we can put
certain default behavior in
place that applies to the entire
application where like we
define style attributes
such as the font family or primary colors
and things like that.
So we want to do this by
creating a CSS file under source.
So let's say source and then new file,
and we'll call this app.CSS.
Okay, this is a regular CSS,
there's nothing fancy about this.
The first thing we can do is
turn that white background
that we currently have into
more of this gradient approach
that you see in the mock-up.
The way to do that is
we target the body element
of the web application.
And for now we can just say
the background color equals to
a hash value is so B9C6D2,
that could be, you know,
whatever you need for
your environment later.
So with that,
it's still white because we
haven't actually loaded that CSS
file, the app.css is an
arbitrary name that I chose.
You could name this
file anything you like.
So before we go any further,
let's just make sure the changes we apply
are actually visible in
the developer environment.
So in our case, we have a
source roots index file.
And in this file,
what we can do is import the
CSS file that we just created
a little while ago, so
if we go to the script,
this is where we import the todo component
as you remember, we can
also import the CSS file,
which lives two directories up.
And there is the, oops, my apologies,
it's one directory up and app.CSS.
So with that, if we switch
back to the todo application,
we now have the grayish background.
So that's one way to load the CSS file,
now, one thing I want to show you is
if we were to add a second route,
so under source routes, new file,
we call this about us just as a test
and within the about us file, we create
the header for now that we
see, we changed the URL.
If I were to switch to about us,
it did not apply that change
to the CSS background here.
And that's because as you
can guess in the index file,
we import a file, we
don't do that in about us.
I could create a script
tag and import the CSS file
as well, but that would
not be very scalable.
So instead there is a
special file we can create
at any level within the roots tree.
So if there were subdirectories,
we could create more of these files
and the file is called __layout
So we within SRC/roots, __layout
that Svelte this file
contains code that applies
to all the routes within the
directory where it's defined
as well as all sub-directories below that.
So what we can do here is we can
import that CSS file at the layout level,
which then applies to about
us and index and anything else
within that directory
or its sub-directories.
So going back here,
let's remove the CSS
import from the index file.
And in the layout,
we are going to create a script tag
and import that CSS from here.
If we go back to the user interface,
we noticed that the about us
page now shows the background,
but it doesn't show the title anymore.
And the same is true on the
index page, completely empty,
but the background is there.
So we need to render the content
of whichever page we are on,
whether we were on the route page
or on the about us page.
We need to tell Svelte to
render the content dynamically
depending on the URL.
And the way we can do that
in the layout component
is by using what is called a slot.
So S-L-O-T as a component
and now Svelte dynamically
replaces line number five
with the content of either the index file
or the about us page,
depending on the URL we are on.
If we switched back, we
have our style todos back
and on the about us
page, we have the title.
All right, that is a
good place to keep that.
If we wanted to add additional
HTML into the layout file
that applies to the other
files in the routes,
we could do things like
wrap the slot in the main
HTML element, and maybe
below we could add a footer
where we say copyright,
something like that.
And then in the UI, the, if we were to,
if we were to save that
and then go back to the UI,
we would now have the
copyright here, the footer,
as well as on the index
page copyright as well.
Okay, that gives you a good
idea of how you can extend the
application and share some
code across multiple routes.
As always the Svelte
documentation at Svelte.dev c
ontains a lot more information
about the feature of slots
and how you can use them
in your own components
to nest certain functionality,
as well as how you pass prompts
from the parent component
to the slot and vice versa.
For the time being we
don't really have a footer,
so let's get rid of that.
We also don't have an about us page,
so we will drop that as well,
but we will keep the main and
the slots so that we can use
our CSS file back on the index page.
Good, so we know we no longer need that
and we don't need this index
file at the moment either.
Good, so this is a good place to be,
to understand how we can load the CSS.
Now, what do we want to do
is apply a few more things
to the website in terms of
styling, we're not quite done.
We are actually far from
done, so back in the CSS file,
what we can do is first
of all, this color is our primary color
that we want to use
across the application.
So in order to not have
to repeat that hex value,
we can use is pseudo element route.
And then we can specify
a CSS property here called --primary-color
and use that hex value
that we have down here
to define the primary color value.
And now anywhere in our CSS, we can,
instead of copying that hex
we can just use the
primary color variable.
So we'll do var and we use primary color,
autocomplete makes that super easy.
So in order to create the
gradient that you see here,
we need at least one more
color so that we can specify
the gradient from this point to this point
in terms of the colors.
But we are going to add two more,
just so that we have three
colors, so secondary color,
and the value for that is D0DDE9.
Again, these are just values
I took from the example,
but you can use your own brand colors.
And lastly, the third one, tertiary color,
and for that, we used
the hash EDF0F8, nice.
So this is not really a CSS tutorial,
but just make sure the
application looks all right,
we'll apply a background and
we can use the linear gradient
for that, and just add a few values here.
So we wanna rotate by 180 degrees
and then use the three
colors that we defined
to specify how will we are styling this.
So let's have a look here, and secondary.
And the last one, there we go.
Now, if we go back,
we have the gradient that you can see.
The problem is that it happens
kind of three times, two and a half times.
And the reason for that is that our body
is not really spanning the
entire height of the window.
So we can fix that fairly
easily by updating our body
definition and add a min height
of 100 view point height.
And now if we look at
that we get that gradient
across the three colors, nicely applied.
The other thing I want to do is see
that marching on the left here?
I want to take full control over that
and not let the browser interfere.
So one workaround for that is
to just basically set a margin
of zero at this level so that we can use
our own margins eventually to apply here.
Now you see there's aligned
all the way to the left.
Good, so this app.css file
is a good place to define
all sorts of global CSS properties.
One more thing we could do is,
all of that doesn't make
too much of a difference,
but just want to show you
in case you have your own
custom fonts, so we could
specify the font family here,
and I don't know, pick
one or use your own.
If you have your own font that applies
as well to everything.
Good, one other thing we
want to do if we look at
this page versus the mock-up,
the todo text is centered,
and we can just agree now
that this is a design decision
that we want to apply
to all the H1 elements
across the entire project,
once we add more pages,
we want the same behavior.
So again the app CSS is a
fantastic place to configure that.
We can say H1 and text align
and then make this center
as well as just specify a
font size of, let's say 2rem.
This then applies a cross the board
and makes all our pages
look the same, exactly same.
And just because we are here,
if you wanted to apply a
media query or really any CSS,
because that's just a regular CSS file,
there's no special use case or anything.
We can use media queries as well,
if we were inclined to do so.
For example, we can change,
if we had a min width of,
let's say 720 pixels,
we can apply a different
font size, for example,
for the H1, as you know,
something for you to work with.
So anything you can do
in CSS, you can do here.
It applies to the todo-item depending
on the media query that applies.
Okay with that, we learned
how we can apply CSS
across the board.
Now for the styling of
the actual todo app here,
so the different rows,
the opacity here, the
margins, all these things.
That is CSS that we don't want to apply
to all the pages, right?
The todo application may live on one URL
maybe slash todo or something like that,
and we only want this CSS to
impact that one component,
which also means that
the browser doesn't have
to download that CSS for every
page the user navigates to.
We only want the browser to download
that check mark, for example,
when a user actually looks
at the todo application, so with Svelte,
the way we can do that is
straight in a Svelte component,
we can write CSS and make sure
that this applies only there.
So let's have a look at the
index file under source route.
So we don't need the
global CSS file anymore,
but under source, roots,
index.Svelte, we can,
besides the script and the
HTML, we can add one more thing.
And that is a style tag.
So a regular HTML style element,
and within this, we can use CSS to target
our element within that component.
For example, if I were to
target a form like this
in regular CSS, if it's
in the app.CSS file,
anything I put in here into
that definition would apply
across the board, across
the entire application.
Because I'm specifying this style element
within my component or my route
here, anything I put here,
even though I use form
like this as an element,
it only applies to that
form within the component.
So any CSS is locally
scoped to the component,
which makes it very easy to
reason about what happens
if I change anything in
this form definition,
it will not impact anything
outside the component.
Super easy to make changes down the road
without worrying that, you know,
you accidentally may have
broken the form layout
on a different page or a
different part of the application.
Now we are not gonna
target the form like this,
but I wanted to show you how this works.
What we are going to do
though is basically wrapped
the entire application in a div
just so that we can target
it and apply things like
centering of the element
and things like that.
So let's first create that div here
and then move our entire
application inside of that div
so same code as before, but
wrapped in a div element.
Now let's give that a
class, so class todos.
And now within the style
element that we defined here,
we can target that
todos div and apply CSS.
The few things we want
to do here is we want
to specify a with of 100%.
We also want to limit the maximum width
in case somebody has
an ultra wide monitor.
We don't want this to stretch all the way
from the left to the right.
So let's set a max with of 42rem
because you know why not 42?
And let's put a margin around of
something like that to center it.
And with that we can switch back
and you can now see that
there's a much bigger margin.
And if we inspect that
part of the application
where we have our todos,
you notice that there's no
margin at the top left and right.
And if I was to change the size,
this moves along and the
margin adjusts accordingly.
Okay.
One thing you do notice
is that Svelte created
its own S dash class name.
This is just so that we
Svelte can uniquely target
that element with CSS so that
nothing we have to worry about
it just happens under the hood for us.
All right, the next thing we
want to do while we're here
is we want to target that
new input field here.
And as you see in the mock-up,
it doesn't really have a background, so,
or a border or things like that.
So let's go back and
define the dot new class.
And right now, Svelte is telling us that
there's an unused CSS selector.
And that's because we
specified a dot new class here,
but we actually didn't use
it anywhere in the HTML.
There's no new class anywhere applied.
So this is a nice feature
of the Svelte compiler
telling us that, Hey, you
have this element here,
but it's not used so you
may as well delete it
and save the browser from
downloading a few bytes
by not having this definition.
So that will come in handy,
you'll see the benefits of that
once you start refactoring
your application,
you may move, let's say
that form somewhere else
and forget to include the CSS.
Then you will get that warning
and you can move to CSS along
with the form so that everything
continues to look the way
you want it to look.
So what do we want to do
for the input field here
is first of all, just add
a bit of a margin here.
They are a bit too close together,
and that's easily done by first of all,
going to our input field
for the new todo-item.
And we have that wrapped within a form.
So we can target that form
either with just form,
or I like to be a bit more specific
and do use a class name, and call it new.
And now we still have an error,
but it's only telling
us that please don't use
empty rule sets, it recognized
that we have a class with new
so that warning is gone.
And then what we want to
say is just margin here,
tiny a bit of margin at the bottom
that applies nicely right there.
Good.
The other thing for the element,
the input element itself,
we can target that as well
by creating another class
so dot new, and then within that new form,
we target the input element like this
and that then applies CSS
for that specific element.
What we want to do is a
couple things, first of all,
it's a little bit bigger than the rest.
So let's say font size 28 pixels,
and then we want to stretch it,
stretch it all the way and
give it some padding, such as,
oops, sorry, 1em, 0.3,
this is, the values here, you
know, I'm not making it up,
that stuff that's in the default template.
So since we're not really
focusing on the styling part,
we can freely copy that and apply,
so basically let me
add all that in one go.
It's a bunch of things that apply only
to that input field within the new class.
So now this looks a lot closer
to what we eventually want it
to look like, but we do notice
it has this border around it.
And so do all the other
elements when you select them.
We want to get rid of that,
and we want to get rid of
that everywhere in this form.
We could add the CSS to remove
that border to the app.CSS file,
and then it applies to
all the input fields
across the entire application.
For the purpose of this course,
I want to introduce
you a concept in Svelte
where we can target all the input fields
in the current component and its children.
So let's look at this
structure real quick.
We have an input element here,
and then we have input
elements within the todo-item.
Remember under source, lib, todo-item.
We have additional input fields.
So if I were to come here
and let's say up here,
well actually after the
new makes probably a sense.
If I came here and I would just say, input
the styling of that input class
would only apply to this
input not the children
because of the local scope
that I explained earlier.
However, Svelte does allow us
to target this one input here
and the ones in the components used.
The way we do that is
we limit it to that todos
class or that element here.
So we say dot todos.
And then instead of just input,
we have to use a Svelte
specific configuration,
so global input.
Now that means target the dot todos class.
So this element on line 35
and then globally within
that, all the input fields,
that's how we can apply styling
to that input and to the
todo-item inputs inside.
What do we want to do for these
items is remove that border.
So border 1px solid, but
we make it transparent.
And if we go to look at that,
that border disappeared,
and if we click, we still get
the blue border around it.
Same here, same here, but
the other border disappeared,
we can fix that in the
same way as we did here,
just that we have to use a pseudo element
saying that target that
element when it's focused.
So same thing to start with,
but instead of targeting the input only,
we want to target its focus visible state,
and then the values we need there again,
no need to type all that.
This is not the main
purpose of the course.
We'll add a bulk shadow,
bit of border in red and outline none.
If we look at that in the user interface,
we now get this red border.
So we know that's the element
we are currently typing in
same here, automatically
applied to all these fields.
With that, we styled everything we can
in terms of the new input field.
It's now time to move on and
style each individual item
so that instead of having
these buttons and all that,
it turns into this nice one row
with the important stuff
that you see in the UI.
For that, we switch to
source, lib, todo-item.
And over here,
this is where we can start
applying the exact same concept
as we did in the index file,
where we create a style element.
And within the style element,
we can create definitions and target
the different elements that we have.
So one note here,
even though we define the
style element at the top,
we could define it at the bottom
if you prefer that,
there's no order required.
Script, style, and HTML,
you can order these three
within a Svelte component
in whatever way you are
most comfortable with.
Good.
Let's do a couple of things
before we apply the styles.
First of all,
let's use some class names
so that we can target individual elements.
First things first, the wrapper div
for an individual line
item, let's call this todo,
and then we need to target that button
so that we can turn this
Done/NotDone button here
into a circle with a checkbox.
So this is the button here,
and we want to target that with a class.
Let's call it toggle.
Next thing we want to target the form
that allows us to edit
a todo item and save it.
So we can call this class,
stick to the same name
as we already used for
other purposes, so text.
And we also want to target the button,
which will turn into a little save icon
when somebody clicks in here.
By default, if nobody
clicks, you see nothing.
If somebody clicks on the text,
then that save button
turns into a little icon.
So we have to target that,
and the way we do that,
as we add a class name
here and we call it save.
Lastly, we need to
target the delete button.
Let's give that a name, delete,
and then let's start
adding the CSS required
to turn this all into a nice line.
All right, first things first,
starting with the todo wrapper, so todo.
For that, we use grid,
but we could just equally use flex
if you're more familiar with that,
I'm going to paste all the CSS in here.
Again, no need to go through
and describe all that.
But it's basically just
applying a few styles
so that things look like the
way they do in the mock-up.
But there's great CSS courses out there
that dive into a lot of
more detail around this.
So have a look what we got,
everything is now aligned
on the single line, so
that's a good first step.
Next thing you want to do is focus
on that button over here,
and actually all of the
buttons, because we can,
we can apply since they're the same styles
to all of these three.
So the way we can do that
is target the todo wrapper
and then all buttons
went in, so all three.
And for all these three,
we want to specify just a couple of things
width and hide the same
number so that we can apply
a background position, 50
50%, which makes it a circle,
remove some colors and make sure
we don't repeat any of the background.
If we have a look, that gray
background that the default
button had is gone, we
still have the text.
We'll drop that as soon as
we have the icons ready,
and that will start to look a lot better.
Buttons look good.
The next thing we want to style are
the input fields, so input.
And for that,
we only have really one input in this case
that's visible, this one,
oops, the input here is hidden,
but this input is visible,
so for that we use flex.
And then we'll see why that is
as soon as we add the image.
Not much changed here until I click,
you can see that edit field eventually.
Next up, let's go and
focus on the toggle button.
So two ways I could say dot toggle,
that would target that specific button.
Alternatively, I can say,
I want to target the button
with the class toggle,
really up to you.
We can do that and
give that some CSS here.
Oops, in here.
Now, if we look at that,
you can see not much changed yet
because we don't have the image yet.
We'll do that very shortly.
Next thing we want to do is
target the text down here.
So let's have a look.
Oops, there we go.
I want to say dot text
and the values for that,
paste them here.
Okay, now this is giving
us a lot more space
because we are applying that
display flex and flex one.
We now have a lot of space
to type and edit our todo-item eventually.
Good.
Next up is the button
for the save element.
So the right here, save button
let's replace that text.
So for that, we remember
we have a safe class,
so we can target it with
a definition like this.
And the content, we can paste.
I'll talk about it in a second here.
So what do you see is that
opacity is zero by default,
which means we don't see anything at the,
by loading the page, and the
background image is just a SVG
that is inlined within that component.
The reason for that is that
this is such a small SVG
with so very so few characters.
It is probably more performant
to include that here rather
than downloading an external
SVG file to display.
So if we look at the page,
you can see that we don't
see that save button anymore.
If we inspected, it is
still here, dot save
capacity is zero,
so if we get it back, we see the icon.
We also see the safe text
that's because we had
a placeholder there,
we no longer need that.
So we can delete the text of that button.
So now if we inspect that one more time,
we can uncheck the opacity
and we see the icon.
So what do we want to do
next is when the input here
is focused, we want to
show that icon like this,
but only when we have to
focus on that input field,
if we don't have to focus, then
we don't want to show that.
So CSS allows us to do
that in a fairly easy way.
And basically what we say here is that
we want the, we can, we can do this.
So to do within that element input, focus,
then target that.
And what do we want to do is
a little bit of a transition
so that is a bit smoother, let
me say opacity 0.2 seconds.
And the other thing we want to do here is
the opacity itself, we
want to set it to one.
Now let's have a look.
If we click on it,
you can see that this slowly appears,
well, it's not very slowly,
but you can see that the icon
appears with a slight delay,
same here and here.
Now there's one more thing we want to do.
If somebody manages the
application with their keyboard
or uses the web app with their keyboard,
when they load the page and they hit tab,
it goes into the input
field to create an item.
If we hit tab again, we
go to the done button.
One more time, we focus on the input.
And you can see the input focus
is what we just specified.
Now the problem is if we tab again,
the focus now is on the element
to edit, but because the focus
is lost on the input field,
we also lost our edit icon.
So we can easily fix that
by just adding a second
definition here, which is if
the save button has focus,
then also show the save button.
So now if we do that again,
we come from here, tab, tab,
and one more time,
now we still see our icon.
So people can use the keyboard
to navigate this application,
which is extremely important
to make sure this works.
All right, lastly, let's
go and focus on the delete.
So the delete icon is a image,
just an SVG, again,
we're going to inline it
like we did for the save icon
and we it an opacity
so it's not too strong.
If we look at that, you can
now see the delete icon.
It is a little bit, almost invisible.
What we want to do is
remove that delete text.
We no longer really need the placeholder
because we have the icon.
We do this, looks better.
And now a nice touch here
is that if we mouse over the
button, we want to kind of pop
it and show it highlighted.
We don't see it in the mock-ups.
And just so people visually can see
that the trash bin can be clicked.
And the way we can do
that is we can focus,
create that delete and on hover and again,
thinking about people using the keyboard.
Also when it is focused,
then same transition as
we used for the edit icon
opacity, 0.2 seconds.
And we want to show it
at its full opacity.
So with that, if we mouse over,
that becomes fully visible.
If we use the keyboard and we
go and select the trash icon
or focus on the trash icon, it
also becomes a capacity one.
So the only thing that's left
is the done, not done button.
And let's add that last.
The reason it's last is
because until we actually know
whether an item is marked as done or not,
we don't really know if we
should show the checkbox
or just an empty circle.
So let's add the CSS and
then we will comment it out
until we have the functionality
to make this work.
All right, at the bottom,
targeting that Done/NotDone item
the way we do it is we have a,
we have a sorry, class called toggle here.
This is how we can target
that specific element.
Let's go to done toggle to
target that specific one.
And let me copy the background
image for that checkbox,
just so that we can have a look.
Again, we don't need to
text, since we now have
an item or an inline SVG.
Now, one thing you see is
I used to classical done,
so let's just drop that for a second
and just start with toggle.
Assuming that every item
is toggled by default.
We now have the check mark for that.
Now, whether or not the
toggle is on or off,
we don't know as I mentioned,
but eventually we want to
show that when it's checked,.
So at some point when we
have the functionality,
we will basically just add a
dynamic class here called done.
We will do that
programmatically when we know
which item we render, and
then when it's available,
then we want to do certain
things versus others.
So for example, that checkbox, the total.
We only want to see it
when that class name
eventually gets added here,
so for now let's rename
that to dot done, and it's still here.
But if we render the UI and the done item
is not set, so if it's not checked,
then we don't want to show the checkbox.
All right, the other
thing we want to do The
if you look at the
mock-up, that entire row,
we want that to be with
an opacity of, you know,
almost zero, so that it's
kind of like blurred out.
The way we can do that
is we can just target
that done element, so if we
do done for that entire row
in here, we can say,
oops, we don't want to transform.
And we want an opacity of let's say 0.4
and we'll give it a little
bit of a drop shadow
to just match the mock-up.
And then again, if we add this done back,
what we have now is
you can see the little,
how do you call it, opacity, 0.4,
blurring that out.
The last thing we want to
do is I noticed we forgot
the circle, so let me have a
look at what are we missing
to get the circle to show up.
I think we added the,
where was it?
We did add the toggle here.
I think that doesn't
get applied, one second.
I'll do some live debugging here.
Order none, uh-huh, okay.
Let's just hang on, we'll figure this out.
There's certainly something missing.
It does have a border one pixel
that shouldn't matter, oh, there we go.
All right, we got that.
We got that back by being
more specific about that.
All right, all good.
So with that we have everything in place
to either mark this as done, not done,
but for the time being until
we know when an item is done,
let's remove that.
And because we don't have to done,
the compilers telling us that
these classes are unused.
So we will comment this out
just for the time being,
and also leave a comment here
so that we don't forget
to bring that back.
once we have the API
endpoint to tell us whether
an item is done or not.
So todo uncomment when the
API endpoints are available.
Good.
So we're back.
Everything looks as if it
was not marked as done.
We can start adding text.
So with that, we looked
at two ways of using CSS,
whether it's through
an app.CSS file at the,
at the root that applies to
the entire application or
whether it is within a style
tag right here in the component
where it is scoped to
that specific component.
And with that, we can go
ahead and make the change,
we can commit these changes.
So set a quick review, todo-item,
we did a bunch of stuff here
to make this all look good,
added some class names, the layout,
and remember that a wrapper
around all the routes
within the directory,
where a file is specified.
And we import the app CSS file here.
And lastly we added some
styles to the main file
so that we can style the UI.
So that looks okay.
We seem to have the
functionality in the UI for that.
Go ahead and commit that
by saying apply CSS styles.
We committed, yes.
That looks good.
Now let's have a look up
here, we have the issue.
We don't have a pull request
yet, so let's have a look
what is going on here, if
we publish the changes.
Nope, we don't want to do that.
If we go to pull requests,
we'll go through this UI for this time.
We don't need any of this.
Close issue number seven,
just double check, yep, looks good.
And we see create pull request.
And with that, we have the
application fully styled.
All the code is here, we remove the text
we no longer need, looks good.
We can go ahead, and
you know, in real world,
we would ask a colleague to review.
We go ahead and merge this confirm.
We no longer need the branch.
We also don't need our preview environment
as well as the developer environment.
That is a thing of the
past, stop workspace
and get rid of it.
That's a pretty good spot to be in.
So we're going to move on
and look at what are
we going to build next.
We now have a web application
that looks pretty good,
but it still doesn't do much.
It has no interactivity
in terms of adding or
updating any of the items.
Before we add that,
let's have a quick look
at the architecture to remind
ourselves where we are.
We have to developed the
front end UI with Svelte
and we leveraged SvelteKit
to run the dev server
and help us parse the URL
and load the correct content.
What are we going to do
next is develop the API
so that we can send
requests to the backend,
parse the data and persist an
item, for now, just in memory,
but at least we can then play
around with the user interface
and see all these things
working together quite nicely.
As always we have an issue created,
it's called develop CRUD endpoints
and watch I've defined
here are four sub tasks
in order to satisfy this issue,
so we will need a post endpoint.
So HTTP method of post on the
slash todos.JSON endpoint.
This allows us to create an item,
a get endpoint at the same URL
to load all the items that
exist in the array for now.
And then we want to delete an item.
The path for that is todo
slash the random user ID
of the given todo-item dot JSON,
as well as a patch endpoint.
We will need that to mark an item as done,
as well as to update the todo-item's text.
So with all that in place,
let's start with the post endpoint
so that we can then go
to the user interface
and create a new item as a first step.
So we're firing up a Gitpod workspace
for that specific issue.
And then we will learn about API endpoints
that are provided to us by SvelteKit.
There we go, we have our
newly styled web application.
Let's inspect it so that we can start
do some debugging there.
We are not going to use much
of the elements inspector
today, so we'll switch
over to the network tab,
which is what we are going
to be using a lot more
to see what's going over the wire
from the browser to our backend.
Back in the editor,
we can start by having
a local where we have
to put our files in order
for all that to work.
As always, I want to quickly show you
under kit.Svelte.dev/docs.
If you want to dive deeper
into the topic, you can see under rooting,
there's an endpoint chapter,
clicking that gives you all
the details you need to know
in order to build an endpoint.
The most important aspect
of that is that each file
that is used as an endpoint
will have to export certain
functions, that map to the HTTP
methods that we want to use.
So in this case, this is a get endpoint.
We can explore other ones as
well to do post, patch, delete.
We'll see that as we go through,
but if you want to dive deeper,
this is definitely a fantastic
piece of documentation here
to go read about that,
as well as the chapter about body parsing,
which I will talk to you
when we start to use it.
Okay, so,
first we need to understand
what endpoints are.
At the moment we have the source directory
and then routes, in here,
we have Svelte files,
so index for now,
we previously had a file
called about us dot Svelte.
Whenever SvelteKit sees a
file in the root directory
or its sub-directories that
ends in Svelte, it becomes
an endpoint, which it becomes
a URL that renders a page.
So in our case, this is the
route page, maps to this file.
If we want to expose an API,
we can do so by creating
files also within the routes
directory that end in
dot TS for TypeScript
or dot JS if you use JavaScript.
Now SvelteKit is then smart enough
to determine the file ending
and parse the file differently
and the behavior of that
will be different too,
but it does use the roots
and the file system here
to determine the path of our API.
Now, if you recall, in our issue,
we specified that we want
a todo slash JSON endpoint
to post our item.
We can copy that todos.JSON,
and under routes,
we want to create a new
directory called todos.
We could call this API slash todos.
We could call it whatever we want.
Let's just pick todos for the time being.
And within that, we want an index file
because we want a todo.JSON
so we can do right click, new file,
index.JSON.TS for TypeScript.
And within that file,
we can now create an endpoint
that replies or response to a get request.
So bear with me, let's create that.
And then I'll show you what we did.
So we can say export const,
get for an HTTP get request.
That's a function.
And for now we'll keep it very simple.
What we have to return from this function
that's defined in the
documentation is basically
an object that contains a status code.
So let's call it 200
because we want to show
whenever it goes, okay,
as well as say body,
in this case, we can
say hello from the API.
So let's go have a look.
If we go the URL and we
go to slash todos.JSON.
Todos.JSON exists because
we created a todos directory
with an index file.
So SvelteKit automatically
creates a todos.JSON URL.
If we hit enter,
we can see that the response
is hello from the API.
And if we look at that in the
network tab on the right
side here, let's have a look.
We can see that the
headers or a get request
and the status code was 200.
That's what we specified in our code.
So that is the simplest
endpoint that you can imagine.
It doesn't do anything as you can see,
it just returned some texts,
but this is what we
eventually need in order
to return all our todo-items,
as well as to add new ones.
So in order to do that,
let's start by first
learning about TypeScript
and how this can benefit
us in this situation here.
So the first thing you
noticed when I created that is
I had to type all that by myself.
It didn't actually do
any autocomplete for me.
So let's for now just add
a line at the top here,
and I'll explain what this line does.
So if we say import
type and request handler
from SvelteJS/kit,
this is importing a type,
a TypeScript type called request handler.
Now what that request
handler does is it contains
a lot of information about that function,
what parameters it gets,
what returned valued,
expects, and all that.
So we can come here and
this is now TypeScript,
so if you have a JS file,
then that will not work.
What we can say that get function.
I want to annotate it
as a request handler.
And now if we remove these two items,
copy this because I'll need it again.
If we do that and I use
autocomplete control space,
it is now offering me the properties
that are allowed in this return object.
So this makes developing a lot easier
because now I can just say, all right,
I know I need a status
and I want this to be 200.
What else do I have, a body,
hello from the API.
So TypeScript really just
gives us some pointers
and suggestions and helps
us write more robust code
that follows the specification.
So we'll do a little bit more
of type of the TypeScript
definitions for our
own code in just a bit.
But I wanted to give you an idea
of some of the benefits
of using TypeScript.
Again, if you don't use
TypeScript in your project,
just drop this and the import
and everything else works
exactly the same way.
All right, so we're going
to leave this for now,
but if we look at the issue,
we agreed to work on
the post request first.
So let's do that.
We can create the post endpoint
just exactly the same way we did the get.
So we can say export const post,
and that's also request handler.
It's a function and it eventually
will return some stuff.
We'll work on that in a second.
Okay.
Now there is one more thing we can do,
and that is a parameter
that's being passed in here
to our endpoint, one of
them is called request.
If we specify that,
then we can leverage TypeScript again
to give us some information.
So let's talk about what we want to do.
When we are on the index page,
let's go back to look at our application.
We want to type something
in here, like first
issue, or first todo-item.
And then we want to hit enter
and send that data to our backend API
and then read it from the
request and persist it, okay.
So what we can do is the request handler,
which gives us information
about what's coming in
the request and what we have to return
comes in handy here again,
because let's say we want to
print just so that we can test
this before we do any
more work, the request,
and you can see it gives
us some suggestions,
what the request provides, there's a body,
there's a bunch of other things,
we currently care about the
body, which will be the
content of our todo-item here,
whatever we type we want
to read from the body.
So request.body.,
and then we don't have
any more details here.
Now there's one more trick
we can do with TypeScript.
And that is the request handler.
We can use a few more details.
So this is getting a little
bit into the nitty gritty
of TypeScript, but basically bear with me.
We can use the less than
and greater than symbols.
And what we can do here is
not worry about the first
argument, so ignore that,
just an empty object.
But then here, we can say FormData,
and I'll show you in a
second where that comes from.
But now if we, if we do a dot here,
we basically taught the TypeScript
with the second parameter here,
what is the type of the body
that we're dealing with.
And it's saying FormData.
Now it gives us different
functions so we can call here.
One of them is get
that we're going to be most interested in.
And if we open that, you can
see that it expects a key.
So let's have a quick
look at mdn FormData.
If you search for that, you
will eventually end up here.
And the FormData interface
provides a way to easily
construct a set of key value
pairs representing form fields
and their values, interesting,
form fields and their values.
Let's have a look, in our index file,
we have a form for the new
item and we have fields
in here and remember
that name equals text.
So what that means is
if we submit that form
to the post endpoint that we defined,
we will be able to access
that text property here.
So from the body, we want to get the text.
That text maps to that text,
if I rename this to
item name, for example,
I would have to map this one here as well.
For now, we'll stick to text.
We'll read that text and we
eventually will return it, so
oops, I don't know where that comes from.
Nevermind.
Maybe if we close it reopen.
All right.
So let's see, we have a post endpoint.
How do we send data to the post endpoint?
With the get endpoint, it was easy,
we could just use the
browser to access the URL
because the browser sends
a get requests by default.
For the post request,
well, we can use the regular HTML form,
which is right here, interestingly
enough, we have a form.
The action attribute here is
the URL that we want to target.
So in our case, it is todos.JSON.
As you remember todos.JSON is this file.
Now we want to target the post endpoint.
So we can say the method,
which refers to the HTTP
method that is being used,
we want this to be post.
There's a lot going on,
so let's have a look.
We'll clear up some stuff here.
And we come here and we submit that form.
So if we hit enter, it gives us a 404.
Now let's have a look
why this is happening.
We are calling a post endpoint todos.JSON.
Say, if we look at the request itself,
it's getting a little bit small,
but you can see that endpoint todos.JSON
post endpoint 404.
And if we go to the bottom, we have,
see if I can find it, oh,
it didn't work because we have a 404,
okay, let's fix that first.
So 404 happens because we did not return
any object from here,
remember here, we had a 200.
So for now, let's say we
want to return a status 200
in a body that maps to
whatever we send in.
So let's copy that and paste it here.
So whatever item name,
or item value we put,
we'll just return.
If we go back and go to the
index page and one more time,
say first we submit, you
can see that we ended up
on the todos.JSON URL and
the server returned first.
If we go back and we say, second,
now it says second.
So we know that we can
send a value in here
read it from there and
do something with it.
Another one to remember
is if we don't return
an object from here, the
default is 404, not found.
So always make sure you have a return
with the correct status code.
Good.
One thing that I don't
like is the fact that
we end up on this todos.JSON endpoint URL.
That's really not user-friendly
because we don't want
to navigate back to add another todo-item.
So what we can do is deal with that.
The reason this happens is because that's
the default behavior, when
you submit an HTML form,.
In our case, we can deal
with that quite easily,
so instead of doing 200 return
or response code, we can
use something called 303.
This is a special HTTP code
used to tell the browser
that we want to redirect
after submitting a form
and what we have to do,
we don't have to return a body
because the browser doesn't
care what was submitted,
but we can return a headers
object and within that,
because it's a 300
redirect, response code.
We can say location, back to our page.
In this case, we want to
go back to the root page.
Let's see what that does
to our user experience.
We start at the root,
we add our first item.
We hit enter and we're back here.
We didn't even see the other
page because that other page
never loaded because we
gave it 303 return code.
That brought us back to here.
So that's nice.
Now the problem is we don't see the item
and that's obviously because
we didn't do anything.
We just locked it in the console.
So if we scroll down in the terminal here,
you can see that printed here.
So the server side console log
shows up in the terminal here,
and we need to do something with it
for now because we don't
have a database yet,
let's create an array of todo-items
and we make this in array, voila.
And also we don't really
want to keep that,
so let's say todo, persist in database.
Once we have a database,
we will come and replace all
that to persist it over there.
So in here we can now say
todos, push and use,
oops, let me just copy
that, that'd be quicker.
Requests body get text,
that's the value of the todo we create.
So todos push that text.
And now that means every
time we create an item,
we add the text of that
item to the todos array.
With that, we can know the
change our get endpoint,
instead of returning
the hello from the API,
what we can return is all our todo-items.
Very nice.
If we go back and we add first
and we add second,
and now we go to the
slash todos.JSON endpoint.
You can see we get an
array first and second.
All we need to do is when
we load the index page,
before we rendered a component
and before we even returned
anything from the server,
the server has to call
that todos endpoint,
to fetch the existing elements,
and then render one line per todo-item
and then return all the HTML to the client
so that the client doesn't have
to make another HTTP
request to fetch the items.
This is called server-side rendering
and SvelteKit makes this super easy.
Now, before we do that,
we probably need to persist
more than just the string.
Somehow we also need to know
whether the item is checked,
so mark this done,
and we also want to
probably keep some kind
of date as to when it was created.
So let's make this change first,
and instead of persisting,
just a string here,
we want a persistent
object or a todo item.
Now, remember how we use
TypeScript here to help us navigate
that code and implement autocomplete?
Right now the todos array
can persist a string,
but I could also, let me
just show you that real quick
persist an object with a property text,
that would work just fine.
So this is okay, but we can do better.
We can use TypeScript
to help us and ensure
that we only persist the
correct type into this array.
How does this work?
Just like we used a request handler,
we can create our own type for TypeScript,
and then say that in this
array, we only want todo-items.
So how do we do that in SvelteKit?
You notice there's a file
under source, SRC, global.d.ts
If we open that up,
we can define our to do type right here
and it will be available to us
across the entire application,
hence global.d.ts.
D stands for the TypeScript Hence
so what do we want to
do is we can say type,
it will be a todo type equals,
and don't get confused by these brackets.
This is not a regular JavaScript object,
it's a TypeScript type definition,
so we want a created at,
and that will be a date.
And we want a text, which is a string
as well as a done,
which will be a Boolean.
This is probably a good
start to kick things off
and allow us to specify what
kind of type we want to store.
So now, if I say that the array of todos,
we can use to type here and say that, Hey,
I only wanted todo-items
persisted in here,
and this is an array of those.
If we mouse over,
you can see that this is
an array of todo types.
Okay?
So that's good, and you immediately notice
at the bottom, it is complaining now.
And if we mouse over that error,
you can see that type text string,
which is our text request
body get texts, this line.
So that type is missing
the following properties
from the type todo, created at and done.
Interesting, let's have a look.
If we were to use
autocomplete, huh, that's cool.
It is telling us that
there's two more properties
that we need to specify.
One is created at, and that's
just a new date right now.
And then I think there was another one.
Let's do that again,
yeah, there's done as well and done,
when we create the new todo-item,
then done is false to start with.
Now TypeScript is satisfied
because we are now
creating a proper todo-item
with a created at, a text and a done,
it's no longer complaining
that we cannot push that
into the produce array.
So this is pretty good.
Now we know whatever element
is in this todos array
is of type todo, and it has
three properties defined.
We're making good progress.
What's still missing though is
the fact that it's not
actually showing our items.
So as I said, we need to load
all the existing todo-items
when we request that page from the server.
We can do that in the index.Svelte file.
What we have to do is,
and that's well documented
in the SvelteKit docs,
but besides the script tag that we have,
we have to create another
tag, another element.
It's also a script,
but it is a little bit
more special than that
because it has context equals module.
So this is how you can
differentiate the two.
Every time a component gets rendered,
this script gets executed
and the script module
only gets executed once
across all the instances,
but this is the place where
if you're familiar with
like Next.js or others,
where you would call,
like get the initial
props or places like that,
where you can fetch data
from the server before
the component is rendered,
this is what we want to do,
and because we're using TypeScript,
we can tell that script that
we will use TypeScript within.
So we can say language is TypeScript.
The convention here is
that we need to export
a function called load
that SvelteKit will automatically call
as part of the server side rendering.
So let's export that function,
const load a regular function.
It's a good start.
And we want to leverage
TypeScript here as well
to help us with the parameters
that are being passed in
and kind of the return values we have
to specify from this function.
So at the top here,
we can import a type
and it is called load.
We grabbed that from
the SvelteKit package,
and then we can annotate this
load function by saying load
and just like that, we can now
see what we need to return.
So if we say return and
we use autocomplete,
there's some error,
maxage, props, other stuff in here.
So eventually we'll specify
the right things here,
but thanks to this TypeScript
type that we specified,
we are not able to see
these autocomplete items.
So one other thing we want
is at this point, this is
where we want to fetch the data
from the backend API, right?
Remember from the slash todos.JSON,
it's empty now because we
restarted the server automatically
when we made code changes
there and our array got erased
from memory, but we want
to call that endpoint,
get that array, and then
render each array item in here.
Okay, the way we do that is we
get an object as a parameter.
And one of the values
in there, or one of the
properties is called fetch.
If we use that fetch, not to confuse
that with the regular fetch
that you get in the browser,
this is a special fetch
that's provided by SvelteKit.
So always make sure you use that.
This is where we can now
call that endpoint to get
and fetch our todos, so
fetch slash todos.JSON.
And this is an async call,
so it's returning a promise.
So let's change our function
to async and then leverage a wait here.
So the response is a wait fetch.
Now, if the response is okay, again,
you can see TypeScript
helping us here, if it's okay,
then where you want to
convert the response
and get these todo-items out of it,
so todos equals await,
JSON response there.
Now that array contains the
same elements as that array
because we return it as part
of the party in this get
request, which we call with
the fetch function here.
All right.
Having these todo-items,
we need to pass them to our component,
so that down here, instead
of rendering three static
todo-items, we want to render
X amount of todo-items,
depending on how many have
been added to the array.
So if we use TypeScript autocomplete here,
you see one property is called props,
and that's exactly what we want to do.
We want to use the props
to be passed into that component here.
So props is an object and we
just want to pass in the todos
which creates a todos property
that is being passed into the script.
So we can come here and I'll teach you
how to do props in Svelte.
The way it works is the syntax for that
is export let todos.
That gives us a prop called todo
that's exported from this component
so here is where we specify the props
we want to pass in down here.
You can see that it's complaining
that we don't have type defined.
So we actually have the to do type right,
that we created in global.TS.
So we know that this property is going
to be of type todo, so we can say,
this will be an array of todo-items.
And because we know using TypeScript,
we have to let the script
know that we use TypeScript.
All right, that was a lot,
but basically we exported a
load function that executes
on the server when we
do a full page refresh,
which is currently the case.
If we were to navigate
from one page to another,
then the client side would,
the browser would call this load function
and do a client side fetch.
But in our case, because we
always refresh that page,
ignore that error, because
we all just reload the page,
that fetch actually
executes on the server,
the load function, and then calling fetch.
So we go grab that and we
return if everything is okay.
We passed the todos array into here,
and then we currently
not using it anywhere.
So it's giving us a little warning.
We will do that in a second,
but before we move on,
let's deal with the error case
in case something goes wrong
with our fetch, what we can say is
if the response is okay,
we return, so that means
that down here on line 13,
the response was not okay.
So what we can do is we
can fetch the message
and we do that from
await response, dot text.
So basically, oops, that should be JSON.
So basically whatever we
get back from the server,
it will contain a message
object, we haven't built
that yet, but that's just
preparing us for later.
And then what we want
to do is we don't want
to return props because
if we return props,
we indicate that everything was okay,
so we can return an error.
And that's just a new error
with the message that we receive.
The nice thing about
that is that if we return
an error then the SvelteKit
will automatically render
an error page instead of our component.
Alrighty.
We now have the todos array
that contains whatever elements
are in the array on the server side.
Now we have to use that
to render todo-items
depending on how many we have.
So basically we need a for loop
or in Svelte's case, an each loop.
This index for that is that you
use the open curly brackets,
hashtag each,
and then you specify which
array we are iterating over.
So that's our todos array.
And then what's the variable name
of the individual todo-item of this array,
so as todo allows us to
access to individual item
from the array, with the
variable to do, and then
to close it, curly brackets
slash each closes the loop.
Now it's telling us this
is an empty each block,
please don't do that,
that's fine we can have
that todo-item render
and we do not need these
other two items we have there.
Let's have a look.
Nothing rendered because
we have nothing added yet.
We go to first.
And we now have one item in the array.
It doesn't show anything,
and I'll show you that in
a minute, how we fix it,
let's do another one.
Two items, nice.
It doesn't show any texts or anything
because we still just render a todo item
that if we look at the details
under source lib todo-item
in the HTML, it doesn't
literally do anything,
it's all empty, that's why we
just see two empty elements.
So first things first,
we need to pass this
todo-item into the component.
And remember in Svelte, export let
is how you specify a prop
so we can do the same for the todo-item.
So up at the top, we
don't have a script yet,
we add script.
We also want to use the TypeScript here.
So language TS, and we say export let
a single todo of type todo.
And we get a warning because
we're not using it yet.
That is changing right now.
The only thing we have for
now is the text property,
remember in the API post,
we set the created at,
which we don't display in
the UI, where you set a text,
which is the value we entered
and had done, that's false,
in the todo-item.
We can now go down to this section here
where we have a text input field,
and now we can say value equals
and then just like in the index
where we used curly brackets
to access a variable, we
can do the same here and say
todo and dot text because it's a string.
With that, we can go back
and in the index file,
we now see that this
is complaining, saying
that todo-item, and that's
because we use TypeScript.
It's telling us that
it's missing a todo-item.
So we can just come
here and say to do prop
is this specific todo-item here in Svelte.
Since the name of the variable
and the name of the prop are the same,
we can use a shortcut and
just basically drop this
and say curly brackets todo.
That will pass in that specific variable.
And now you can see, we have first second.
If we were to add third, we
would get third it as well.
Now, keep in mind.
The way this currently works is that
every time we add an item and hit enter,
you can see that there's
a lot of requests.
That's because we first sent the request
to the todos endpoint
where we get a redirect to the homepage,
and then the browser
reloads the entire page
and all the development stuff,
hot reloading loading everything.
What that also means is
that what we just built
works even if we disabled JavaScript,
let's have a look.
In our developer tools, we go to settings,
we scroll down to the debugger section
and we say disable JavaScript.
And if we come here, we reload the page
and we add a fifth item.
That's still a works
because all we're doing
is we're using HTML forms
and a post submission.
So there's no JavaScript involved at all.
We will later improve this
so that if somebody
has JavaScript enabled,
we will just send an Ajax request
and not reload entire page.
But for now it's really
interesting to know
that the application works
even with JavaScript disabled.
Alright, we built a lot and
there's a lot more to do,
but I think this is a good
point to commit the changes,
because if we look at our issue,
we already created the post endpoint
as well as to get endpoint, they are done,
so it's probably a good
time to commit that
so we can check these two off
before we move on to building
the delete functionality
and then the patch to update the items.
Okay.
So quick review, we created
the new type called todo
that has three properties in the API.
We created a new index of JSON.TS files
under source, routes, todos.
This is where we have a
get endpoint that returns
whatever array elements we
have in that todo array.
We also have a post
endpoint where we create
a new todo item every time
somebody sends a post request,
we read the text value from the body,
and then we redirect back to the homepage
to get that experience of adding an item
and then seeing it displayed in the UI.
Okay, that's a good start.
What are we going to do next
is in the commit message,
we can say that we add
get and post endpoints.
We can go ahead and commit these changes
and create a pull request
that, let's use a better title,
develop CRUD endpoints.
And here we say, we want
to close issue number nine.
We are not done yet,
so we make it a draft.
There's two more endpoints we have
to implement, but this
is a good start, publish,
and with that, it will have
added that CRUD endpoint.
So let's check this off.
So our team members
know what's the status.
We can switch here and we
now see the files we changed.
Good, so with that,
we could continue to
work on that environment,
but I think it's a good
time to take a break,
go grab some food or drink some water.
So what we'll do instead is we just
shut down this environment
here, we'll stop it.
We'll get rid of it, preview done.
And we will come back
and then continue with
the new environment,
just so that you see that
it doesn't really matter
how many environments you start.
Each one is completely independent.
All right, so continuing on
with the other patch
and delete requests now.
Let's have a quick look at our
issue to check what's next.
So we've done post get,
now we're going to work
on a delete endpoint.
And as we specified, we want this endpoint
to live at a /todos/uid.JSON endpoint,
where you currently see the colon UID,
this will have to be a dynamic part
of the path in the URL, where
depending on the todo-item,
where we want to delete that part,
we'll update as we click
the delete button in the UI.
So we'll see how we can
do that in SvelteKit.
And also we will have to
create a unique identifier
for each todo-item.
So with that,
let's switch back to the
pull requests that we already
started and start a new
environment so that we can go ahead
and develop that delete endpoint
at that specific URL that
we specified in the issue.
Here's our new developer environment.
It also opens up the application preview,
which is exactly what we want.
We inspect that and select our network tab
so we can keep an eye
on what is being sent
between the client and the browser.
Okay, now we can,
first of all, start by
creating the new endpoint file.
So let's have a look
under source routes todos.
We already have an index.JSON.TS file,
which we created previously,
where this file contains
our post and get endpoints.
Now, in order to create the
endpoint with the dynamic UID,
what we can do is under the
todos directory as well,
we can create a new file
and we can call this
[UID].JSON.TS
that naming convention
with the square brackets
tells SvelteKit that this part of the path
is going to be dynamic.
And it will change depending
on what ID we send.
So let's create a file.
And then just to test real
quick, what is going on here,
let's create an get endpoint
so we can use the browser for testing,
so as you recall from the
previous endpoint we created
export const get,
and that's a function,
and we'll just do this very
quickly without any TypeScript
definitions, but basically
we get a request here.
And what we have to return is the,
an object that contains the
status of 200 and a body.
And for the body,
what we want to do is we want
to use request.params.UID.
So, oops,
so what we have is the params object
refers to any path,
any part of the path where
we have square brackets.
So in this case, UID that's
wrapped into brackets,
turns into a property
on that params object.
And we can access that by simply
calling a request.params.UID.
So what we can do now is if we go back
to the browser where we have
our application running,
we can go to slash todos
slash and then a dynamic part
of the URL, so that's our
UID, let's say ABC.JSON.
And if we load this page,
you can see that the response is ABC,
that's because as I said,
we just read that params UID
and return it as a 200 response.
If the todo-item UID was 123.
You can imagine if we change this to 123,
then the return value is 123.
So this is great.
We can then dynamically
generate this URL when we are
in the user interface and
click on the delete icon
next to a todo-item.
Now, before we do the UI part,
let's first complete the
API for that endpoint here,
so that when we built the UI,
we can immediately test it.
Okay, so what do we
have to do in this file,
first of all, let's import the types
for the endpoints here.
So same as we did in the index.JSON file,
where we have that request handler,
we'll grab the same type and
we import it here as well.
Now we can say that endpoint
is of this request handler type.
And the other thing we can do is we want
to change that get endpoint
to a delete endpoint.
Now delete is a keyword in
JavaScript that we can not use,
so the actual name is
just D-E-L for delete.
And now if we use the request
dot, we get this autocomplete,
because we have the
request handler defined.
So TypeScript knows what's going on here.
Now we have a bit of a challenge here,
first of all, let's get rid
of this just for a second.
The challenge we have is, even
though we can access that UID
we need to somehow remove the correct item
from this todos array right here.
Unfortunately, we don't
have access to this array
because it's in a different endpoint.
And from this file,
there's no easy way for us
to go and access that array.
So what we're going to do instead is
we will refactor that code a little bit,
so that anything related
to actually creating or
adding a todo or updating
or deleting, we will move
that into a separate file
and the index.JSON.TS
and the [UID].JSON.TS,
both of these endpoints will then leverage
that new file to interact
with the todo-item.
This also makes it
easier a little bit later
when we switch from an array
that we persist in memory
to accessing the database,
we will have just one
place in the source code
where we have to make that modification.
So doing that refactoring now
is a good point to bring us
into good shape for later.
So one thing I can teach you now is that,
as I said, any file within
the roots becomes an endpoint
if it ends in dot TS or JS,
or a page if it ends in dot Svelte.
Sometimes just like we do
what we want right now,
we want to create additional
helper files that we can use,
like in this case to consolidate
certain functionality.
We could, if we wanted
to move that into lib,
but that really starts to
convolute the lib directory
and add a lot of stuff in
there that isn't really used
across the entire app, but
only in certain places.
So there's another
convention in SvelteKit,
and that is if a file in
the roots directory starts
with an underscore,
the SvelteKit router ignores it
and does not create a path for that file.
So we can leverage that
knowledge and under source routes
todos, we can create a
new file called _api.TS.
And this is going to be
our file that we can access
from both of the other
endpoints that we created.
All right, the first thing
we want to move in here
is that array of todo-items.
So we'll grab that, remove it from here
and add it to our API.
So with that thing moved over here,
we know, we can ignore
this warning for now,
that'll fix itself in just a second,
what do we want to do now is
we want to export a function
here that we can then call
from the different places
such as the get and to
post endpoints here.
And we will do all the behavior
related todos in there.
So let's create that
function export const API.
For now, it doesn't have any parameters.
There we go.
So now what we want to do in here is
depending on whether we want
to create or delete or update
an item, we want to execute
different functionality.
So if you recall,
let's have a quick look
back in the index file.
When we look at the form
where we create a new item,
you see that we specified the
HTTP method as being post.
And we also know that
when we load index page,
the server receives a get
request from our fetch here.
So that fetch slash todos
by default is an HTTP get request.
So we want to kind of like an
if else situation in our API,
where we say that if
the HTTP method is get,
then please return the array,
if the HTTP method is post,
then please create an
item for us in the array.
So what do we need in
order to determine that
is we need the request
object because we need
to access that HTTP method.
So I'll show you how we can do that.
First things first,
let's go grab that import statement again
for the, oh, sorry, not
the request handler.
What we can do is in the
API, you want to say,
we want to request and
the type of data request,
we can fetch that from
the SvelteKit packet.
So import type request from SvelteKit.
Now, if we go to the API and we say
the request is of type request,
we will get all the autocomplete
functionality that we need.
Now, if we have a look in both cases here,
we eventually return that object.
So that depends, the value of that object,
the return object depends on
whether we do a post or a get.
So I suggest we will move that code also
into the API so that in this file here,
we can just make a call to
the API and return the result.
So we don't have to do
any more code in here.
Let's start by running a switch statement.
So switch and the value we want to check,
as I mentioned is request.method,
which is going to be either
post or get or patch,
things like that, as we go through.
Now, let's also make this uppercase
just to be sure in case it
is being sent by clients
in different format, lowercase
or uppercase mixed maybe.
Now the value we want
to look for here is get.
In the get case, we want to
return all these todo-items.
And in order to do that, remember here,
we had a body and a status
of 200 and the todo-items.
So what we can do in here in our API,
above the switch statement,
we can specify a body and
that's by default empty.
And we can specify a status
that is by default 500.
Now we set this to 500,
which represents an internal server error,
just so that if somebody sends a request
with a method that we did not
add to our switch statement,
the default behavior will be a 500 error,
which indicates that
whatever the clients try
to do with their method
here is not implemented yet,
so right now, if somebody
were to send a post request,
they would get a 500 error,
as soon as we returned that.
Now, in the case of get,
we know that the body has
to be the array of elements.
We had that over here previously.
Now we no longer have
the array here, however,
we do have it here in our API.
So we can say body equals todos
and status equals 200.
With that we rebuild the functionality
that we had in the index.JSON.TS file.
Lastly what we want to do
after the switch statement
is we want to return
that status and the body
so that whatever we set
in the switch statement
will get returned down here.
Now, for the post request.
So first of all, before
we get to the post,
let's clean up the get request.
And the way we do that is by
importing the API we created.
So we can say import API
from the API file.
And then the fix down here,
the code change is that
instead of just returning
that object, we can remove that
and we do need to get the request
because our API expects that.
And then we can say return
API and pass the request.
Now this just becomes a
one-line function here
where we call that API
that we specified here,
then the switch statement
will fall into the get case
where we set the body and the status,
and down here, we return
body and status back,
which then gets returned
from this function,
and we are back to the
behavior we had previously.
The benefit now is that
everything is consolidated
in that API script.
Let's do the same with the post endpoint.
So in the switch statement,
let's add a case for post.
So don't forget the break statement,
otherwise we'll run into the next case
and that will have
unexpected consequences.
Okay, in the post case,
let's see what we have to do.
We need to push a new
item into the todos array,
just like we did here.
So we could potentially create that
item inside of our API right here,
by reading the values from the request.
Another way to do that
is to add a parameter to the API,
which is a todo-item.
And that will then basically
help us create the item for the array.
So either way it works.
I think for now, what
we can do is right here,
we'll create the item and then
we will pass it into the API.
So let's say that our API
also requires a todo-item.
And the type of that is
to do remember we created
that in the global.d.ts,
there's our todo type,
so we can tell what properties we expect.
Now in the post scenario, we want to add,
so push the todo-item into that array
and then the body and status,
in the post case, we can
go grab that from here,
you'll see it was status 303
and headers and location.
So this is interesting because
that return object is different
from the return object
that we had down here.
Now for the time being,
let's just take that return here.
And because we're working
on a post, we can come here and exit early
to return that status 303
because we don't really
want to return the body
that we don't have, also
we need the headers object
for the post request.
So we don't want to, you know,
deal with that down here
where sometimes the headers
is available, sometimes it's not,
we'll just move it in
here for the time being.
All right, now, if we go
back to that index file,
what do we want to do now, here
is basically call that API.
So same as we did above,
and we'll fix that
error there in a second.
So again, we want to return API.
The first parameter is a
request and the second one
is the object that
represents our todo-item.
And then we don't need
any of this anymore.
So that's good.
Now we noticed that the
return statement up here,
where we call the API and to get request
is now red underlined.
And if we do that it says
that it expected two arguments
but it got one, that's because we added
that todo-item for the post requests,
but when we have a get
request or maybe later
delete request, we don't
really have a todo-item.
So what we can do in TypeScript
is after the parameter name,
we can add a question mark
to mark this specific
parameter as optional.
And now the API accepts a request
or a request with a new todo-item.
So so far we have refactored the code
that we had previously,
the get and the post,
and because we have return statement here,
we don't really need the break,
we can remove that for now.
Now we did all that work
because we wanted to
add a delete endpoint.
So we have the wrapper here
and now what we can do
in that specific file,
we can leverage what we
already built in the API file.
So if we import the API here
and that lives in that API file,
we want this to be a return API request.
And then we want the API file
to worry about the details
of how to implement that.
The way we do that is when
we have a delete request,
we expect the HTTP method
to be delete, right?
So we have get, post,
and now we want a case
for the delete endpoint.
And I want a break from that.
The response status for a delete request
is going to be 200, so status 200.
We do not have to specify
a body for a delete request
because the item gets
removed and doesn't exist.
So we'll keep the default, which
is an empty object, but
we have to remove the item
based on the UID from the
array that we have up here.
Eventually when we have a
database, that will be super easy,
we just say, you know, delete
from the database with that ID
for now, because we just persist
that todos array in memory,
we have to manually just go
in and filter the existing
array, but not include the
element that we want to delete.
So the way we do that
is todos, we set a new value for that.
And then we basically filter,
we filter that and we say that we want
the todo.UID not equals to
remember request.params.UID
gives us the unique ID.
And what we notice is that
an individual todo-item
does not have a UID because at the moment,
if we look at that global.d.ts file,
there is no UID specified.
However, because we need that
UID now to identify an item,
we have to extend our todo
type by adding a UID property.
And that will just be a string.
So UID now exists and our
API no longer complains
about the UID not being present.
However, if we look at
the index JSON file,
we know we're getting an
error here because we create
a todo-item that does not
include a UID property.
Now this is again, the beauty
of TypeScript, really to help us identify
these kind of box before
we even go to production.
So what do we do?
There's a good way, and a
temporary way to do that.
The good way would be
to import a UUID package
and create an actual UUID, or
we can do a little workaround,
which is fine for now,
but eventually that UID
will be generated for us
by the database, so we really just
add a temporary UID for now.
And what we can do is UID
equals, it has to be a string.
We specified it as a string type.
So we can use string literals
here and say Date.now,
which gives us the milliseconds
when this item gets created.
Again, don't do that in production,
definitely don't do that
if you have two requests
coming in at the same time,
you will have a conflict of
two items with the same UID.
So do not do that.
Todo replace with UID from database.
This is something that we will
fix once the database exists
and we can create the item in the DB,
but for now, at least we get a UID.
And when we delete the item,
we have access to that
and we can remove it.
So this is a pretty good start.
Now, what do we want to do next is
go have a look at what
do we have to change
in the UI in order to
call this delete endpoint.
The place where we click the delete icon
is under lib todo-item.
In here, you know,
that we have a prop
for our individual todo
and down in the forms, you can see here,
we have the delete todo button.
Now the action is the
endpoint that we just created.
So that endpoint lives
at slash todos slash
let's just make UID.JSON.
The UID has to be dynamic
depending on the item we render.
So if you recall with the curly brackets,
we can access the variables.
So we can remove that and
just say curly brackets
and todo.UID again, thanks to TypeScript,
we have that autocomplete
of the new field available.
And as we set the method
that we want to use,
we'll look at the API, deleting
something in a REST API
is an HTTP request with
a method of delete.
So in our todo-item method,
we want to say delete so that
the API knows what to do.
Now, let's have a look
at the user interface.
So we'd go back to the index
and there seems to be a bug
somewhere, let's have a look okay.
Just temporarily because
of the changes we made.
Okay, let's clear this, clear console
and let's add an item.
So that worked.
And now if we inspect
the button real quick,
you can see that the form now
points to slash todos slash
the unique ID that we created
based on the date dot
now function dot JSON.
So this is just like before,
when we did slash todos slash ABC or 123,
we have a delete method,
so that should all be good.
Now let's see what happens
when we send that request.
So we go to network, clear this,
clear the console, and we delete the item.
Interesting, we get a 404,
it says not found slash todos
blah blah blah dot JSON.
What is going on?
Let's have a look.
There's our requests
that ended up in a 404,
but clearly we know that exists
because we just created it.
And if we click on it,
we notice that the
request method was "get".
Now, why would it be "get"
when we specified "delete"
in our method here?
So unfortunately I have some
bad news and the bad news
is that an HTML form only
supports get method or post.
Very unfortunate for us
because we can not use delete.
However we don't want to change our API
and put all our code to
delete and update items
into the post handler.
Because if somebody were to build,
let's say a mobile
application for our todo app,
they would expect the REST API
to provide a delete endpoint.
So this is really on us to
find a workaround for our web
application so that we
can still make this work,
but rely on the delete
endpoints, even though HTML forms
don't actually support it.
The way we can do that in SvelteKit
is back in our todo-item.
We have to conform to the post endpoint
or post method because that's
the only thing we can do.
So we'll change this to post,
but we use a query parameter here,
and that's just something
that we agree on.
There's different ways
we could solve that.
This is one way to do it.
So what we say is that let's append
an _method parameter,
and we call it delete.
Okay so we are in the request object
that our API eventually gets.
There will be a created parameter
called _method equals delete.
So that will help us identify
where do we want to do a delete.
Even though we are actually
sending a post request
over the wire.
Now we could go into the
API and here where we say,
switch request.method.
I could show you that request.query.
We could go and fetch
that _method parameter,
and then we could check if that is delete,
then do something, but again,
we don't want people who want
to build on top of our application,
but using our APIs to create
URLs that contain this created
parameter, they can just
send an HTTP delete request,
and that should work, so we
have a little feature here
that we can use in SvelteKit.
Basically when that request is sent
from the browser to the
SvelteKit application,
we can intercept the request
before it reaches our API
and the place to do that is a file
that lives in the source
directory, new file,
and the file is called hooks.TS.
Not to be confused with hooks
from other frameworks that
you might be familiar with,
completely unrelated things,
same name, different ideas.
So definition of the hooks file, again,
it's documented in the SvelteKit docs,
but what we need to know is
if we export a function
from here called handle,
we can do things there
before the request is sent to our API.
So let's do this export
const a handle function.
And if we want to make our life easier
to see what we have to do,
what the parameters are,
there is a TypeScript definition for that.
So if we import type
handle from the SvelteKit,
we can then annotate our
handle function with that.
And right away, it's
telling us that, you know,
type void is not assignable,
which means our function
currently doesn't return anything.
So we do have to return
something here, but first of all,
we also get some parameters
that are important to us here.
And if we inspect that one thing we get is
the request object and a result function.
So in order to return
the right value here,
we have to call the resolve function
and pass in the request object
and all this happens asynchronously.
So we have to make this
an it async function
and here return,
await resolve request.
There we go.
Or to make this a bit more clear in terms
of what's going on, we
can const response equals
this and then return response.
All right, let me explain.
So all we're doing here is we call
that resolve function
and we await the result.
The request is a parameter we pass in.
And then when this is all done,
we get a response object
that we have to return.
So this is the default implementation
of that handle function.
So where do we do this?
Or completely comment this
out and remove the file.
We get the exact same behavior, however,
in line number four here,
where we say await resolve,
this is when SvelteKit
actually executes the code in our API.
What we can do is before
we do that resolve call,
we can intercept and
modify that request object.
So what we want to do is we want
to check if the query
parameter _method exists.
So if this _method exists,
we want to take the value
and set that value as the
request method so that
when we get to the API,
request.method is equal to delete.
Okay, now let's see how we can do that.
First, right above that, we can use
an if statement to
inspect the request.query.
And if it has that _method endpoint,
then we want to change the request method.
And we want to set it to the
value from the request query,
get method, and then let's
just also make it uppercase.
You don't have to,
but it's probably a good practice
to keep this as uppercase,
okay, so now if we have that parameter,
we override the request method
and set the value to whatever
we pass in into URL.
With that we now can go back
to the UI and this all failed
horribly in the meantime,
which is okay, we'll go
back to the index page,
clear this up.
We add our first todo-item, okay.
We reloaded the page, that worked well,
and now if we click the delete button,
what happened is that
we got a status code 200
and our endpoint was still
a post request, fine.
That's nothing we can do about
because of the HTML specification,
but we ended up on the endpoint URL
and we got an empty object.
The empty object comes from the API file,
as I said, the body's an empty object.
In the case of delete,
we remove that todo-item and
we returned status code 200.
But just like with the post request
where we had to do a redirect
back to the index page,
we need to do the same
for our delete request.
Now, just to show you what happened
to the server, because
we executed this line,
but we never saw the result
of that item being removed.
If we go back to the index page,
you can see that the item is gone.
So the API actually works,
just the redirect didn't
happen back to the index page.
So one way to fix that
is to copy that return
down to the delete as well,
or really the pattern that
starts to emerge when we look
at that, is that if the
request.method is not get,
then we want to redirect
back to the homepage.
So we can do that down here,
that will be a lot easier
to read, so if the request.method
to uppercase, is not equals
to get, in that case,
we want to do that redirect 303.
So we can take that code and
replace that with a break
and then move it down here.
So now in the case of post
or delete, it will automatically
redirect back to the index
page as a 303 redirect.
So now there's one more thing we need
to do to satisfy the
REST API specification,
and that is when we do a post request.
When we add an item,
the return value of that API call
has to be the newly created item.
So after we do a todos.push
and add it to our array,
we need to set the body
equals to that new todo-item.
And the status code is 201,
which is the HTTP created status code.
That is basically a good point
to go back and see if that
if statement here worked and
let's have a look at that.
So we add an item and when we
click on the delete button,
it reloaded the page and
the item disappeared.
This is basically all we need
in order for the delete
endpoint to work at the moment.
So we did a lot of changes.
I think it's a good point
in time to commit that
because if we look at the
issue and we were working on,
the delete endpoint is now implemented,
so let's go have a look at the changes.
First of all, we created
a new UID JSON endpoint
with our delete request.
We consolidated a whole bunch
of code into an API file
where we now have a switch statement.
And depending on the HTTP method,
we process the request
and do certain things.
So we returned the elements,
or we create a new item in the array,
or we delete the item that we
specified in the request URL.
And then if it's not a get request,
we want to redirect back to
the homepage, so that people
don't end up on that empty
page of the endpoint.
And in any other case,
we just returned status and body.
Fantastic, this is a good
place to be at this point.
One more thing we want
to quickly review is
HTML forms only support
get and post methods.
So even though we would
like this to be delete,
we worked around it by using
a query parameter _method
where we specify what HTTP method
we really want it to be.
And thanks to the hooks file
in the source directory,
we can intercept that request
and overwrite the method
based on the query
parameter that we specified.
And then our way to
resolve here calls our API
and the request method is
now correctly set to delete.
Okay, let's go in and make some change,
make commit of all of that,
push it to our existing pull request
and then move on to updating an item.
So we see add delete endpoint.
And we sync the changes
and back to the pull request,
we have the delete endpoint here.
So here we can close all that again,
the environment we don't
need any more, drop that.
And with that,
we have the issue here and what is left,
delete is done, it's
now the patch endpoint,
which you can see based on the URL,
follows a very similar pattern
in order to also implement
that, so let's do this now.
We're making great
progress with our issue.
We've done three tasks
already, we have one left,
which is updating a todo-item.
It lifts at the same
URL where we need a UID
to specify which item we're updating.
And if we look at the
user interface real quick,
there are two things we need to implement.
One is the checkbox.
So marking an item as done
as well as somebody can edit a todo-item
by clicking on that text
and changing what's in it,
and then use the save icon
to persist these changes.
We will split that up into two parts.
So the first thing is we're
going to work on that editing
text, and then we will work on
editing the check mark last.
So edit text, let's implement that now.
And then we should be in good shape,
so develop CRUD endpoints,
this is our pull request,
still in draft and we spin up
a new developer environment so
we can work on that endpoint.
Should be fairly quick, and there we go.
Lots of stuff getting
up and running, cool.
So why do we want to do is...
We don't need this.
Over in source, routes, todos,
we created already a file
that has a dynamic UID where
we have the delete endpoint.
So right next to this, we want
to export the patch endpoint.
So that we can update the item,
same concept, export const patch,
and we use TypeScript
annotation in just a second.
For now, we just specify the function.
All right.
Now, a quick look at the post endpoint.
Remember when we get an HTTP
body that is being sent to us.
So in the patch request,
what will happen is the request
will contain the new text
that we want to add.
So we need to use the same
annotation as we had here
so that our body,
we will get the autocomplete
for the get functions
based on the FormData
that will be passed to us.
So we can copy that from the index file.
It's the same concept here
as well for the patch.
All right, now, looking
at an index file again.
Remember when we have a post endpoint,
we create an entire todo-item like this
with all the properties that
are required for a todo-item.
Now in the case of a patch,
we only get a text property.
So all we get is going to
be a request.body get text,
so let's have a look what happens.
We want to do the same as
with all the other endpoints.
So return API, and then we
want to pass in the request,
but we don't have a full todo-item.
So we want to just pass in a partial item,
and in this case, all we
have is a text, so request
request, yeah, it's all red at the moment.
That's okay, we'll figure
that out in just a sec
body get, and then the text.
This is the same as we had here.
So request body get text
and paste that here.
It says it cannot find a
request that's because we need
to specify it as a parameter
that we get passed in,
same as a delete request.
But now it's saying that
it's missing properties.
So UID created that.
That's because if you recall
the API file over here,
it expects a todo-item that is passed in.
It is optional, but if
we do pass a parameter,
it has to be a complete todo-item.
So we have two options.
One, just like we specify this parameter
to be optional with the question mark,
we could go to the global.TS
and make all these optional,
but then that kind of defeats
the purpose of using TypeScript.
So alternative here is that
we just change the type
in our API file.
And instead of a
todo-item being passed in,
we can say that you can
send as an argument,
you can pass any record or any object
that contains a key value pair.
And the way to do that
with TypeScript is that we
replace that todo with a record
of string and string for the time being.
And what that does for us is,
so we've got to close this.
So we can now pass a
object that contains text,
which you say a property and
the string has the value.
And with that,
this allows us to pass
in a partial todo-item.
So now, to be fair, this
is no longer a todo-item.
Really, this is more of a data parameter.
So to just name that more appropriately,
let's change it to data because
it's not a full todo-item.
Now, what we have is TypeScript
is now telling us that, Hey,
you have an array of
todo-items and you're trying
to pass in something
that is not a todo-item.
So even if you changed this to
data, which is our new name,
it will still complain.
Now we know as a fact
that the data we pass
in the case of a post request
is indeed a proper todo-item
because in our index file, right here,
we specify that the object we pass
is a proper todo-item.
We'll look at that in a second,
but for now what we can do,
we can tell TypeScript that, Hey, we are,
we are sure, we know what we're doing.
So we can say that this is a todo-item
where we pass in that data.
The reason it's still complaining
is because I said here
that we want the record to
be of string and string.
But if we look at the todo
definition in our global file,
not everything is a
string, some are dates,
some are Booleans.
So the way to get around that
is we can say that we don't
actually know what the value
is, it's unknown at this time.
So we can say unknown.
And with that TypeScript is now satisfied
that here we explicitly
say data is a todo-item.
And we can say that with
confidence because in the
index file, in our API, we
know we created a todo-item.
So with that, we go back
to our patch endpoint,
and that now properly creates
this object that just contains
the text, which is our new
item that we will create.
Good, now, patch request
we currently don't have a
handler here in our Svelte,
sorry, in our switch statement,
let's change that right now.
So what we do is after the delete,
we're gonna add a new case
for patch and eventually break from it.
And the status in this case will be 200
once that's all good.
But just like we're
here in the delete case,
delete an item.
We now have to go find
the correct todo-item.
So basically we're going
to loop through that array.
We look at each item in the array.
If we find the item that
has the correct UID,
we will update the item's text,
and that is some
JavaScript array work here.
So todos.map, an individual todo-item
we're going to look at,
and what we do here is
that if the todo.UID
maps to the request
params.UID we get passed in,
then let's update that item's text
equals the data.text
that is being passed in.
And we notice it's a string
in that case, because
in our patch request,
we set the text property
to a string that we get
from the request, so
we can tell TypeScript,
Hey, trust me, I know what I'm doing.
That data or text is of type string.
So that's when we find that
item, we update that todo.
And then in all the cases, we
want to return the todo-item
from our map, and now at the end of this,
we have an updated todos array
that contains the new text.
The last thing we need to
do is under lib todo-item,
we have our form at the bottom.
We already added the delete endpoint.
And the patch endpoint, as we know,
is in the same URL, just a patch.
So the safest thing to do
here is to copy that URL
from the delete and move it up here,
but it's not a delete
method, it's a patch method,
and then again, limitations
in the HTML form
is that we have to actually
send the post request,
which as you recall,
our hooks.JS file will revert or override
the request method if that
query parameter is available.
All right.
One last thing is our input field
doesn't have a name attribute yet.
And as you see here, we
are using the text value.
So let's go to our item and
specify a name equals text.
Whatever you put here, it
doesn't have to be text,
it could be anything you want,
but it has to match what's in our endpoint
that we read here.
That's the only thing
you need to worry about.
All right, let's have a look.
Let's do some inspecting
and let's add an item first.
Let's also add a second
item and then let's change
the text of the first to "first item"
and persist that item.
Now we have first item, if
we were to reload the page,
just to make sure first item
is still here, and with that,
we implemented the edit
functionality of a todo-item.
That was a lot less work
than the previous time
when we had to delete endpoint,
because we already reused
a bunch of functionality,
like the _method hack we
did to work around some
limitations we have with the
method we can use in the form.
All right, let's have a quick
look at what's going on.
We created a new patch
endpoint right here.
What we do is we call the API
and we pass in a new object
with just a text property
that we read from the request body.
The API, instead of expecting a todo-item,
it now expects any object in here.
And we used a little
bit of TypeScript magic
to tell TypeScript that we know
for sure in a post request,
we get a todo type data.
And then we implemented a patch
where we loop through all
the todo-items in the array.
If we find the one that has matching UID
with the request parameter, we
update the text, from there,
we return all the items
and the 200 status code
back to the browser.
All right, this is all we need for now,
so let's commit that,
add patch endpoint update text.
All right, yes.
We're going to push that,
close all our views here.
Don't need a developer
environment anymore, and now.
I may have just closed
that a little too early.
So I'll show you how you can
get your developer environment
back, if you go to Gitpod.io/workspaces,
and then you can see it here.
That's the one that was 14 minutes ago.
Yeah, it has unpushed commits,
so I shut that down just
a little bit too early,
not a big deal, we can
click the dots here,
we can open that environment back up,
and that is just going to take a second
and give us our environment back.
So as I mentioned, this is, you know,
if you have enough patience and wait
for the push to complete
and you don't have
to do that, but since I
didn't wait long enough,
we can just come back here
and switch over here and then
click that sync changes again
and wait until it gets properly pushed.
There we go.
And now we can go ahead
and shut that down again.
So good lesson,
if you do need to get an environment back
for whatever reason, GitPod.IO/workspaces,
and you will get access to this.
Alrighty, with that in
place, we have one more patch
to implement that is to
make the checkbox work.
And then once we do that,
we are feature complete
in terms of the API, we
can then add, read, update,
and delete todo-items.
Let's go build that
last piece and then have
that application feature
complete in terms of the API.
All right, let's move on,
go and start a new workspace
and then build that edit feature for the
marking an item is done
part of the application.
This one should be straightforward
because we already built
an edit feature for the
text of a todo-item.
So we can leverage that exact same code
that we have in place already.
Let's go have a look at how this works.
All right.
So starting out with the endpoint,
we go to source, routes, todos
and the [UID].JSON.TS file.
Now,
at the moment, we only
deal with a text property
that is being passed in by the web app.
So if we add one here real
quick, when we edit this text
and we submit it, then that
body has a text property.
What happens though,
when we click this button
and we submit a form
to the same endpoint as
the edit endpoint here?
So let's have a look in
source lib todo-item.Svelte.
If we scroll down to the HTML,
we have this input field
where we have a name done
and the value doesn't exist at the moment.
So the value we want to put in here is
either nothing or true if we
want to mark an item as done.
So let's have a look.
Basically we can use the
curly brackets to access
the todo item, and let's
do this first, todo.done.
So if the item we are rendering
is marked as done, then if
somebody clicks on the circle,
the value we want to
set in this field here
is an empty string.
Otherwise we want to
add the value of true.
So that then basically just toggles
between true and an empty string,
depending on whether the
item is toggled or not.
Now with that, we also can
update that aria label here,
because now we know whether
the item is done or not.
So let's do that, so we
can say mark todo as,
and then the string
here depends on whether
the item is done or not, so if it's done,
then we want to say not
done and otherwise done.
So now this says that,
if the todo-item is done,
then mark todo as not done, so flip it.
Otherwise we mark it as done.
Alrighty.
In order to test that, we need to go back
to our source, routes,
todos [UID].JSON.TS.
And now because we have
a name equals done,
we get an additional
parameter here potentially.
So let's go in and also
specify the done property.
And what we want to do is
if the request body
contains that done value,
then we want to make a
Boolean value out of it,
so request.body get the done.
And if we don't have the
done property available,
then we just say undefined, all right,
let's go have a look at the API
as well, so in our API file,
_API in the patch section.
Up to this point, we only
deal with the text value,
but now we also have a
potential done value.
So they will never be
set at the same time,
it's either text or done
that will be available
depending on whether we clicked the button
on the left or whether
we updated the text.
So we can deal with that
in our API by just simply checking here.
If the data dot text is available,
then we want to set that.
And the other thing we want to check is
that else, we can say we're
dealing with the done property
so we can see data.done,
and we know this a Boolean,
because we set it to a
Boolean or undefined.
Now, if there were more
features or properties,
then we could refactor that
slightly to make it more
readable, but this does the
trick for the time being.
And we can, you know, use
that as a good starting point.
Going back to the
todo-item Svelte component,
we need to provide the
action and the method.
Now that's the exact same as
for the editing text, right,
we are going to the same
endpoint so we can copy that
URL action from here, paste it,
and the method as always is post.
And with that, let's have a
look at the user interface.
Let's inspect, get the console back
in case there's something
interesting there.
So first we set that, let's
add a second one as well.
Nice.
Now let's check the second
one, mark this as done,
and it didn't update the user interface.
Hmm, why would that be?
Let's see if we reload.
Same thing, now, the reason for that is,
remember when we styled
the web application,
we commented out some of the work
because we didn't have a
way to mark an item as done.
So now remember here that
CSS, we set that a uncomment
when the API endpoints out available.
Now guess what, the NPI
endpoint are now available.
So we now have a way to
say whether this todo-item
is done or not, remember
the todo.done property,
we have access to whether
an item is done or not.
So let's first uncomment that code.
Svelte immediately tells us that
these are unused CSS
selectors, both of them.
And that's because we need to dynamically
add the done value here.
So we could use the same
concept where we say todo, done,
then at that, otherwise
don't add a class name.
Now let's have a look, and just like that,
the second item is now checked.
And visually you can see
it is marked as done.
If we uncheck it, it works,
we can check this one,
uncheck, perfectly valid,
but oh-my-God is this convoluted,
look at all this code to
specify whether this item
should have that class name or not.
It seems to me like this
is a lot of code that
it's also very fragile because
there's an empty string.
There's a done here.
So let's have a look at
what Svelte provides us
to make this a little
bit more maintainable.
Instead of doing some string
manipulations right here
within the class attribute,
we can use a second attribute,
which is a class and then colon.
Now, what we add here,
after the colon is the name of the class
we want to add conditionally
in our case, this is done value.
And in order to specify whether or not
we want to set that class,
we can use equals todo.done.
Now Svelte conditionally adds or removes
that class from that element depending on
whether the value in the
curly brackets is true.
Just to make sure this works,
let's go back and add an item.
There we go, well, okay,
it reloaded from the
server, so it's all good.
We can drop it.
All right, that works.
If we had a variable in our script
at the top that is called done,
then we could drop that
entire part here as well..
We don't have one called done,
but if I were to go up here in the script
and I would say, const done equals
todo.done, and we now can do that.
So if the variable exists
that has the same name as the
class name we want to add,
we can just say class and the name,
and then Svelte will
automatically toggle that.
Now I think this is one way to do it,
I don't think it's necessary in this case,
there's a lot of good use cases for that.
In our case, I think this is fine enough
to just read from the
todo object directly.
But that gives us basically
the user interface
where we can add items,
we can mark them as done.
We can remove them all by
using the user interface.
Now I showed it once before.
I think it's worth mentioning again,
to just remind you, if we
go to the developer settings
and we go to debugger
and disabled JavaScript,
that website, I can reload
it just to make sure,
I can still go ahead
and work with that API
and the website exactly the
same way as we've always done.
So there's no JavaScript
whatsoever being used right now
to make this web application work.
And this is something that I
think has been forgotten a bit
recently that the web could
easily work without JavaScript.
And it used to for a matter
of fact, many years ago.
So I think it's very important
to keep that in mind,
there is a lot of people
that have low powered devices
to access the internet and
JavaScript is making this hard
and slow for many people in the world.
So if we do want to provide
a slightly better user experience
for people that have JavaScript enabled,
then we can do that.
We can enhance this application so that
if JavaScript is available,
we are able to leverage it.
And instead of, you know,
doing a full page refresh,
if I delete an item,
that does a redirect back
to the homepage and reloads
the entire page, all this code,
we can speed that up
and we'll do that next.
But for now, let's close this preview,
have a quick look at what
we've changed in our code.
First of all, we added a new done property
when we call the API.
The API is extended so
that our patch can deal
with text and todo
done text and done properties.
And lastly, we have
the todo-item updated where
we could finally uncomment
our CSS when a item is
called, I will mark this done.
And we then learned how we
can add a class dynamically
to an item or an element here,
depending on whether
an item is done or not.
Alright, this is a good
place to commit all that.
So we call this add the patch endpoint
and the value for it is
mark as done, for example.
Okay now sync the changes.
Make sure you wait until that's all done.
And we have that available here.
So now it's a safe time to
shut down our workspace.
That'll disappear, and
with that, we can also
go back to our issue
and we have that patch implemented.
With that, our pull request
is no longer in draft,
ready for review.
Somebody on our team can
help us review the changes.
And then we can go ahead
and merge that PR, delete the branch.
So with that, we have
fully functioning API
ready to go, and the
application is nice and working.
So we're going to look
at a few more things now
and make good progress
throughout the course.
So stay tuned, more to come.
Okay, what do we want to do now
is leverage a feature from Svelte
called actions in order
to enhance the HTML forms
for visitors of our application
that have JavaScript enabled.
So we've got a new issue
called enhanced HTML forms.
We start a new Gitpod workspace
for that specific task.
And what we're going to do
now is basically find all the
HTML forms that we have and
use this new Svelte action
that we are going to
create that will help us
to make an AJAX request
instead of a full page refresh.
I'll show you what I mean by that.
If we come here and we add a
new item currently by hitting
enter here, you remember
it reloads the entire page.
It adds the item, and then
redirect back to the homepage,
which means it downloads
all the CSS, the HTML,
and all the code.
We really want to just
make an AJAX request
to the endpoint, add the
item to our array in the API,
and then update the UI accordingly.
So the way we can do that
is by using Svelte actions.
And Svelte actions are very powerful tool.
Well-documented at Svelte.dev
but I'll walk you through
and teach you everything you need to know.
The first thing we want to
do is create a new action
and an action is really just a function.
So I like to have them
under source lib, and then
in the actions directory,
and in our case, we're
going to call it form.TS.
So in here we just have
to export a function
and the name of that function
will become the name of our action.
So export const, let's call this enhance
because we will enhance the HTML form
with additional functionality
in case JavaScript is enabled.
So it's a function and
that's basically it.
Now with actions,
there is a parameter being
passed to us by Svelte
that represents the HTML element
that we use the action on.
So in our case,
we will use that enhance
action for HTML forms.
So Svelte automatically passes us a form.
And with TypeScript, we know
this is an HTML form element,
and this is passed into
us into this action.
So before we go any further,
let's see how we can use
that in the code of our Svelte component,
we copy the name and we
go to source roots index.
And here in the top,
we want to first import our new function
or action, same thing.
So import enhance from,
and remember the shortcut
to go to a source lib.
We can use the dollar sign lib slash,
now we can see our new actions directory,
and within that, the form file.
Alrighty, with that we can go down
and we'll start by enhancing the form
to create a new todo-item.
So we can use an action by saying use,
and then the name of our action.
As I mentioned Svelte provides a reference
to the element we use the action on.
So this is on the form element
and that's why the parameter
we get is a form
parameter into our action.
So let me show you what happens.
Before we go any further,
let's just do console log
action executed for example.
If we switch to the UI
and we clear the console
and we reload that page.
You can see that
as soon as the HTML form
gets mounted to the DOM,
we can see that the action got executed.
Okay, so now this means at that point,
we can start to interact with
the form using JavaScript
in our action to intercept
the submit request.
And then instead of
doing a full page reload,
we can just send an Ajax
request before we get there.
I'm going to show you one more thing
that is extremely important to
know when you build actions.
And in order to do that,
I'm going to rename that
text form mounted to DOM.
Now, anything you do
in the enhance function
here or in your action,
keep in mind that this
action gets executed
every time the HTML element
gets added to the DOM.
So if we navigate from one page
to another and we come back,
that enhanced function is called again.
Let me demonstrate that
so that we can then see a few things.
I'm going to under source routes,
I create a new file
called about-us.Svelte.
And for now this just contains
an H1 element, about us,
and a link that brings us back
to the homepage like that.
And that will just move us back.
On the index page itself under the title,
I'm adding an anchor that
brings us to about us
so we can navigate between
the two pages easily.
All right, do that, clear things.
We reload the page
and you can see that the
form is mounted to the DOM.
And now, oh there we go,
had to refresh, hot module
reloading kicked in.
So it got mounted to the DOM.
And now if we click the about
us, we load the about us page,
and if we go back,
you can see that the form
mounted to DOM appears again.
This is extremely important to know,
because anything we do in our action
happens every time the HTML
element gets added to the DOM.
So navigating between back and forth,
we have to somehow clean up
everything we do in here.
For example if we were to add
an event listener or create something
in memory or whatever,
we'll have to clean that up
when the HTML form gets
removed from the DOM.
So when we navigate away from the page or
the element gets removed from
the DOM, for any other reason.
To do that, the convention
is that we can return
an object from our action that
contains a destroy function.
And in that destroy function, we can
print form removed from DOM.
And now if we have a look at the console,
when we load the page,
you can see the form, mounted to the DOM.
When we navigate away, the
form was removed from the DOM.
And then when we come back,
the form is mounted again.
So anything we do in the action,
it is very important that we
undo, you know, in air quotes,
everything we did so that
we have no memory leaks,
and we don't accidentally add
multiple like event listeners.
And then all of a sudden our
code executes multiple times,
things like that.
So with that knowledge in mind,
let's have a look at
what we really want to do
in order to make the user
experience a bit better
for people with JavaScript enabled.
When somebody actually,
before we do that, hold on,
let's clean this up, we
don't need the about us page.
And in our index file, we
no longer need the link.
We've proven that this does
what it's supposed to do.
So now when somebody submits this form,
we currently send,
or we let the browser
send an HTTP post request
to the endpoint that we
specified in the form here.
And then that redirects us back.
So what we really want to do
is we don't want the browser
to take care of that.
If JavaScript is enabled, we
want to tell the browser, Hey,
thank you for your service,
but we don't really need your help here.
We can take care of sending
the content of this text field,
to the API, process the API response,
and then we'll update UI automatically.
So we don't need to
reload the entire page.
The way we do that is in our action,
under source, lib, actions, form,
we have access to the HTML form.
So what we can do is we're
going to drop these console logs
because we know they do
what they're supposed to do.
So here we can say form.addEventListener,
and we can listen to
the form's submit event.
That's when the browser usually kicks in
and does its post request to the API,
and we need to give it a function
or a listener that will be
executed when that event
happens, so let's call this
handleSubmit, and then let's
create a function here,
handleSubmit, and
as I said, anything we do in our action,
we have to undo it in
the destroy function.
So when we move away to another
page, we want to say form
removeEventListener, submit,
and the event listener we want to remove
is our handleSubmit function.
So with that,
we have the basic structure
in place of our action,
where we add event listener, when the DOM,
the element, it gets added
to the DOM and we remove it
when the element gets
removed from the DOM.
So what do we want to do
when a form gets submitted?
The very first thing is we
want to tell the browser
to not do the default behavior.
As I said, the default behavior
is to send a post request
to the endpoint that is
specified in the HTML.
So in this case,
send in a post request to
that todos item endpoint.
Let's not do that.
Now, because this is a regular
event listener that we added,
we get a parameter passed in
here, which is called an event.
And that's just of type event
if we wanted to use TypeScript here.
And on that event,
we have a function that's
called prevent default
that tells the browser, Hey,
don't do your default behavior.
I will take care of it.
So let's see what that
does to our user interface.
Clear out, network, clear.
Alright, we add a second
item and we submit,
I think that did not load,
let's try it one more time.
Clear, add a third item and submit it.
If you hit enter, nothing happens.
And that's exactly what we want.
And that's also what we
said, don't do anything.
However because we told the browser
not to do its default behavior,
it is now up to us to make this
HTTP request to the backend.
So let's have a look.
Whenever we deal with an HTTP request,
it's probably a good idea
to wrap it up in a try-catch
because things could go wrong,
the API could be unavailable.
There could be any other
errors that may occur.
So if that happens, if we do
get an error for some reason,
let's just say console.error
for the time being
fetch error and eventually
specify what is wrong.
We'll do that in a second.
Okay.
How do we make an HTTP
request from a website?
Well, the solution to that is using fetch
and we have to go to some
kind of endpoint here
endpoint, alright, now
fetch is asynchronous,
so we have to await it and
we will then get a response.
Since we use now await,
we have to make the handler
asynchronous, we'll do async.
All right.
We'll figure it out, that
endpoint in just a second.
But for now, we now have a response that
if something does go wrong,
then we can do something with it.
So the let's change this here
to could not submit the form.
And the error we get is
whatever error we have.
All right, first things first,
how do we figure out what's
the endpoint of our form?
If we look at the index file, the endpoint
we want to use this value
within the action property.
Remember that our action we
are defining here is generic
so that we can use it for
any form on the application.
We don't want this to be very
specific to just one form.
And the good thing is that if
we look at the form elements
that we defined under
source lib todo-item,
and we go down all these forms,
they specify the action attribute
that we want to use for our HTTP request.
So the good news here is that
we do get a form passed in
as an attribute here, or as a parameter.
So let's have a look.
What if we look at
what's inside that form,
do we have, ah, we have
the action property.
Okay, that's exactly what we want.
We want to use that action
as the URL for our request.
So this is a good start, now,
if we don't specify any more
parameters for the fetch call,
then the default request
method would be get.
But as you know, we want
this to be post like here,
so we can just like access
the action attribute,
we can access the method as well.
So we can pass in a second
argument to the fetch function
and we call this method and the
value is whatever we specify
in the form method attribute.
Alrighty, there's one
more thing we need to do.
So in the case of creating a todo-item
or updating an item, we
need to send the fields,
the input fields that we
specify within the form.
And in order to do that,
we can leverage a pretty nifty feature.
So let's specify,
let's say a body and
the way we can do this,
we can use new FormData, pass in the form.
Does this look familiar, FormData?
In fact, I still have it open as a tab.
We looked at that earlier on
the Mozilla developer page.
And if we switch over to the roots todos,
the UID or the index, so index.post here,
remember we specified the FormData
that is being sent as a body.
This is exactly what we're doing here.
We create the body as a new
instance of the FormData.
And now in our request,
we can specify a body attribute.
And since it's the same
as the variable name,
we can just leave it like
that instead of doing this
short form is just using body.
So now we are sending a request
to the action with the
correct method and the body,
but there's one more thing we can do
that is, we can specify
that we accept a JSON response.
So let's have a look, we
can pass in headers as well.
So headers, and what
do we say here is, Hey,
we accept application/JSON,
and this will come in handy
in just a second and I'll show
you why, for now, let's just,
you know, make this request,
we get a response, and then we want
to do something with that response.
So let's go here and say
that if the response is ok,
then we want to console log API response.
And for the time being, we just say await.
So what is happening here?
We basically just pick the
JSON response that we get
from the server and what just
print it into the console.
If something goes wrong, let's say else,
we want console error, fetch error.
And we will just take whatever
the response text attribute
is like, if something happened there,
then the response will
contain some information
of what went wrong.
And we can leverage that
to display an error message
in the console for now.
Okay, so we did a lot of stuff here.
Now, what do we want to go check is
what happens when we submit that request.
Let's go back here and
let's reload the page.
Clear all that.
Let's go and create a third
item, and we submit it.
Interesting, look at that.
First of all, it didn't do any
redirect, which is, you know,
kind of good news, however,
it tried to, see this?
So a post request 303
is the response code.
And it tried to redirect
back to that index page.
So why is that, well, because
we configured it that way,
obviously, there's a POST request.
And if we go to our API
source routes todos API,
you recall that we say that if
the request method is not get
then redirect to the index
page, ha that's a problem.
We only want to do that redirect
when the browser submits
the form on its own,
so when JavaScript is disabled.
If JavaScript is enabled
and we submit the form
through our action right
here, in that case,
we don't want to do a redirect
and instead we just want
to return the response
and then we parse it here
and we print the value, right?
All right so let's have a look
at how we can go about that and make sure
we can differentiate whether
the browser submitted
the request or whether we did.
Now, I already did a little
bit of work here upfront.
I added a new header that
says accept application/json.
The browser doesn't do that
when it submits the form,
the value for that is
different in that case.
But because we are
specifying application/json
by ourselves, when JavaScript is enabled,
we can leverage that in our
API file and enhance our
if statement so that we are not
only looking for the request
method, but it also checking
the header that we specified.
So here we say and request headers accept,
that's the one we specified
is not equals to application/json.
Probably a good time to move
that to a new line, okay,
with that, we now have the check
so they shouldn't do a redirect anymore
when we sent the request,
let's see if that's the case.
Because we changed our API
file, the server reloaded,
and it cleared our items.
That's okay, we'll just add them again.
So we add a first,
that, okay, hang on, let's
clear this, it will be easier.
We'll do that again.
We'll add a second.
And now look at that,
we only have one request
and if we move things around here a bit,
you can see it's a post
request, the status code is 201,
and you can see that the
payload was text second,
that's what we created.
And the response that we
got back from the server
is a full todo-item,
including the created at,
the UID, the text, done false.
This is fascinating, this
is all we really need.
And in fact, all we need to do now is
update the user interface
to make sure we showed
that item in the UI.
At the moment, if I were
to refresh the page,
you can see that our two items are here.
That's because the GET request
fetches everything from
the server and displays it.
But we want to do that dynamically.
And the way we can do that
is because we're dealing with JavaScript,
we also can modify that list
and do so in a pretty dynamic way.
Let's look at how we do that.
At the moment, when we
have a successful result,
we just print API response
out to the console.
So if we look at that,
I disappeared because I reloaded the page.
We can do it again, if I add a third item,
we can see the API response here.
Now let's take that information
and update the user interface.
And the way we do that is,
instead of just printing,
we have to update the user
interface in the index file.
Let's have a look.
In the index file, we
have that enhance action.
So somehow when the request
is made to the server
from our action, and we
get the response back,
at this point right here,
we need to update the user interface here.
So the number of todos
that we have in this array,
we need to push in our new item
that the server sent back to us.
With that, we can then
let Svelte to do the rest
of the matching and
just rerender that array
and display a new todo-item.
But how do we access that
array that we get in as a prop?
There's some good news.
And the good news is that we
can pass additional parameters
to our action.
The form is given to us by Svelte,
but we can add our own parameters as well.
And that's exactly what
we're going to do, so
in order to make this more
flexible going forward,
let's add an object as
an additional parameter.
And what we will pass in is a function
that we named result.
Why do we do that?
Because this enhanced action will be used
across multiple forms.
The behavior of the success
case is going to be different.
When we add an item, we
want to add it to a list.
When we edit it, we
want to update an item.
And when we delete a todo-item,
we want to remove it
from our list in the UI.
So because of that,
we basically pass in that function,
again, you could call
it whatever you want,
but then instead of printing that text,
what did we will do is
we will call that result function here,
and we will pass the response.
We could pass the todo object or whatever.
The fact that I'm passing
response allows us
to be more flexible in the user interface,
where we could read values
from the response such as
the status or things like
that, if we wanted to, you know
react to that in certain ways.
This is, you know, up
to you how much you want
to pass through here, in our case,
we'll pass the response
and let the user interface
deal with whatever it
wants to do with that.
So that's good.
Now, how do we get access to that?
How can we pass that result in here?
Very straightforward,
TypeScript already tells us that
it expects two arguments,
but it got only one.
So we're missing that object
with the result function.
So here's how we can do that.
Similar to how we defined
the conditional class.
Previously, we can say, use:enhance,
and then equals JavaScript,
and then the object here.
So what's going on,
the inner brackets represent
the second parameter here.
So that part, and the outer brackets,
they are there just like
we used them down here
to tell Svelte that we are
doing some dynamic work here.
All right, so now what
we need to pass in here
if we do control space, it
expects a result property.
So let's do a new line result.
And the result
is a function we are going
to specify in our script
where we push an item
into due todos array.
So let's have a look.
We'll just call that for
now, processNewToDoResult.
And then let's go define
that function up here.
So const equals, let's
make a function first,
and then as you remember
from the enhance action,
we call the result with an
argument called response.
So that means that in our
index file, oops, sorry,
process new todo result,
we get a response.
Pass in parameter.
We can use TypeScript to
specify what type that is.
And what do we want to do here now is
read the item that is
being sent back to us,
just like we printed
it to the console here.
We can use that await res JSON, grab it,
make sure we remove that line
because you can only call
that JSON function once on a response.
So remove that.
And in here, we can now
say const new todo equals
await response JSON.
And we have to mark this
as an async function
because we're awaiting.
Now, this is an object that
contains everything we need
to know about the new todo-item.
We saw that in the console
previously with the UID,
created at, all that information.
Excellent, now all that's
left to do is update the,
todos array inject that new object.
So you would be inclined
to likely do, todos push new todo.
Now in Svelte, that doesn't
quite work because in order
for Reactivity to kick in,
and Svelte to rerender that
todos array, what do we have
to do is reassign the array
of that variable, which is not a big deal.
We can change the code
here and say todos equals
a new array with the old todo-items
plus the new todo-item appended to it.
And with that, we can now go
back to the user interface
and reload that page, there
was a lot of code going on.
And first, second, third,
let's go clear some things
and add our fourth item.
We hit enter, and you can see
one request to the backend.
The fourth item shows up instantly
in the UI, but it didn't
clear out our input field,
that's a bit annoying.
The user experience here is not great,
so we can easily fix that back here
at the end, once we updated
the list, it would be great
if we could clear that form
and reset it to its default values,
which would be an empty
string for the input field.
So luckily in our action,
where we call the result,
we also have access to the
form that we are using.
So we can just pass that in as a prop
as a argument here, form.
And then in the index file
where we have our function,
we now also get a form which
is of type HTML form element
with that, we can now say form.reset,
and that will clear the form
back to its default values.
Let's have a look.
First of all, let's
delete a few things here.
All right, clear that.
So we'll add our third
item and we hit enter.
It gets added and the form
gets immediately reset.
Okay, this is a very nice, one request,
if JavaScript is enabled,
if we go here to the developer settings
we disable JavaScript and
we were to add a fourth item
and submit that form,
you can see that now
the submission happened
by the browser and it used
the 303 redirect to come back,
but the functionality still works
even if JavaScript is disabled
we used that before, we saw it.
But if it's enabled,
we get that nice little performance boost
by just sending a single request
and then use JavaScript to
perform the addition to the UI.
Nice.
So we created the functionality
to add a todo-item and
we have a very generic
form action that we call enhance.
Now let's go ahead and add
that enhance function to
all our other forms as well.
So marking an items done,
editing and deleting.
The way we do that
is we switch to the todo-item component,
and at the top we import the action.
So we can go to the index
file and grab it from here.
Now, even though the index
file and the todo-item
are in different places
in the file system,
thanks to the $lib,
we can just copy paste that import.
And now we have our enhance function here.
So the first thing we
want to do is let's start
on the right side and do the
delete action, first, go down.
This is our delete form
with the delete todo functionality.
So over here, use, enhance
and pass in a result.
And then we call this, let's say, process,
the deleted todo result.
And we go and define that
function up in the script.
So now we have a challenge,
in order to delete that todo-item
once it's removed from the server,
that function will be called
by our action, but we
don't really have access
to the array of todo-items
so that we can remove it from that array.
The only thing we have access to
is that item that no longer exists.
So we have to find a way
to access the todos
array in our index page,
just like with the adding a new item,
we can get the existing
items and add a new one.
We need access to deleting
an element from this array.
The good news is with Svelte
and Svelte components,
we can just use a prop the same way that
we pass in the todo-item.
We can also expect a prop to be a function
that we can use to delete that item.
Let's see we can export, let our function,
and just like we specified
todo-item to be a todo type.
The prop here is going to be a function
that receives a rest
parameter, which is a response,
and it will have no
return value, so avoid.
All right, now, all we need to
do is back in the index file,
we now get an error saying
that the todo-item expects
the additional property
that we just specified.
And the way we can do that
is we add it here just like the todo,
we can pass in a new function
that doesn't exist yet,
but it will in just a second,
where right here, next to
the one, we create an item,
we can say const equals
and make this just a function.
Alrighty.
And then remember it receives
a response, actually
let's do this differently.
I'll show you another
trick, let's delete this.
And instead what are we going to do
is we're going to define the prop here,
but instead of writing the code off,
we'll write it right in line.
The reason we do that is
because we need access to
the existing todo-items so
that we can read its UID.
So this is a regular function.
We can just pass that in here.
And we say todos equals,
and then we filter them.
And we say that an individual todo,
if the UID is not equals to the todo UID,
then keep it, otherwise drop it.
So now we'll remove the current todo,
if the ID matches to the one
that we are filtering through.
Let's see what that does
to the user interface.
Let's just make sure we have
JavaScript set correctly.
Yup, JavaScript is enabled.
We clear console and we
delete the fourth item.
Yeah, okay, we have to
refresh the page real quick.
Let's try that one more time.
And we do delete the third
item, that sent a request,
if we look at the details,
was a post request,
but it had the method delete
in the query parameter.
That was our workaround for the form.
And then what it did is remove
that item from the UI and from the server.
All right.
So what's missing now is editing
both marking as done and adding the text.
This can be achieved the exact same way
as we did for the delete
and the adding a new item.
So let's follow that same pattern.
In the todo-item itself,
we already have a prop that we passed
in here to delete the result.
Let's add a new one process
updated todo result.
And then in our forms, further down,
here we go, we want to add
new actions, so we used that
same enhance action enhance,
and we want to pass in
the result being that.
And the same is going to
apply to the first form
where we check it off as done.
So here, we may as well
just copy that entire thing.
There we go, we can paste here.
And with that,
we now have to specify the
behavior of that function.
And as we noticed, this passed
in as a prop to our todo-item component.
So in the index,
it will expect that we define
that function here as well.
So we don't really need to do much
other than just passing that in
and making sure everything is fine.
So hold on, probably a good
time to clean this up a bit
add the new properties on new lines.
And then we also had the, oops.
This new process updated todo,
and in this case, what we
could do is define that
up in the scripts, doesn't
have to be down there inline.
So we can say const
equals a function.
And as always,
what we get passed in here is
a response of type response.
It will be async
And what we do inside now is we do const,
similar to how we fetched the new item,
we say, give me the updated item.
So const updated todo await
JSON, and then the updated todo,
we need to go through
the list of todo-items
and update the array with the
new item that was updated.
The way we do that is todo equals
we map over all of them.
And here we just say
that if the current item
we are iterating over,
if the UID equals to the updated items,
updated to do the UID,
then return our updated item and
otherwise just return the one
we already had in the array
and don't bother about it.
All right, now,
one thing we forgot to
do when we built the API
is that you see that when we update
an item, we expect the
server response to include
a copy of the new item, just like we do
when we create an item,
the server replies with
the newly created element.
We need to update our API to also include
the updated todo item from that response.
If we go back to the API and
we look at the patch case,
you notice that we have a
status, but we have no body.
And if we look at the post,
we return the element that we received.
So in the patch case,
the element we want to
return is whichever element
that was just updated as part
of this map function here.
So we can specify this
by saying body equals,
and then we'd just go
find that element in here.
So if the element we are iterating over
its UID maps to the request params UID.
Then please, you know,
give us that element and we'll
return it back into body,
send it to the client where
we then update the UI.
So let's have a look at
what's going on here.
Let me clear all this.
And we add a first item that
went ahead, added the item,
it downloaded, you can see
the images here, inline SVGs,
because it's the first time
we have that edit button.
We can now rename that to first item
that just sends a request to
that endpoint, nothing else.
And then the UI gets updated
automatically and we can mark
them as done as well, that's
the other feature we built.
You see it's another
request marking is done
and we can get rid of it too.
So with that, we developed
a web application
that works with JavaScript disabled.
And if somebody has JavaScript enabled,
we enhanced the forms to leverage
that and use Ajax requests
instead of full HTML form submissions.
This is a good point in time to commit,
we did a lot of work here,
but this was all necessary
to make sure our application
behaves nicely for everybody
depending on their preferences
and settings of their browsers,
whether JavaScript is enabled or not.
Let's do a quick recap.
The first thing is we made
a small change to our API
so that the PATCH request now
returns the updated element.
We also enhanced our function
here saying that we only want
to do to redirect if the
browser submitted the HTML form.
If the client accepts an HTTP
or an application/json, then
we don't want to do that.
Most importantly, we added
a new action called enhance.
The action receives a form
that represents the element
where we used the action
and an object with a result function
so that we can update the UI
when we get a response back.
As an exercise for the viewer,
you could go ahead and enhance
that second object to expect
an error function as well, so
that if something goes wrong,
you could call the error
function and update the user
interface to show to the user
that something went wrong
and they should retry again.
I'll leave that up to the
viewers as an exercise,
since we want to move on and, you know,
focus on building the full,
all the backend stuff,
the API that connects to the
database and persists the item
instead of just using an array in memory.
Okay, so this is a good place
to commit all these changes
and close that PR that
we're about to open.
So enhance HTML forms.
We'll go ahead and push that
and then create a new pull request
that we want to slightly rename,
make this a bit more readable.
And here we say in the
description close issue number 11.
And with that, we can
create a pull request.
All right, give that a
second to do all this work.
Now, if we look here, we have the new PR
and we are ready to merge and move on
so merge PR, delete the branch.
Just as a reminder, never
review your own code.
Always ask a colleague to do that.
I don't have a colleague
available right now,
so I'll do this myself and
then our developer environment
on Gitpod, we can go and throw this away,
no need for that anymore.
And with that,
we completed that part where
we enhance the HTML forms
so that we can now leverage
Ajax requests where needed
It is no time to move on
and look at the rest of the architecture.
So let's go ahead and start
working on the database.
Okay, time to move on.
Before we work on that database setup
for our developer environment,
let's quickly recap where
we are in the architecture.
We've developed the frontend with Svelte.
We developed an API using SvelteKit.
We had our REST API in SvelteKit exposed
so that we can communicate with
the frontend and vice versa.
Now it's time to focus on the second part
of the architecture,
where we persist the todo-items
in the database instead of
where they currently are, which
is in memory on the server.
So having a look at
the final architecture,
we're going to start
with a Postgres database
in the developer environment
so that we can test
the end-to-end flow from the
front end through the API
via Prisma over to the
database and all the way back.
We want to do all of that in
the local developer environment
or in our case on a Gitpod workspace
so that we know all the code is in place
before we deploy the
application to production.
If you follow along on
your local computer,
this is the point where you have
to go over to the Postgres website.
And so PostgreSQL.org
and click the download
button here in the banner
or up in the header, there's
a download link as well.
And depending on which operating
system you use locally,
please select the appropriate
installation instructions here
and follow along to set up
that database on your local computer.
If you follow along using Gitpod,
then all we need to do is
just make a one-line change
in our gitpod configuration
in order to get access to Postgres.
So that's what I will be focusing on
in the next couple of minutes.
So we have an issue to install
and start the dev database.
We click the Gitpod button to
start a developer workspace
for that particular issue.
And that is pulling the
container image just like it's
always done, it will also
start the development server.
So we will see the preview
of the web application.
At this point we don't need that
because we are not
focusing on the frontend
so we can close the tab.
And we are now back on that
development environment.
So the developer server
here, we can go work on.
We don't need to get started
and if we open the Gitpod
YAML file in the root
at the moment we have not configured
which image we want to use.
So which Docker container
to use as our environment.
That totally fine and Gitpod
just uses a default image
that comes with a various languages
and frameworks pre-installed.
But now we have a special interest
in getting Postgres installed,
so we have two options.
One, we could specify a Docker
container in our source code
and then tell Gitpod to
use that Docker container.
So if we have special libraries
or operating system dependencies,
we have full control over
what the base image looks like
for our developer environment.
However, in our case all we care about
is that we have Postgres
installed and started.
So the way we can do it is
we can use the image property
and we specify Gitpod/workspace-Postgres.
So this is an image that Gitpod maintains
and provides to people who
use the environment here.
If you want to see what else is available,
head over to
github.com/gitpod-io/workspace-images.
And you will see a list of other images
you can base your environment on.
So if you work in Flutter or
with a Flutter application,
you can use that as a default image.
The same for PostGres, the
one we use MySQL, MongoDB,
and a few others.
As again, as I said, if you
want your own Docker image,
that's an option too.
And the Gitpod documentation
explains how you can configure that.
In our case, all we need
is the workspace-Postgres.
And because we are now
starting a development server
for this Postgres database,
Gitpod will automatically realize
that there's a new port available on 5432,
which is the default port for Postgres.
So if we do nothing else,
other than adding this line for the image,
every time we start a new
Gitpod developer environment,
we will get a popup at
the bottom here saying
that a service is listening on port 5432.
We don't really want that
because we don't need to know.
We know what the database
is installed and running,
so we can add another port
definition to our ports array,
where we just say port 5432.
And when we open the workspace,
we want to ignore that port,
that just makes sure that nothing gets
displayed at the bottom yet,
the port will be available
so we can connect with a database client.
That's all the changes there
are for this pull request.
We literally just added one line here
to base our development
environment on a new image
that contains Postgres.
And we said that let's ignore port 5432.
Next step is we commit these changes
and create a pull request.
Now I already did that
off-camera so for the time being,
I can just shut this
environment down and close it,
and then you can see, I already
have a pull request here.
If we look at that,
then you can see that I
made the same changes,
GitPod workspace Postgres and port 5432.
If we start an environment
based on that new configuration
file, so we click the
Gitpod button on the side,
and now it's using that
new underlying Docker image
that contains the database.
So we're going to give
that a second to download
all the dependencies and
spin up the environment.
And then we can see
that port is available,
and also, we now have a CLI
to connect to the Postgres
environment, that database
that we started up.
So let's just wait until things start up.
There's the preview of our
app, we don't need that.
And back here, we can
close to get started.
If we're heading over
to the Remote Explorer,
you can see now we have a
new port available 5432,
that is our database.
And if we open new terminal,
so on the right side up here,
we can click the plus to
create a new terminal.
And now if we type psql,
then that connects us
to the Postgres database
that is installed on our
computer in our environment here
the GitPod environment.
And now everybody who works
on this project using Gitpod,
they will automatically
have Postgres installed
and started up as soon as
the workspace is ready,
and they don't have to
follow any instructions
on how to download Postgres
onto their local laptop.
This is all automatically
configured for them.
This is a great point in time
to commit, we already did,
we have a pull request and we validated
that we can login to that database.
So we are going to shut this down.
And we know we satisfied that PR.
So we installed and
started a dev database.
We can now go ahead and merge
that pull request, confirm
the merge, drop the branch.
And with that, we are now
ready to start the integration
with the database and the API.
What an exciting part
to be working on next.
We are finally going to find
a way to connect our API
with the Postgres
database that we installed
in our developer environment,
just minutes ago.
As part of the architecture,
we are going to work on that
Prisma part here, so the glue,
if you wish between the API
and the Postgres database,
it will help us interact with the database
and the database's response,
depending on what we do.
And we can just use
TypeScript or JavaScript
in this case where we can
call methods to add items
and fetch items and Prisma
will do all the hard work
of converting between SQL
queries and JavaScript objects.
If you've ever worked with an ORM before
or have written your own raw SQL queries,
Prisma will be an
absolute mindblowing tool
and seriously increase
your developer experience.
We will see that as we go
through the configuration,
if you combine it with
Gitpod and automate a lot
of the steps, then you'll
get the best of both worlds.
Now, before we dive in, we
are working with prisma.io.
So having a look at that,
lots of information here,
fantastic documentation
that they've put together
with all the details we need to know.
I will walk you through everything we need
in order to get this
application up and running.
And if you need more
or want to learn more,
then Prisma.io is the place to go.
Okay, in GitHub, we have
an issue ready for us,
use Prisma ORM.
So we'll spin up a new
Gitpod developer environment.
And once that's ready,
we can start by installing
the Prisma command line interface.
That's a NPM package that
helps us integrate with Prisma
and run certain commands to
make things easier for us.
So giving Gitpod another second here
to spin up the environment,
and then we'll be off to the
races and can get started.
Here's our editor.
And in the second, we will
also see the terminal,
our preview of the web application,
which at the moment we don't need,
this is a bit of a distraction.
So we'll just close that browser tab
and get rid of the get started section.
We also don't really need
the development server
to run so we can click
into the terminal control C
to cancel that, what we
do want to do, clear,
is we want to install that Prisma CLI.
And the way we do that is
by typing npm install -D
so that it gets saved as a dev dependency.
And the package name is prisma.
If we run that, it gets it all installed.
And now we can access the
node_modules bin directory,
where we have a Prisma executable.
And this is how we access
that new package's CLI,
that's a lot to type.
So the alternative to
that path is to use npx
and then the name of the
CLI that we want to call.
Before we go any further,
I want to show you what
Prisma Studio is all about.
Prisma Studio is a web
application that connects
to our database and we can
then inspect the tables
and the rows and the
columns of our database.
So we can validate that
the information we send
from the API to the
database gets correctly
persisted or updated, depending
on the action we perform.
So in order to start the studio,
we can see npx prisma studio
and start that by hitting enter.
At this time, this will
fail and we will see why.
Error, could not find
a schema.prisma file.
So the schema.prisma file
contains the necessary information
for Prisma to understand
everything it needs
to know about our database,
such as what's the database provider,
what's the URL to connect to it,
and what does the database look
like in terms of its schema,
what tables are available,
what columns are within these tables,
and what kind of types are these columns.
So if we read the error message carefully,
we noticed that at the bottom,
it tells us that the
default location of the file
is a Prisma directory slash schema.prisma.
So if we take that path, we copy it.,
and in our root, in the editor,
we create a new file for
Prisma slash schema.prisma
that generates the file that we need.
And now we can go ahead
and start editing it.
You saw I tried an
autocomplete, that didn't work.
The reason for that is that
we don't have a VS Code
extension installed that
understands this file.
So we can head over to VS Code extensions
and search for Prisma.
There's an insider and a stable version.
I prefer to stable
version, so we click on it.
And over here, you remember
that from the Svelte extension
that we installed earlier
under manage, if you
say, add to Gitpod YAML,
that will ensure that everybody
who opens this project
on a gitpod workspace will have
the Prisma extension installed by default.
Just to show you it ended up over here
under VS Code extensions
within the Gitpod YAML file.
Currently, we don't have it installed,
I just added it to the file.
So we can either start a
new workspace with that new
configuration file or easier way
is to hit the quick fix link
and say install prisma extension.
That doesn't take very long
and once it's installed,
then the line will disappear.
And now if we go back to our schema file
and we use autocomplete, control space,
we now have access to the
properties that we need to define.
One more thing I'd like to do
for future us and our
colleagues, in a file like this,
where it may not be obvious
where we can find more
information about it.
I'd like to just add a comment,
learn more about this file in the docs
and the URL for that is HTTPs
and pris.ly/d/prisma.schema,
quickly double check that
there's no spelling mistakes.
That looks good, all the
information you need in here.
As I said, the Prisma team
did a fantastic job
documenting everything.
So we'll drop that.
And what we can do now is
define our datasource, datasource DB,
and then the values inside,
lets use autocomplete,
it asks for the provider
and the provider we want
is in our case Postgres.
So we have other options here as well.
We already know we install
the Postgres database,
so we'll choose Postgres
and still something missing,
which is the URL.
The URL is depending on your environment,
so generally speaking,
the format of a Postgres URL
is Postgres colon slash slash,
and then the username that
you created in your database.
In our case, because we
use the Gitpod Docker image
as our foundation for the
developer environment,
I know the username is Gitpod,
and then @ the host name,
so localhost in our case,
slash the name of the
database we want to create.
So this in theory works just fine
in our local development
environment or here on Gitpod.
But when we deploy to production,
this is no longer going to
work because that path is going
to be something completely different
that we need to set dynamically.
So luckily the Prisma
schema file allows us
to use something called ENV.
So this is a way for us to use
an environment variable
instead of a hard-coded string.
And what we want to do
here is DATABASE_URL.
So with that, we now have
to set the DATABASE_URL
in our development environment.
One way to do that is as you
also see in the docs here,
we could create a .env file at the root
and configure the
environment variable there.
Another way since we're
using Gitpod is we can go
to the Gitpod YAML file, and in our tasks,
we currently have one terminal
indicated by the one dash here.
So here we can just add env
and then say DATABASE_URL.
And the value of that is
that Postgres localhost URL
that we defined before.
So now we know that when
we start a new workspace,
the terminal with the server
will have that DATABASE_URL available,
so that's pretty neat,
that's all we need for the time being.
Let's go back to the Prisma schema,
so the schema.prisma file,
we have to configure a
few more things here.
The next thing is we need a generator.
As I mentioned briefly,
when I introduced Prisma,
based on our database schema,
Prisma will generate a JavaScript
slash TypeScript client
that we can load into our API
and then interact with the database.
So what'd we do here, we specify
a few parameters for that.
So we do generator client and
bunch of things it's asking for,
we'll start with the provider.
And the value is, there's
only one prisma-client-js.
The other thing we want to do
is specify the binaryTargets.
And that is important because
as you see in the description,
it specifies the operating system on which
the Prisma client will run to
ensure binary compatibility
of the query engine.
A lot of text, what it
really means is, right now,
the Gitpod developer environment uses
a Ubuntu operating system.
If you follow along in
your local computer,
may you may use Windows,
or you may use MacOS as your environment.
What we're doing here
is we're just indicating
that the binaryTargets we
want the client to generate
is whatever, I'll show you,
whatever the native environment is.
That's all the documented,
but native means in this case,
it will generate it for Ubuntu,
when we deploy to Vercel,
it will generate it for
whatever operating system
Vercel uses to run our API.
So that gives us the peace of mind,
we don't have to worry about anymore.
Lastly, and arguably, most importantly,
we have to define a database schema.
And what that means is if we
look at the API just real quick
source, routes, todos _API,
remember that todos
array that we specified?
And at the moment, this is just
an array, a variable living in memory
that needs to move to the
database, so in the database,
we need a table that can
hold all the todo-items
that we add to our web application.
So we are lucky in so far that we have
already a Todo TypeScript definition.
So let's head over there
and look at what we defined.
That definition is under src global.d.ts.
And you can see, we have a
UID, created at, a text a done.
So let's copy that
so that we make sure we don't
forget any of the properties.
And we move back to the schema.
And then what we define
here is called a model
and the name of the model,
you can roughly think of that
as the table name as well.
So that would be todo,
and within that, we can
specify the properties.
So for now, let's just paste
our TypeScript definitions.
And now we just have to update the syntax
to match the syntax used
within our schema Prisma file.
That's pretty straightforward,
so we do it all in one go.
We remove the colons,
replace them with a space.
And then the next thing is that
String is a capital S, so is it here,
so is Boolean and date is
actually more specific a DateTime
and we also need to drop
all these semi-colons.
And with that, we are almost ready to go.
It's still complaining about an error.
And it's saying that each
model must have at least one
unique criteria that has only
required fields, blah, blah,
either mark or field ID.
Now, what that means
is remember in the API
source, routes, todos, index.json.
Remember we created that UID
and we used Date.now, which
as I mentioned earlier,
never ever do that in a
production environment.
And we even left a note saying that,
replace that with the
UID from the database,
nice spelling mistake, okay, so
at this point we have
access to the database.
We are literally defining
the schema right now,
so we can now drop this line.
We no longer need to create it.
And what we do instead is we remove that,
and in our schema, we
can tell the database
to use that UID field as the unique ID.
And in Prisma, we can
use the @id for that,
and also we want to
give it a default value.
And the default value,
we can use a function
to create that global unique identifier
based on the cuid spec, so I'll use that.
And with it,
every time we create a todo
record in the database,
the database will automatically
add a default value
to our UID, and we will provide
the created at, text, and done.
Okay, that was a bit of
configuration here, now,
the error we received in
the console before was that
this file didn't exist, so
we couldn't start the server.
Now there's one more thing we need to do.
Remember in the Gitpod YAML
we specified the DATABASE_URL
as Postgres localhost blah blah?
If we were to commit these changes
and start a new Gitpod workspace,
that would be available,
but at the moment, if
we do echo DATABASE_URL,
we actually, we have it because
I think I already ran it,
but that, we have to make
sure this environment
where it was to set, so we do have it,
and now let's try to clear
this and run npx prisma studio.
Give that a second.
It is saying that services
available in port 5555.
We can close that preview
here, but if we open a browser,
it opens up the Prisma
Studio and you can see that
it shows us all the models we defined,
so in this case Todo model,
that's the only one we defined
in our schema down here.
So if we click on that,
it gives an error, unable to run script.
Let's have a look invalidate, blah, blah,
and then here the table
public todo does not exist
in the current database.
That is true because we never
actually created that table.
The only thing we did
was we defined the model,
but we never told Prisma
to create that table in the database.
We could go to the database
and manually run a SQL query
that, you know, create
table with these fields.
But the whole point of using Prisma
is that we can automate all that.
So let's stop our studio with control C
and I will show you how we can ensure
that the database is always up to date.
So the command we can
use to make this work is
again, we use npx prisma migrate dev
let's see what happens, basically migrate,
is going to look at the Prisma file
it's going to see that
there's a todo record.
And when it sees that record,
it will then go to the
database and check whether
the database matches what's
configured in our schema.
And let's see what happens
at the moment, just FYI,
the database is empty.
So there's going to be a
discrepancy between what we expect
the database to look
like with the todo table
and the empty environment in the database,
let's run that command.
Alright, so let's walk
through that together.
Prisma schema loaded from
this file, excellent.
Datasource db is Postgres, mhm very good.
Schemas, public and localhosts, 5432,
that looks all good.
And now it's noticing that
the database doesn't match the schema.
So it is asking us to provide
a name for the migration.
So at this point we really
just initialized the database.
So let's call it init.
We say init and hit enter.
All right, let's give this a second,
and then we're going to go back
and review everything that
was going on here, it's a lot.
We specified init as the
name of the migration.
And then it says the
following immigrations
have been created and applied
from the new schema changes.
Something in a migrations
directory, blah, blah, blah.
And then your database is
now in sync with your schema.
Let's look at that file, look
at this, there's a SQL file.
Prisma migrations.
There's a directory here and a SQL file.
If we look at that file,
oh my, look at this,
it generated the SQL that is necessary
to run against the database
in order to create that table
with the necessary columns,
such as the text, the
Boolean, the done, the UID.
It also created some constraints
on the primary key being the UID field.
That's incredible.
All done for us, all we
had to do was just specify
what we wanted to look like.
Good, let's go back to the terminal
and see what else went on here.
And then it says that your database is now
in sync with your schema.
So not only did Prisma
generate the SQL file,
it also ran it against the database.
Very cool, we had literally
nothing to do here.
It just did it all for us.
And then it ran generate,
and it did a bunch of npm stuff here,
blah blah, blah blah, all good.
And at the end it says,
generated Prisma Client to
node modules @prisma/client
That is something we're
going to look at afterwards.
For now, just note that in this directory,
we now have a client that
we can use in JavaScript
that is fully aware of the
schema of our database.
It knows about this todo-item.
There are functions available
to us that we can leverage
to find, update, and delete records.
We'll get to that in a second.
For now, I want to go back
and clear the terminal
and then go back up and run
that Prisma Studio again.
I'll take a second,
I'll close to a preview
and we can ignore that because
we already have the tab open.
And if we go back to
the, reload that page,
let's have a look.
We are now looking at the todo table
and you can see there's
a UID, created at, text.
We could add a record from here
and go ahead, change the date, add a text,
change the value of the done
and commit that, we'll do that later,
but for now, just know that Prisma Studio
gives you a way to access your database
through a web browser.
So we'll discard the changes.
One more thing I want to do.
Anybody who works on this
application sooner or later
is likely going to need access
to that Prisma Studio, but
they may not know the
command npx prisma studio,
and we want to make this so
easy for them that they don't
even have to run the command,
again, we can automate it.
Let's imagine we start a Gitpod workspace.
And in one terminal, we run npm install
and fire up the web application.
In another terminal, we
automatically start Prisma Studio
and then we open the preview
in a new browser tab of Prisma Studio.
Let's see how we can do that,
just like we configured
the init task here.
We can create another one
and we don't have any init for that.
We only have a command
and command is simply,
npx prisma studio,
and we also need to specify
the environment variable
so that Prisma Studio knows
how to connect to our database
using the DATABASE_URL
environment variable.
And with that, it will
automatically open two terminals
at start up of the workspace.
And lastly, it will start
a new service on port 5555.
So let's configure that port down here
by saying four times 5, 5555
and on open, we want to open a
browser window automatically.
So we will have two browser
windows open one for
the application and the other
one for the Prisma Studio.
There's a lot going on in this file.
Generally in this PR we
made a bunch of changes.
I think at this point,
we can go ahead and review and
then almost ready to commit
and start working on the
integration with the API.
I think the, let me
just have a quick look.
Yep so there's one more
thing we need to do
before we move on.
Remember how we manually
created the migration,
we ran Prisma migrate dev?
We can automate a little bit more.
Let's assume somebody starts
this developer environment.
And at the very first time,
their database is always going to be empty
because every environment is
going to be built from scratch.
So in order to make sure
the database is always
in sync with our schema,
that we specify here,
we want to make sure that
that Prisma Migrate dev
command automatically runs
before we start our SvelteKit application.
So that's an easy fix.
All we need to do is open
the package.json file.
We already have a dev script.
Now in order to run something
before the dev script,
we can either come here and say,
prisma migrate dev && Svelte-Kit dev.
However if we want to run more commands
before we start the dev server,
this starts to get really
hard to understand.
So here's a little
trick that NPM provides.
We can take that and then
take the name of our command
and create a new command
or a new script called pre
and the name of this one
here, let me show you,
in this case, we are talking
about, we want a dev script.
We want to run something
before the dev script runs.
So we can say predev,
which means it runs before the dev script.
And we wanna run prisma migrate dev.
This is nothing, you know, no matching,
that's just a regular NPM feature.
And with that now every time
we start our dev server,
if we came here and ran
NPM run dev, we hit editor,
you can see that Prisma
Migrate dev runs first.
And then it starts to development server
and our application is up and running.
So let's have a really
quick look at the output.
Prisma Migrate dev
same output as before it
loaded the schema file,
connected to the database,
but now it says already in sync,
no schema change or pending
migration was found.
That's because of the
migration we ran before.
The schema, our model here
is already available in the database.
That's why it doesn't run anything.
The next time we start
a workspace on Gitpod,
this will not be the case,
the database will be empty.
And Prisma will a automatically
run our migrations in order,
based on the date that's
in the folder name here.
So with that,
we have a lot of code that
is ready to get committed.
And that's exactly what
we're going to do next.
Time to head over to the source
control and do a quick recap
of what happened, make sure
we don't have any bugs.
So we added a new terminal
that runs npx prisma studio.
We have the new environment variables,
and we also open a
browser for Prisma Studio.
We added the VS Code extension
so everybody gets the same
experience when they edit
the schema.prisma file.
We added a predev script,
so that our web application
always has the database up and running.
And the latest changes are applied
before we start the dev server, so predev.
We added to Prisma CLI
as a dev dependency,
and you can see it also
automatically added a Prisma client
dependency, that was added
automatically when we ran
the migrate command the first time,
so that we can then use @prisma/client
in our code to access a generated client
to connect to the database.
We'll see that in a couple of minutes,
the probably most important
file that we worked on
as part of this part is
the schema.prisma file.
We specified that we work
with a Postgres database,
the URL is from an environment
variable and the provider
for the JavaScript client
is prisma-client-js.
And at the bottom we have the Todo model.
And this is where we now
generate a UID automatically
with a cuid specification.
So it'll be a random generated ID
that we'll see in just a second.
Lastly we made a small tweak to the API
and the tweak was that we removed
our very bad workaround here
to create a UID because now the
database will do that for us
and we no longer have to do that manually.
So with that, let's go ahead
and commit these changes.
So add Prisma & init migration.
We can commit this and
create a pull request here.
Let's call this use Prisma ORM
and we will close issue number 15.
Now we only just configured
to Prisma Client,
the CLI so far and set up the migrations.
We have a little bit more
work to do to update the API
and leverage all the
configuration we put in place.
So we'll make this a draft and we go ahead
and create the branch and the
pull request up on GitHub.
That only takes a couple seconds.
And then once it's ready,
we can go ahead and close
the Prisma Studio here
and let's go have a
look, see if that worked.
It doesn't seem to have pushed that
let's oh, it's pending, okay,
let's see what's going on.
I think we can have a look.
Review no matching.
Okay, maybe what we can do,
let's just give it a second,
maybe there might be some hiccup here,
it seems to be loading.
Nope, maybe that was it.
Not yet.
Let's cancel that here in
the console and have a look
what's going on.
What if we push manually,
maybe we'll get it around.
It could be some GitHub issues.
We had something going
on yesterday as well.
All right, that created the branch
and we should be able to create
that pull request manually,
that's no problem at all.
Call this use Prisma ORM.
You don't need any of that,
just close issue number
15, I believe it was.
And then create a pull request.
There is many ways that lead us to Rome.
So all good.
We want to convert it to a draft
and keep working on it before
we mark this ready for review.
Good with that,
we can go ahead and shut
this workspace down,
close the tab, and from here,
we'll now move on and start
to use that Prisma Client that
got generated for us and use
it in the API so that we can
then persistent read and
update items in the database.
With the Prisma configured
in the environment
and the studio automatically starting up,
it's now time to update our
API in order to leverage
all the work we just did.
So firing up a new
workspace to get us going.
And then we will also
see for the first time
how the updates we've made
to the Gitpod YAML file
will impact a startup of a new workspace.
So it will start two new browser tabs,
one for the application preview,
just like we've always had.
And then a second one
that is going to show
the Prisma Studio web application,
where we have access to the database
to look at tables and
the content of the table.
So we can validate that
the API properly persists
the changes that we made in the frontend.
So this is a fairly
straightforward part of the course.
All we will do is update the API file
and replace that todos array
that we've had so far with functions
to interact with the database.
Just giving Gitpod here
another couple of seconds
to pull down our base Docker image.
And then we should be off to the races.
That sometimes takes a
couple seconds more than
on average, but ultimately
it is still super convenient
to have all that just automated
so anybody who works on our
project gets the benefits
of the work we did throughout this course
without fully understanding
what needs to be installed
and what needs to be done.
All right, we got our two browser tabs.
One is the application,
one is Prisma Studio with the Todo model,
that's currently empty nothing in here
and we get all of this preview
data we can safely ignore.
Good.
Let's get going, so down
here in the terminal,
you notice that on the right side,
there are now two terminals.
The second one that's
currently highlighted
is the Prisma Studio.
And the first one is the one
that runs our web
application on port 3000.
So you can navigate between the two
if you want to start or
stop any of the services.
Okay so the main file we're
going to work with today
is source, routes, todos, _api.
Now we moved all that code
into this file a while ago,
and now we're going to actually
see some benefits of that
because any interactions we've
had with that todos array
is now consolidated into that one file.
So now that we're going to replace that
with the database table we created.
We can just update to code below here
to leverage calls to the database.
So when we ran the migrate dev command
from Prisma, so in the
package.json our predev script,
prisma migrate dev, that
generated our Prisma Client.
If you recall, in the terminal,
if we scroll up just a bit,
it generated the,
it used the migration and
applied it to the database
because we started a new
workspace, the database was empty,
and it also generated
that Prisma client into
node_modules @prisma/client.
Okay, now that client,
we will see that in a second
is fully aware of our database model.
And we can import that because
it's in the node_modules
directory, we can input it like
we would any other package.
So at the root of our
file here at the very top,
we can add a new line saying import
Prisma from @prisma/client.
And we can then use that
instead of, you know,
todo.push, for example,
we can use that new Prisma import.
Now there is one gotcha.
and that is related to
a temporary workaround
we need to implement until
everybody moves to ES modules.
So that line import
Prisma from Prisma client
works well in our environment,
but once we deploy to Vercel,
we'll need to import
this slightly different.
Long story, there's
some information online,
but we basically want to extract that
for the time being into
separate file and allow us
to deal with that workaround.
So just bear with me as
we go to source, lib,
and we create a new file
here called prisma.ts.
And within that,
we basically implement
the loading mechanism
of both approaches,
one that works on our
development environment
and one that works on
Vercel, and then we will use
that in our codes, in the API
file so that we don't have
to deal with any if else
statements and whatnot over there.
So the way we do that is we import Prisma,
but also we import star as PrismaAll
from the Prisma Client.
So as I mentioned,
depending on whether we
run on our environment here
or in Vercel, this one,
or this one will be
undefined, one of the two,
and it's the opposite way,
depending on the environment we're on.
So all we need to do now is we
say the actual Prisma Client
is either Prisma if it's available,
so TypeScript, we can use question mark.
So Prisma Client or alternatively,
PrismaAll again, if it's
available, dot PrismaClient.
And then we see export
default, the PrismaClient.
And now with that, we don't
have to worry anywhere else
in the code, whether this
approach loaded the correct client
or this approach did with
the star as Prisma Client,
all because in this line here,
we basically just pick
either this or the other one
and export to Prisma Client.
With that in our API,
we can simply say import the PrismaClient
from remember the
shortcut with $lib/prisma.
And now we can use that Prisma
client just like we would
if we imported it regularly
according to the Prisma docs.
A small little workaround
that we need to make this work
on the local environment
or in Gitpod here,
as well as on Vercel.
Now, the probably most exciting part
of this entire course is that
we can finally get rid of this todos array
and no longer the todo items in memory
and lose them every time
we restart the server.
So let's celebrate by dropping
this, hooray, is gone,
we'll never have to worry about it again.
Instead what are we going to do
is we create a new instance
of that PrismaClient.
Let's call it, Prisma
equals new PrismaClient.
And now you'll see the power
of Prisma in just a second,
if we take this and
we start to go through all the places
where we access currently
that array, and we replace it
with a call to the database,
let's check this out.
So here we want to
fetch all the todo-items
that are persisted in the
database, so let's look at this.
We use Prisma dot and now the autocomplete
show us a todo property
with that todo, we can then say find many.
And you can see there's code
examples right in the docs.
So that get all todos is
const todos equals await
Prisma todo findMany.
So we'll do findMany.
We call that and this returns a promise.
So we'll say await and we
make this an async function.
Unbelievably cool.
You can tell I'm really
excited about this.
This is such a game changer
to how we've developed with
or interacted with database
from JavaScript in the last 20
years, Prisma really sets the
bar high with that approach.
That's literally all we
need to do, and as you saw,
we had full TypeScript
support for our todo-item.
If we were to go into the Prisma schema
and start to add more
models or update the model,
every time we start a dev server,
the new client will be generated
and we would have access
to these new fields and functions
and everything immediately
through TypeScript autocomplete here.
Okay.
The next thing is we want
to create a new todo-item.
So far we just set todos.push,
now, this is no longer the way to do it.
The new way to do it is that
we say await prisma todo,
and guess what, create, ah, so cool.
And within that, we have autocomplete,
which asks us to provide a data property.
We will happily do that, and as part
of that data property, you
can now see that it's asking
for created at, done,
text and an optional UID.
Again, fully autogenerated
because of our model.
And we know what these values
are, so let's go ahead.
Top to bottom, created at
is the data dot created,
oops created, what did
we call it created at?
And we know this is a date,
so we'll tell TypeScript that.
And then we have done,
which comes from data.done,
that's a Boolean.
All right.
And we have the text, which
is data.text as string.
And with that,
we now have a new item
created in the database.
So that push is no longer needed.
Now here's one thing we have to change.
And the reason we need to change here is
so far our post endpoint
added to UID right here.
This is no longer the case,
but when we add an item to the database,
the response to the frontend
has to include the UID,
or basically it has to
include the todo-item
with the same data that
we have in the database.
So we could, you know,
use Prisma to go fetch the
newly created item somehow.
But the better way is
that the create function
actually returns the created item for us.
So we can just say, body
equals and drop this part here.
Now we create the item in the database
and when that's complete,
the response we get back from the database
is newly created item
that contains the UID.
Moving on, let's see how
we can delete an item.
This doesn't exist, but we can say
await Prisma.todo dot,
let's see, do we have a delete?
We have a delete right here.
And what do we want to do?
In the docs, It says that
it wants a where clause,
where we can specify which
element we want to delete.
All right, let's have a look.
We'll pass in an object
with a where clause.
And it's suggesting that we provide a UID.
Let's do that.
We know that the UID we want to delete
is the one we get from
the request params.UID.
And that will take care
of removing that element.
We can apply whatever response
we get back to the body
if we wanted to.
That's all good.
Lastly let's look at how we can patch
an object in the database.
So none of that is needed anymore.
As well as the body, we
will do that in one line,
body equals await prisma todo
and then guess what,
there's an update function.
And the update function wants an object,
let's have a look data and where,
okay, we are already
familiar with the where.
So we can just use that.
We know it wants a UID, which we have.
And also it wants a data property,
which presumably is going
to be the data we want
to update for the given
todo-item we selected up here.
So data, we have data,
text, and todo done.
So let's say done, and the
value for that is data.done.
And the other thing is the text.
And that is data.text
that we want to put there.
Okay, now we don't need
that code from before,
we don't need that.
That looks good.
And what we can do now is go have a look
at what this looks like
in the user interface.
So first of all, let's go all
the way to the bottom here.
This looks good, seems to compile.
If we switch over to the application,
let's inspect the network tab.
So here we'll add a first item,
that seemed to have worked,
something happened, at
least we show it in the UI.
Let's look at the requests.
Todos JSON, all right.
We sent the text, and in
return, we got an item.
There's our new UID
generated by the database.
Definitely a lot more unique
than our timestamp that we had before.
Again, a reminder, do not use
Date.now as a UID, never ever.
So very cool, let's look at
Prisma Studio to double check
if that item actually got persisted.
So heading over to the Prisma Studio tab,
and there's a little refresh icon, voila,
we have our very first todo-item
persisted in the database,
which means that we could
now stop our server.
Let's do that.
Stop our frontend server
and start it back up,
let all these scripts run
and do what they need to do.
All right.
There's a new preview, and guess what,
it shows our item still
here because we fetched it
from the database.
Let's have a look at the done
column, it's currently false
just to make sure updating
works as well, we check it.
We come back and refresh,
and this now says true.
And lastly, for good measure,
first item persist in the Prisma Studio.
First item is now persisted.
What a wonderful time to be
a full stack web developer.
So many tools that make life so easy.
And we now have TypeScript
support basically
from the database all
the way to the frontend.
And if we were ever to change anything,
TypeScript would yell at
us right away telling us
to update our code and match
the new code we want to implement.
Okay, let's close the Prisma Studio,
close out preview, and commit
the changes that we made.
We finally were able to
drop that todos array
that we now replace with
database calls, and you can see,
we have the Prisma instance
of the Prisma client,
and that now autocompletes
our todos and the functions
we can call on that todo object.
With that, let's go ahead and commit that.
We're now using the Prisma client.
All right, let's commit.
Yes.
And then since we already
have a pull request open,
we can just sync our changes and let
GitPod send that up to GitHub.
And here we go, we now
got that code in here.
And that marks the end
of that pull request.
So ready for review, ask our
colleagues to have a look.
They can go through,
see all the changes we've
made to the different files
as part of this pull request,
our migration autogenerated
and our file here with the schema
where we defined what
the table looks like.
And then the update to the API,
where we replaced the in memory array
of todo-items with calls to the database
to assist and update, all that.
Wonderful and with that,
we can go ahead and
merge that pull request,
and then move on and start
to look at some more things
in order to deploy this
application to production
merge it and delete the branch.
Good, that's all cleaned up.
That environment is no
longer needed, we'll stop it,
get rid of it.
And that marks the end of
this issue that we worked on.
What an exciting time.
We now have our full stack application
that is running perfectly fine
in a local developer environment
or in a Gitpod developer environment.
We have a frontend API and the database,
everything is connected,
everything communicates and
what's missing in this course,
and to wrap it up is in order
to use that application,
we need to deploy it to production.
So for that, we have
two tasks ahead of us.
The first one is to deploy a
Postgres database to Railway.
And the second task is to deploy the API
and web app to Vercel.
We will start with the database
so that when we deploy the API,
it will be able to connect
to the database right away.
All right, first things
first, we had over to issues.
We have two issues left.
One is to deploy a database on Railway.
That's the one we want to work on.
So we fire up a new Gitpod
developer environment.
And once that is ready,
we will be able to make
a couple of changes
just so that when we deploy
the application to Vercel,
everything works and is in place
the way we expect it to be.
So here is our developer
environment spinning up
and it fires up Prisma Studio,
which we don't need right now.
And our web application preview,
we don't need that either.
So all we really need here
is the package.json file
where are we going to
make a couple of changes.
So we can cancel that Prisma Studio,
we can control C and switch
to the other terminal here.
This is where our application runs.
We'll cancel that as well for now.
And what we now need to do
is in the package.json file,
you remember, in development,
before we start the dev server,
we created a predev script
where we run the prisma
migrate dev command.
This helps ensure that
the Postgres database
is always up to date with
the latest migrations
that exists under Prisma migrations.
Now this, as the command says
is for development, but when
we deploy to production,
there might be changes
to the database schema
that we have to apply to the
production database as well.
And in that case, we don't
want to run Prisma migrate dev.
We want to run a production
level command for that.
Now, when do we want to run that command?
When we deploy to Vercel,
the Vercel adapter for
SvelteKit will automatically
execute the build script.
So, or in other words,
Vercel will actually
execute the build script
and the SvelteKit command
line interface here,
that will then execute the Vercel adapter
and deploy the application.
And we'll talk about
that when we deploy the
web application, but the build
script is something where
we want to run that command
to update the database and migrate
if there are any migrations.
The problem is we could run
that build script in our
local environment as well,
so this would be confusing.
We wouldn't want to update the database
by running the build script locally.
So luckily there is a
script that we can leverage.
So if we add a new script
to our package.json file,
and we call it vercel-build.
This script is only executed
when we deploy to Vercel.
And at that time,
this is the perfect place
to upgrade our database.
The way we do it is we use Prisma,
prisma migrate, just like
we did in the predev script,
but instead of dev, we use deploy
and then once that's done
and the database is updated,
we can say && npm run build.
So that Vercel then kicks in,
first deploys the database
and then runs the build script
for the web application.
So let's quickly run that build script.
So the one we're going to
execute here npm run build,
let's run that in our environment
to see what actually happens
when we deploy to Vercel.
So npm run build.
And it is now telling us
that it could not detect
a supported production environment.
And that's because we are not
actually running on Vercel.
So because in our Svelte config,
we use that adapter-auto,
it tries to determine
where we are executing
this command from.
And because it doesn't see
this environment as being
Vercel, it automatically
basically gives us that error.
Now I spend a lot of time in
the SvelteKit source code,
so I know that if we
temporary export a variable
called Vercel, and we give
that, let's say a value of true.
And then we run that and
NPM run build script again,
it goes through the same steps
and now it determined
that we are on Vercel.
So we basically just, you
know, cheated a little bit,
but this is only temporary because I want
to show you what happens on Vercel.
So the first thing we
noticed is that he created
a new directory called
.vercel_build_output,
and within that directory, we
have a functions sub-directory
and then node, and then render.
So that index file here
within the render directory,
this is our generated
code, it's very long,
but that's basically our
generated code for the application
that we developed, our
service side application.
Now, when we deploy to production
in that directory here,
we need to include our schema.prisma file,
that needs to be available
so that when we run
Prisma migrate deploy,
Prisma can find the schema,
and in the schema, you'll remember,
it has the information on how
to connect to the database,
what database it is and
all the schema information.
So because of that, we want
to run a script after we build
that directory, so we can say
here in the package.json file,
postbuild, so it just like we had a predev
that runs before the dev
script, we have a build script
and if we say post build,
that script runs after
the build completes.
So what we want to do here
is copy our prisma/schema.prisma file.
And we want to copy it
into that render directory
that we have here, so let's right click
and see copy relative path.
And then in our copy
command, we'll paste that
so that we go from
.vercel_build_output into here,
functions, node, render,
add a slash at the end.
So that copies the Prisma file.
And there's one more thing we need to copy
that are these binaryTargets.
So they get generated
by default into the node modules directory
and within the node
modules, under the, @prisma,
we have a directory here called engines
and within the engines,
you can see the lib query
engine debian open SSL
something something, that
file or a similar name,
depending on what environment Vercel runs
needs to be copied into that
same functions directory.
So that way we can do that is
just like we copied that Prisma file.
We can add another copy command,
and this time let's go back
node modules, Prisma engines.
We want to copy that relative path.
So from that directory
under @prisma engines,
we want to copy everything
that contains query
and the place we want to copy it to
is the same one here under
the Vercel build output
functions, node, render, we'll
drop that at the end here.
So that makes sure it
copies these query files,
if there's more than one,
it would take all of them,
put them in the right place.
And the other thing we can do just in case
we were to run that build script again,
let's ignore the Vercel
build output because
we don't really want to commit that
that would be bit of a mistake.
So in our gitignore file,
we can say that we do not want
that Vercel build output
committed to Git, so that's good.
All right.
Few things happened here.
We basically just prepared the
application so that on Vercel
it makes sure that it runs prisma migrate
and then npm run build.
And after the build in
the post build script,
we copied the schema to
the function on Vercel
and we also copied query
files to the same directory.
Okay.
Let's go and commit these changes.
So configure,
configure, Vercel build,
and post build scripts.
Alright, and we'll commit that.
Yes.
And we can open a pull request.
So let's call this deploy
database on Railway
and this will close issue number 18.
Alright.
We'll say create, yes please publish.
Let's give that a second to do its job.
And we now have a pull request
that contains these latest changes.
So as part of the deploy
database on Railway,
we also actually have to go
create that database on Railway.
So the way we can do that
is we go to Railway.app.
And even if you're not
logged in, we can just say
start a new project and
provision Postgres database
that runs for a few seconds.
And now we have a
Postgres database running.
You can see that this
is a temporary project
and will be deleted in seven days.
That is because I am an anonymous user.
I will eventually claim
that so that the database
stays online and you see
all this working in action.
For now, this is all we need.
One important aspect is if
you click on the Postgres
link on the left here, we can
then eventually see some data.
But for the time being,
if you click on connect,
you can see our Postgres connection URL
listed right here.
This is something that we're going
to need when we deploy to Vercel.
So let's just keep this
browser tab open and we will
come to that and copy it in a second.
For now, though, we've done the work
that is necessary to deploy to Vercel.
And we have a few scripts
here that are needed
to make sure the database
in production is up to date
with the latest schema and we can deploy.
So we are good to go and
can merge this pull request
into the main branch, drop the branch,
and go ahead and shut down our workspace.
Alrighty, and we can now go back to issues
where we have one left,
that's deploying the application to Vercel
and then configure it
so that it can connect
to the database we just deployed,
let's go and do that now.
Last step of this course,
we have to go ahead and deploy the web app
and the API onto Vercel,
and if we compare to the architecture
this is the piece right here,
where we have to go and
deploy that and then make sure
it can properly connect
from Prisma to the database
we just deployed a little while ago.
Okay.
Here is the best news that
you can possibly imagine.
When it comes to deploying
a SvelteKit application
to, at the time of this recording,
Vercel, Netlify, or CloudFlare,
you don't have to do any code changes.
The reason for that is that
in the Svelte config file,
we have an adapter that is being imported
that's called adapter-auto,
and that is used here.
As you recall, from the very beginning,
adapters are used by SvelteKit
to prepare the application
for the different environments.
So if you deploy to Netlify CloudFlare
or Vercel at this point in time,
then you don't have to
make any code changes.
If you're curious what the
latest supported environments are
head over to kit.svelte.dev/docs,
scroll down in the navigation
until you get to adapters
where it says supported environment,
and you have a list here
of supported environments.
So the three are here, we
are deploying to Vercel.
So we are in luck and we don't have
to actually make any code changes.
The only thing we have
to do is log into Vercel.
So make sure we create an
account, pick the right team,
and then you can say new project.
And from the screen,
you select the organization
or the account,
and then the project you want to deploy,
in my case, that's the full
stack web development project.
So I can import it.
You can see that it
automatically recognizes this
as a SvelteKit project.
So it analyzed my code in
Github and it saw that this
is a SvelteKit app, no need
for me to make any changes.
However, if we look at
the environment variables,
there is one thing that
we want to configure,
which is our DATABASE_URL
that we configured locally or on Gitpod
as part of the developer environment.
In production, we also have
to specify a DATABASE_URL,
so that Prisma knows how
to connect to the database.
The value that we want to add here
comes from the Railway.app,
remember we created a
Postgres database here
and it has a Postgres connection URL.
So we want to copy that.
And over in Vercel at
this as the DATABASE_URL,
we say add, and with that,
that environment variable is
available for Prisma to pick up
and we then can say deploy.
And you can see down here,
it starts to build four seconds ago.
It's running all the necessary scripts
in order to build the
SvelteKit application.
It will also run the post
build scripts that we specified
so that the database
will be populated with
the table that is needed as
well as all the other things
that are necessary to make this work.
Lots going on.
We can see here that one
migration found in the migrations.
So it applies that.
This is happening because we specified
that Vercel build script, which
runs Prisma migrate deploy.
So this is why it said, Hey,
I'm running this migration
and applied to the database.
It does a bunch of other stuff.
There's two warnings we can
safely ignore that's okay.
And eventually we are
uploading the build cache
to the server.
And I have seen this page getting stuck
at certain times, and it
looks like this is one
of those days, so this has
been running for a minute,
which is a bit longer than it
usually takes, which is fine.
What we can do is instead of waiting here
for that to never finish,
we can just go back to the top
and click the back button here.
That brings us to that page
where we can input a project.
So if we just click at
the top on our team,
we can now see that we have
that project configured here.
And if we open it up,
we get a nice little preview
of our todo application.
And over here, we have
the URL available to us.
So if we click on that,
you can see that
full-stack-web-development.vercel.app
is our production environment.
And if we come in here and
we add an item saying, first,
we can enter this,
hit enter and see what
happens in the database.
Let's do that one more time.
There we go.
And now we have the first
item added to the database.
If we head over to Railway
and we select the data tab
in our Postgres database,
we can see that Prisma
created a migrations table, that's okay.
Prisma will manage that,
nothing for us to worry about.
More importantly we can see the todo table
that now contains our first todo item.
If we were to go back to production,
mark this as done, and
then head over here,
you see that this done
column changed to true.
And we could go ahead
and add a second item
and even a third item.
This works just like it did locally.
And we could even go ahead
and remove certain items
that would then reflect
what we see in the database.
First and third, true and false,
true, false, first and third.
What an exciting time,
truly how we deploy web applications
as a full stack developer
has dramatically improved
over the last couple of years,
thanks to amazing companies,
such as Vercel and Railway development
of these applications as well
is dramatically changing.
Thanks to developer environments
in the cloud by using Gitpod.io.
With that, we can head back to our issue.
And one thing we want to do here
is take that URL and
leave a note saying that
application deployed to this URL.
We leave that comment and we can go ahead
and close that issue.
This complete the coding
part of this course.
Amazing work, congratulations
on making it all the way through.
You now have a full stack web
application available here,
built with Svelte, SvelteKit,
using Prisma to connect
to a Postgres database.
And all of that is deployed
to Vercel and Railway.
Excellent, congratulations,
you have developed a full
stack web application,
deployed it to Vercel, deployed
the database to Railway.app
and connected all these pieces together
so that this is now a
really good foundation
to build anything on top of it.
Let's quickly recap what we've done
and how you can move on and
do more features, development
on that, or add other things
you might be interested in.
First off we created a
user interface with Svelte
that was really the basic foundation
that we needed for the web app
in order to create
todo-items, update them,
delete them and display all of it.
We then moved on and created
a SvelteKit backend API.
There was a REST API with endpoints
to create, read, update,
and delete todo-items.
We used REST or HTTP to
connect to that backend
and returned JSON data
to display in the UI.
At the very beginning,
we started off building
that application with JavaScript disabled.
So we used the regular HTML form elements
and post requests to submit the data.
We then enhanced our
forms with Svelte actions,
which allows us to intercept
the HTML form submission,
and instead do an Ajax request.
So we don't have to reload the entire page
for every action that we do.
So we now have a front end
that works with JavaScript.
It also works with no JavaScript
enabled in the browser.
In the second part of the course,
we went ahead and used Prisma,
an ORM to let us connect
to a Postgres database.
This really simplified the
entire integration with
the database, we did not write
a single line of SQL code.
All we really did was
using generated TypeScript
and JavaScript in order to
connect to the database,
we were reading data,
updating data all by simply
just calling functions
within our JavaScript
and TypeScript files.
Lastly when we had all this working
in a developer environment,
we then deployed the web
application to Vercel
and we deployed the Postgres
database to Railway.app
where it is now running
so that we can connect
to it from our production environment.
When we developed the project,
we did all of that in a
Gitpod developer environment.
So you notice that for every
task that we worked on,
we started a new GitPod workspace.
And this is the concept
of what ephemeral developer
environments or are all about.
You start in an environment,
it's fully automated,
it started our developer
server, installed dependencies,
and we then basically
could just write our code,
stop the environment,
and for the next task,
we opened a new environment to
do the work we wanted to do.
Amazing achievement,
congratulations, once again,
this is a full stack
application that you can use
as a foundation to do further work
and build your own projects.
Let's spend a few minutes
talking about what's next.
How can you further enhance
the application in order to
deepen your knowledge about
the technologies that we used
and the different
providers where we deployed
the application as well as the database?
The first thing I want to bring
up as a suggestion to look
into is trying to deploy
the web application
and the API endpoints to a
different hosting provider.
As part of the course, we used
Vercel and I introduced you
to the adaptor concept of SvelteKit.
So an easy kind of next steps
would be to maybe deploy this
entire application to Netlify
or CloudFlare or any other
hosting provider that you
might be familiar with.
So this would be a good next steps,
minimal code changes in
order to get it resolved.
So you would get some quick
success by looking into this.
Another suggestion would be to play around
and try to use a different database.
Maybe you are not familiar with Postgres.
Maybe you are more familiar with MySQL,
try to change the database
to MySQL instead of Postgres.
Read up about the Prisma configuration,
how you can change that and, you know,
try Railway or try Planet Scale
or any other database provider.
See if we can connect the
API to that database system
and learn about that part
of the backend development
in this entire stack.
Lastly, a third suggestion
to look into might be
to enhance the project.
Right now, this is a very
simple todo application
where everybody who is using it,
they'll get the same list of todo-items.
Now it would be more helpful if
for example, there were people
you could assign items to,
and of course, if you
just had your own lists,
so add some kind of authentication
to the system where,
you have to log in with
GitHub or maybe email address
and password, and then
you could add due dates
where you say that this
item is due by Friday.
So try to learn how to
persist that in the database.
And overall this could
really be an application
that you can build out as
part of your learning journey
for the full stack
application development.
Alternatively, you could
take what we built,
use the concepts and build
something completely different.
I would love to hear what you come up with
based on the course, so do
reach out and let me know.
Otherwise let's wrap this
up with a few more words
about the overall course.
With that thank you so
much for taking your time
and working through this course.
It was a great pleasure
putting this together,
and I hope this gives
you a good foundation
for your next project
when you want to build a
full stack web application
with a frontend, API,
and the backend database.
You can find me on Twitter @MikeNikles,
I'm also available on my
website at mikenikles.com
where I have blog posts,
I have links to open source
projects that I work on.
So do check these out and also
have a look at www.gitpod.io,
the underlying developer
environment that we use throughout
the course where we spin
up a fully automated
developer environment for each given task.
And we then shut it down when we're done
and move on to a new one
the next time we work on an issue.
Do check out these links.
Let me know if there's
anything I can help you with,
I would love to hear from
you, if you have feedback,
please let me know.
I'd love to make a full up
course or maybe something else
to help spread the knowledge
and let people learn from
the experience that I have.